DOCTOR QUIRK NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM. THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THE CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA
OUR QUE HAN BERMAN. BIGELOW
BLOOM BURNER **** BATH BONTA
BROUGH BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN DAVID CHIU
CHOI KANSEN CHU COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALY DEEP. EGGMAN
FLORA FONG FRAZIER FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY MASON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER-DOVE KILEY LACKEY
LEVINE LIMóN OWN LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAMOS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO. SALAS
SANTIAGO SMITH STONE TING
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER
. MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN. THE ROAD BOB REVEREND.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A BRIEF
REFLECTION ON LEADERSHIP. A
TRUE LEADER. TWO LEADERS SHOULD
BE THE VERY DEFINITION OF
INTEGRITY AND HONOR THEY SHOULD
BE RESPECTFUL OF HISTORY AND
SERVICE ARE LIVING TIME
CAPSULES CAPSULES OF EXPERIENCE
AND KNOWLEDGE. MOST IMPORTANTLY
THEY SHOULD BE ARE INVISIBLE
GUIDING HANDS UNASSUMING AND
ABSOLUTELY RELIABLE. THESE
QUALITIES EMBODY THE IDEAL. I
DO QUALITIES OF LEADERSHIP. AS
LOW THROUGH SAID A LEADER IS
BEST WHEN PEOPLE BARELY KNOW
THEY EXIST. OPRAH WINFREY SAID
REAL INTEGRITY IS DOING THE
RIGHT THING KNOWING THAT
NOBODY'S GOING TO KNOW WHAT YOU
DID OR NOT. MY ANGELES SAID IN
ORDER TO MENTOR ONE MUST CARE.
AND IN THE WORDS OF MAHATMA
GANDHI THE SIGN OF A GOOD
LEADER IS NOT HOW MANY
FOLLOWERS THEY HAVE. BUT HOW
MANY LEADERS THEY CREATE. FOR
THIRTY LEADERSHIP WE HAVE BEEN
THROUGH THE FORTUNATE. NOW MORE
ME THEM WITH KINDNESS AND
GRATITUDE BEYOND. THANK YOU
REVEREND. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER AS HE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE MISTER JUNCTION
WHERE THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
NOW READY. BEGAN I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE. YEAH. THANK YOU YOU
MAY BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY
SEPTEMBER FOURTH TWENTY
NINETEEN RECENTLY MET AT SEVEN
AM ON OH FRANK BIGELOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FIFTH DISTRICT PRESIDING
SHEER CALDERON MOVES. MR FLOOR
SECONDS OF THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH PRESENTATIONS OF
PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
THERE ARE NO ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY PROCEDURAL MOTIONS MISTER
CALDERON. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION SIR
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY WILL FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE ALLOW SOME
REMEMBERS Là MON EGGMAN STONE
IN BLOOM TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
MEMBER TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHORS PLEASE
MOVE THE FOLLOWING BILL C. BACK
TO FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR SB
SEVENTY. SEVEN FORTY NINE
DORADO. AND ITEM THIRTY THREE
SB FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT ARCHULETA.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE. MEMBERS
BEFORE WE TAKE UP THE BUSINESS
OF THE HOUSE. I WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE AN ANNOUNCEMENT ON BEHALF
OF THE SPEAKER. WE WELCOME THE
PUBLIC TO WITNESS THE EXCHANGE
OF IDEAS ON THIS FLOOR. AND WE
CELEBRATE THE FIRST AMENDMENT'S
GUARANTEES THAT ALLOW EVERYONE
TO EXPRESS THEIR OPINIONS ABOUT
MATTERS BEFORE THIS BODY TO
THEIR REPRESENTATIVES. HOWEVER
THIS BODY EXPECTS TO QUORUM IN
THESE ASSEMBLY CHAMBERS DECORUM
IS NECESSARY TO PROPERLY
CONDUCT THE BUSINESS OF ALL THE
PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THOSE VISITORS TO
ATTEND SESSION MUST AGREE TO
BEHAVE IN A QUIET AND ORDERLY
MANNER. THIS MEANS WE EXPECT
GAS TO NOT APPLAUD SHOUT OR
DISRUPT PROCEEDINGS. WE WILL BE
ENFORCING THESE RULES TODAY.
THOSE WHO DO NOT COMPLY WILL BE
ASKED TO LEAVE QUIETLY. THOSE
WHO DO NOT COOPERATE WILL BE
REMOVED FROM THE CHAMBERS THE
ASSEMBLY THANKS YOU FOR YOUR
UNDERSTANDING AND YOUR
COMPLIANCE. MOVING TO BUSINESS
ON THE DAILY FILE
. MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO START ON THE
CONCURRENCE FILE. THIS IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE PASS AND RETAIN.
FINAL AT FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
AND NUMBER THREE EIGHT WE ARE
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY. WE
ARE GOING TO BEGIN WITH FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR. THIS IS AB.
TWO FIFTY SIX BY AGUIAR-CURRY.
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO FIFTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
ACTUALLY TO WILDLIFE. MS
AGUIAR-CURRY OR RECOGNIZE THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
AB TWO FIVE SIX IS A CLEAN UP
BILL TO THE WINTER RICE HABITAT
INCENTIVE PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM
PROVIDES INCENTIVE FUNDING FOR
FARMERS TO FLOOD THEIR RICE
FIELDS IN THE WINTER N ORDER
TO CREATE WETLAND HABITAT FOR
MIGRATORY BIRDS THIS BILL HAS
NO OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MS CURRIE SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. WE HAVE A
TECHNICAL ISSUE GET THAT
FIGURED OUT THANK YOU MISS
MELENDEZ WE HAVE THE PROPER
ITEM ON THE BOARD THIS IS FILE
ITEM FOR AB TWO FIFTY SIX THANK
YOU MISS AGUIAR-CURRY SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. COUPLE OF
THE ROLE. SORRY TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. PARK WELL CLOSER ROLE
TALLY THE VOTE EYES FIFTY FOUR
KNOWS ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRENT IN. THIS IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY TWO CORPORATION ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVENTEEN FIFTY TO BUY
SOMETHING MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. MISS
PETRIE-NORRIS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY TWO THIS BILL ENABLES THE
SOUTH COAST WATER DISTRICT TO
CONTRACT WITH A PRIVATE ENTITY
IN ORDER TO COMPLETE THE DEAL
HEANEY OCEAN DESALINATION
PROJECT THIS PROJECT WILL
ENABLE ORANGE COUNTY TO
DIVERSIFY OUR WATER SUPPLY. AND
TO LESSEN OUR DEPENDENCE ON
IMPORTED WATER THE PROJECT
ENJOYS BROAD SUPPORT FROM A
COALITION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS LABOR AND THE LOCAL
COMMUNITYAB SEVENTEEN FIFTY
TWO ENABLES US TO BRING THIS
WILL PROJECT TO FRUITION
RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE FIVE.
THANK YOU WAS AGUIAR-CURRY
SINGLE DISCUSSION OR DEBATE THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS OF. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL
TALLY THE VOTE. I IS FIFTY FIVE
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP. AND
ITEM ON SENATE THIRD READING.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
FIVE SB THIRTEEN. FILE I'M
THIRTY FIVE SB THIRTEEN.
KERKORIAN. SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
BY SENATOR WHITE HOUSE SKI AND
ACTUALLY THE LAND USE. MR
VOEPEL. MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI I PRESENT SB
THIRTEEN SB THIRTEEN CONTINUES
THE IMPORTANT WORK THE
LEGISLATURE HAS DONE TO SPUR
THE DEVELOPMENT OF ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNITS OR A. D. U.'S.
SB THIRTEEN ADDRESSES THE
REMAINING EIGHTY YOU BARRIERS
IDENTIFIED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING WHICH INCLUDES REDUCING
EXCESSIVE IMPACT FEES LIMITING
OWNER OCCUPANCY AND PROVIDING A
SAFE PATH FOR ALLOWING ON
PERMITTED A DO YOU WEEDS. TO BE
BROUGHT UP TO CODE EIGHTY USE
MAY BE A SMALL PART IN SOLVING
OUR HOUSING CRISIS BUT IT IS AN
IMPORTANT ONE. I URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER VOEPEL
MISTER BLOOM YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER A
MEMBERS LIKEWISE SO I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN HI THERE
AB YOU LEGISLATION IN THIS
STATE HAS BEEN AN INCREDIBLE
SUCCESS STORY IN FACT SINCE. MY
BILL AB TWENTY TWO NINETY NINE
WAS CHAPTER IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
ALONE THERE HAVE BEEN OVER NINE
THOUSAND APPLICATIONS FOR
EIGHTY YEARS AND MANY OF THOSE
HAVE ALREADY BEEN BUILT ARE
UNDER CONSTRUCTION NINE
THOUSAND THAT'S ABOUT TEN
PERCENT. OF THE CITY'S
POPULATION IN THE CITY OF LA SO
THINK ABOUT HOW MANY THAT IS
STATE WISE STATEWIDE THIS IS A
HOUSING SUCCESS STORY THE
EXPONENTIAL INCREASE IN THE
PERMITTING AND CONSTRUCTION OF
THESE AFFORDABLE AND INNOVATIVE
HOUSING UNITS IS A DIRECT
RESULT. OF YOUR POLICY MAKING
AND- WHO ARE WE SHOULD CONTINUE
TO TWEAK THESE LAWS SO THAT
THEY'RE MORE EFFECTIVE THAT'S
WHAT THIS BILL DOES THAT'S WHAT
THE OTHER THREE BILLS THAT
THERE WERE BEING ASKED TO VOTE
ON ON EIGHTY USED TO. AND I
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE. DAVIS BLOOM
IS FRIEDMAN YOUR RECORD ACCESS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AS SOMEONE WHO THIS
YEAR OFFERED THREE BILLS
DEALING WITH EIGHTY USE I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. I
WANT TO JUST POINT OUT THAT.
USUALLY WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
DEVELOPMENT DEVELOPMENT FEES
WERE THINKING ABOUT LARGE
COMMERCIAL DEVELOPERS PEOPLE
WHO ARE MAKING PROFIT AS THEIR
BUSINESS BY BUILDING. BUT IN
THIS CASE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SINGLE FAMILY. YOU YES
SOMETIMES FOR INCOME BUT OFTEN
TIMES FOR PARENTS FOR A CHILD.
WHATEVER THEIR MOTIVATION
THEY'RE NOT AS EQUIPPED AS
COMMERCIAL DEVELOPERS TO DEAL
WITH LARGE IMPACT FEES THAT ARE
PLACED. ON IT THERE EIGHTY USE
SO FOR THOSE OF YOU WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT GOVERNMENT OVER
REACH AND FEES THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY THE BILL FOR YOU.
AND THIS IS ALSO A WAY FOR
SINGLE FAMILY HOMEOWNERS AND
INDIVIDUALS TO REALLY
PARTICIPATE. AND TO HELP WITH
DEAL WITH OUR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PRICES AND ARE HOMELESS
IS CRISIS BY LEVERAGING THEIR
OWN PROPERTY. BY BRING THE
RENTAL UNIT TO MARKET. EIGHTY
USE ARE VERY IMPORTANT PIECE OF
THE PUZZLE AND TOO OFTEN LARGE
FEES THAT CITIES IMPOSE OUR
BARRIER. TO PRIVATE PROPERTY
OWNERS FROM HELPING. THEIR
NEIGHBORS HELPING THEIR FRIENDS
HELPING THEIR OWN FAMILY PUT A
ROOF OVER THEIR HEADS. I'VE
SEEN THESE IMPACT FEES
PURPOSEFULLY ENACTED BY CITIES.
TO BLOCK EIGHTY YOU
CONSTRUCTION. WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO HELP REMOVE
THOSE BARRIERS AND ALLOW OUR
RESIDENTS IN OUR CITIZENS TO
HELP BE PART OF THE HOUSING
SOLUTION FOR THAT I RIP REQUEST
REALLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MS FREEMAN DOCTOR CHOI YOUR
RECOGNIZED. YOUR SPEAKER AND A
MEMBERS I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF OUR A. B. THIRTEEN. THIS
MEASURE IS TO SIMPLIFY AND TO
ENCOURAGE MORE A. D. U.'S ARE
LOCALLY IT SHOULD BE RED EVER
AT THE EXTRA SPACE HIS SAW.
AVAILABLE FOR SINGLE FAMILY
UNITS HOUSES SO SHOULD ADD THE
A. B. USE. DESPITE DAHLE WERE
AFTERWARD AND THE SPIRIT OF
FROM THE STATE TO PROVIDE THE
MORE OPPORTUNITIES. FOR LOWER
INCOME DWELLING UNITS. AS SOON
AS THIS SIDE DISH IN OUR UNITS
ARE ADDED SOMEBODY WOULD BE
OCCUPYING THE LIVING IN MY
EXPERIENCE. I HAPPEN TO HAVE A
SPACE IN THE BACK OR TRY TO ADD
THE- WHAT ARE. DIFFICULT
RIDICULOUS. REQUIREMENTS ARE.
LOCALLY I AM FACING AND MY
NEIGHBOR SO MANY NEIGHBORS
SOUTH FACING THAT TESTING TIED.
FOR THE DAY ARE A DO YOU ON THE
SAME ADDRESS FOR THE BACKYARD
THEY REQUIRE A SEPARATE ADDRESS.
UNDER THE NAME ABA SAFETY BAYAT
LOCAL FIRE DEPARTMENT CAN YOU
IMAGINE THAT AND OKAY THEN THEN
THEN OLD HAVE ONE ADDRESS.
HOWEVER US A POST OFFICE A
CELLS SO WHAT WE HAVE ON NORMAL
SPACE IN THE AUTOMATED BOX YOU
CANNOT EVEN ADDED. AND NOT THAT
WILL CREATE THE EVEN BEFORE YOU
ADD TO A VERY EXPENSIVE BUT
ANOTHER UNIT THAT THAT HAS TO
BE ALL WE ARRANGED. SO WHAT
THERE ARE STILL LONG WAYS TO GO
OUT TO MAKE OUR EIGHTY USE OP
MAKE IT MORE PRACTICAL AND EASY
ARE FOR. ALL PRIVATE PROPERTY
OWNERS TO AND DOES A D. USED
AND I ENCOURAGE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS OF TO CO OPERATE
THE NOT TO INTERFERE WITH THE
DISCOUNT ABOUT RIDICULOUS
ADICIONAL REQUIREMENTS. I WOULD
YOU VOTE ARE YOU AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU DOCTOR CHOI. MR
MURATSUCHI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH HI LOOKS
LIKE I'M GOING TO BE IN A
DISTINCT MINORITY IN OPPOSING
THIS BILL. I HAVE A LOT OF THE.
MY LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS WHO
ARE SAYING THIS IS ONE OF OUR
ON GOING. EFFORTS TO IMPOSE A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL SOLUTION HAS
TAKEN AWAY LOCAL CONTROL FROM
OUR LOCAL CITIES. I'M OFTEN
ASKED BY MY LOCAL CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS AND MAYORS. IN A WHY IS
THAT THAT STATE LEGISLATORS A
COME FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
SEEM TO FORGOTTEN WHERE THEY
COME FROM. FOR THAT REASON I
OPPOSE THIS BILL. SEEING NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. MR VOEPEL YOU MAY
CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. AND WITHOUT THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSER ALL
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
TWO KNOWS FOR THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WE WILL BE
TAKING A RECESS UNDER CALL OF
THE SPEAKER THERE WILL BE A
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS IN THE LOUNGE
ANY REPUBLICAN CAUCUS IN THE
RULES ROOM. MEMBERS THIS IS
RECESS UNDER CALL OF THE
SPEAKER
. MEMBERS. YOUR
ATTENTION PLEASE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE WILL BE
MEETING IN THE RULES ROOM IF
YOU'RE A BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS PLEASE GO TO THE
ROLE TERM FOR COMMITTEE HEARING.
IN ADDITION PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT TWO I'M REFERRING THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO COMMITTEE AB
ONE EIGHTY ONE MAIENSCHEIN TO
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS. AB TWELVE NINETY
GLORIA TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AGAIN IF YOU ARE ON BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS PLEASE GO TO A
COMMITTEE HEARING IN THE RULES
ROOM. AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
BE IN RECESS UNDER CALL OF THE
SPEAKER
. MEMBERS I HAVE ANOTHER
FUN ANNOUNCEMENT FOR YOU ALL WE
HAVE HEAT IN THE MEMBERS LOUNGE
IN CELEBRATION OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. QUIRK SILVA AS BIRTHDAY
WHICH IS SEPTEMBER SEVENTEENTH
SO. HEAD ON INTO THE MEMBERS
LOUNGE IF YOU HAVEN'T ALREADY
HAD ENOUGH SUGAR
. MEMBERS WE
ARE BACK IN SESSION. HAS
MEMBERS TO RETURN TO THE FLOOR
WE'RE GONNA START WORKING THE
FILE. STARTED A THIRD READING
ON SENATE BILLS. EVERY PLEASE
COME THE FOR WILL START OUR
AFTERNOON SESSION
. MEMBERS WILL
BE STARTING WITH FILE ITEM
THIRTY SENATE BILL TWO THIRTY
FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE
BILL TWO THIRTY FIVE BY SENATOR
DODD AND OTHERS IN ASHLAND
HOUSING. MS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS SB TWO THIRTY FIVE IS
THE DISTRICT BILL THAT SENATOR
DODD AND I ARE WE ARE CO
AUTHORING TO ADDRESS A UNIQUE
SITUATION IMPACTING ONE
CRITICAL AND KEY KEY HOUSING
PROJECT IN NAPA COUNTY. NAPA
COUNTY AND CITY HAVE WORK
COLLABORATIVELY ON THE NAPA PIE
PROJECT FOR NEARLY A DECADE.
AND IT IS NOW READY BILL TO
BUILD. UP A PIPE WILL CONSTRUCT
FOR NINE HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
NEW UNITS INCLUDING DEED
RESTRICTED UNITS FOR VERY LOW.
LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS SB TWO THIRTY FIVE
WILL ALLOW THE CITY AND COUNTY
TO REACH A MUTUAL AGREEMENT TO
ALLOW ONE OF THOSE
JURISDICTIONS. TO REPORT THE
ENTITLEMENTS BUILDING PERMITS
AND CERTIFICATES OF OCCUPANCY
ISSUED BY THE OTHER ON ITS
ANNUAL HOUSING PRODUCTION
REPORT TO SPEECH CD. ABSENT
THIS LEGISLATION THE COUNTY HAS
NO MECHANISM TO ISSUE BUILDING
PERMITS OR OBTAIN RENO CREDIT.
AND THE PINEAPPLE PIE PROJECT
WOULD NOT MOVE FORWARD. TWO
THIRTY FIVE HAS HAD NO
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU
MISS AGAR CURRY. SEEN OTHER
MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK ON
THIS ITEM THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTES HI SIXTY TWO
NO ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WILL MOVED OUT OF FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY ONE SENATE
BILL TWENTY FOUR THE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL TWENTY FOUR BY
SENATOR LEYVA AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC HEALTH
MAKING APPROPRIATION THERE FOR
THIS CAREER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE THE ROW VERSUS WADE
DECISION THE US SUPREME COURT
AFFIRMED A FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO
PRIVACY THAT PROTECTS A
PERSON'S RIGHT TO CHOOSE
WHETHER OR NOT TO HAVE AN
ABORTION SB TWENTY FOUR WOULD
REQUIRE ALL ON CAMPUS STUDENT
HEALTH CENTERS AT PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES TO PROVIDE
MEDICATION FOR EARLY PREGNANCY
TERMINATION FOR THEIR STUDENTS
BY JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. RESEARCH FROM UC SAN
FRANCISCO IT'S THE ESTIMATES.
UC AND CSU CAMPUSES SEEK
MEDICATION ABORTION SET OFF
SITE HEALTHCARE FACILITIES IF
WE TRULY VALUE ACCESS TO
ABORTION IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF SUPPORTING
STUDENT SUCCESS IT IS CRITICAL
pEVERY MONTH ARE ABLE TO ACCESS
THESE SERVICES ON CAMPUS.
THOUGH MANY CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES ALREADY OFFER A
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES SUCH AS PREGNANCY
OPTION COUNSELING AND
CONTRACEPTIVES NONE CURRENTLY
OFFER ACCESS TO MEDICATION
ABORTION ON CAMPUS AXIS IS
SEVERELY LIMITED FOR COLLEGE
STUDENTS SINCE ONLY 15% OF THE
CLOSEST OFF CAMPUS ABORTION
PROVIDERS ARE OPEN ON WEEKENDS
MEANING THAT STUDENTS MAY OFTEN
HAVE TO MISS CLASS EXAMS AND
WORK TO ACCESS ABORTION WHICH
THE SUPREME COURT HAS
DETERMINED. TO BE A PROTECTIVE
RIGHT. MEMBERS THE COLLEGE
STUDENT RIGHT ACCESS ACT WILL
IMPROVE TRUE ACCESS TO ABORTION
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS ACROSS OUR
STATE INCLUDING COLLEGE
STUDENTS AT OUR PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES. SB TWENTY FOUR
WILL CONTINUE TO MOVE
CALIFORNIA FORWARD BY
REAFFIRMING THE RIGHT OF
COLLEGE STUDENTS TO ACCESS
ABORTION CARE WITHOUT ANY
DELAYS. ALL CALIFORNIANS
INCLUDING COLLEGE STUDENTS
SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO THE FULL
RANGE OF CHOICES OF
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES SO THAT THEY CAN PLAN
THEIR FUTURES AND ACHIEVE THEIR
PERSONAL AND PROFESSIONAL GOALS
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS CAREER.
SEEN NO ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLICK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES AYE
AYES FORTY FOUR KNOWS FIFTEEN.
THE MEASURE IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
WILL PASS TEMPORARILY I AM
THIRTY TWO. ITEM THIRTY FOUR.
WE HAVE ALREADY DISPENSED WITH
I AM THIRTY FIVE. PASS
TEMPORARILY IF ITEMS FILE ITEMS
THIRTY SIX AND THIRTY SEVEN.
NUMBERS THAT BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT SENATE
BILL. SIXTY ONE THE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL SIXTY ONE BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TO FIREARMS MR
MAIENSCHEIN YOUR RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SB
SIXTY ONE PROHIBITS ANY PERSON
FOR MAKING AN APPLICATION TO
PURCHASE MORE THAN ONE SEMI
AUTOMATIC CENTERFIRE RIFLE
WITHIN A THIRTY DAY PERIOD. THE
FIREARM WILL NOT BE DELIVERED
WHENEVER THE DEALER IS NOTIFIED
BY THE DOJ THAT WITHIN THE
PRECEDING THIRTY DAY PERIOD THE
PURCHASER HAD MADE ANOTHER
APPLICATION TO PURCHASE A
FIREARM IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE
LEGISLATION WAS ENACTED TO
LIMIT THE PURCHASE OF HAND GUNS
BUT AS RECENT DATA SUGGEST LONG
GUNS ARE BECOMING A SIGNIFICANT
PIECE OF CALIFORNIA'S GUN
TRAFFICKING PROBLEM. OVER THE
PAST TEN YEARS CALIFORNIANS
HAVE TYPICALLY PURCHASE MORE
LONG GUNS AND HAND GUNS SB
SIXTY ONE ALSO PROHIBITS THE
SALE OF A SEMI AUTOMATIC
CENTERFIRE. TO ANYONE UNDER THE
AGE OF TWENTY ONE UNLESS YOU
ARE ACTIVE MILITARY OR ON FOR.
YOU KNOW EARLIER THIS YEAR AND
NINETEEN YEAR OLD INDIVIDUAL
OPENED FIRE AT THE BOTTOM
HIGHWAY IN MY DISTRICT. KILLING
ONE PERSON AND INJURING THREE
OTHERS THE SEMI AUTOMATIC RIFLE
USED IN THE SHOOTING WAS
PURCHASED THROUGH A LOOPHOLE.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO REMEDY. WITH
THE RECENT TRAGIC EVENTS IN MY
DISTRICT AND IN GILROY THIS
IMPORTANT WE STRENGTHEN OUR
FARM LAWS TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITY FROM HAVING A FIREARM
END UP IN THE WRONG HANDS.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER MAIENSCHEIN. SEE NO
OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK
ON THIS ITEM THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED AS DIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES FORTY
SIX NO SEVENTEEN. THE MEASURE
IS ADOPTED
. MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA
RETURN TO THE TOP OF THE FILE
CONCURRENT WITH SENATE
AMENDMENTS. STARTING WITH FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
FIFTY SEVEN BY FAMILY MEMBER
DAVID CHIU AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC BANKS MR
CHEWED YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES
AB EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. SENATE AMENDMENTS
AMENDED THE BILL THAT WE
SUPPORTED ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
TO NARROW IT TO A SEVEN YEAR
PILOT PROGRAM CAPPING THE
NUMBER OF CHARTERS EACH YEAR TO
WITH NO MORE THAN TEN REQUIRING
ANY NEW CHART TO BE APPROVED BY
VOTERS IN A GENERAL ALL CITY.
AND REQUIRING CHARTERS TO
PARTNER WITH EXISTING CREDIT
UNIONS WHICH HAS REMOVED THE
OPPOSITION OF OUR CALIFORNIA
CREDIT UNIONS WITH THE SUPPORT
OF A HUNDRED EIGHTY
ORGANIZATIONS ON THIS BILL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER TO. SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM. THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. SIX
FORTY ONE VOTES. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
.
TAKES FORTY ONE VOTES. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
.
OR WE
. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES HIGHS
FORTY ONE KNOWS TWENTY TWO
MISTER DONALD IS THE HERO OF
THE DAY. THE SENATE AND THAT
ARE CONCURRED IN
. YEAH YEAH WE
NOW TO FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY
CLERK WILL READ A CYNICAL
THIRTEEN TWENTY FIVE FAMILY
MEMBER DESIRING AND OTHERS AND
ACTING A PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
RETIREMENT SYSTEMS. MISTER IS
THERE IT YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I'M
PRESENTING A. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY FOUR CONCURRENCE THIS
BILL HAS BEEN WORKED ON FOR THE
PAST THAT FOR YEARS AND
HOPEFULLY THIS IS GONNA BE THE
TIME THAT THE GOVERNOR ALSO
SIGNS IT A. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY
WOULD REQUIRE THE BOARDS OF
CALPERS AND CAL STIRS TO DIVEST
PUB PUBLIC EMPLOYEE RETIREMENT
FUNDS FROM ANY INVESTMENT
VEHICLE. ISSUED OR OWNED BY THE
GOVERNMENT OF TURKEY THE
REPUBLIC OF TURKEYS AND
WILLINGNESS TO RECOGNIZE THE
GENOCIDE AND THEIR UNRELENTING
CAMPAIGN TO DENY THE GENOCIDE
CONTINUES TO DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST ARMENIANS GREEKS AND
ASSYRIANS AND OTHER ETHNIC
MINORITIES WHO SUFFERED AT THE
HANDS OF THE TURKISH GOVERNMENT
CALIFORNIA HAS HAD A CLEAR
POLICY ON GENOCIDE. IS
DEMONSTRATED BY DECADES OF
LEGISLATIVE RESOLUTIONS AND
GUBERNATORIAL PROCLAMATIONS
THIS BILL CONTINUES
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT TO ACT
APPROPRIATELY AGAINST COUNTRIES
THAT HAVE A RECORD OF HUMAN
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS AND UNDERMINE
DEMOCRACY. UP WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IT I VOTE
BUT BEFORE. I COMPLETE MY
SPEAKING. A MISTER SPEAKER ON
MY TIME. SO JUST WANTED TO TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY ALSO AND THINK
MISTER DOTSON WILLS ARE CHIEF
CLERK DOTSON WILSON FOR THE
WONDERFUL WORK THAT HE HAS DONE
I KNOW THAT I'VE BEEN A BETTER
MEMBER BECAUSE OF HIS WORK AND
HIS STAFF'S WORK SO GIVEN THAT
THIS IS GONNA BE MY FINAL BILL
OF THIS SESSION COINCIDING WITH
HIS FINAL DAY. WANTED TO TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY AND SAY THANK
YOU TO HIM. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THANK YOU MISTER
NAZARIAN. WELL NO THE MISSION
IS THERE WILL NOT BE SPEAKING
THE REST OF THE DAY. SEE NO
OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK
ON THIS ITEM THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW THE VOTES HIGHS FIFTY ONE
KNOWS ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
.
THERE'S ALWAYS FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE WE VERY EXPENSIVE FILE
ITEMS FOUR AND FIVE. WE WILL
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX. THAT BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE SEVENTY EIGHT THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW MOAN AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE CHILD
CARE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALONE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
WAS HEARD IN THIS COMMITTEE AT
IN COMMITTEE ANSWER IN.
MULTIPLE COMMITTEES AND BUT IT
HAS COME THROUGH THE UP THEIR
PREPARATIONS AND FLORA BOTH
HOUSES IT'S TAKEN AMENDMENTS TO
DO THE FOLLOWING IT CLARIFIES
THE ROLE OF PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT BOARD OR PURPOSE
RELATED TO THE MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING BETWEEN STE STATE
AGENCIES AND THE RIGHT TO
STRIKE. TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
UPDATED IN THIS BILL WITH
LANGUAGE A CODIFIED IN THE
TRAILER BILL AB THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT REMAINS AT COMMITTED TO
STABILIZING THOSE WHO EDUCATE
OUR EARLIEST LEARNERS AND THE
FAMILIES WHO SEE CARE FOR THEIR.
FAMILIES AS THEY REMAIN. IN THE
WORK FORCE. JOINING THEM YES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THE
LAST DAY EVERYBODY
. THANK YOU
MS ALONE. SEE NO ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE VOTE TALLY THE VOTES
HIGHS FIFTY TWO KNOWS FIFTEEN.
THE SENATE MINUTES ARE
CONCURRENT
. MEMBERS WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT. THAT BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAO AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TO CONSUMER
PRIVACY. THE CHECKOUT YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
TWENTY FIVE CLARIFIES THAT THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT
OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN OR CCPA
EXEMPTS INDIVIDUALS WHOSE
PERSONAL INFORMATION HAS BEEN
COLLECTED. BY A BUSINESS WITHIN
THE SCOPE OF THEIR EMPLOYMENT
OR IN SIMILAR CONTEXT TO THE
EXTENT THAT THAT INFORMATION IS
COLLECTED AND USED SOLELY FOR
PURPOSES RELATED TO THOSE
ACTIVITIES. SENATE AMENDMENTS
TO THE FOLLOWING ONE PROVIDE
FOR THE EXCEPTIONS TO INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL CATEGORIES OF
SIMILAR INDIVIDUALS FROM HOME A
BUSINESS MAY COLLECT PERSONAL
INFORMATION. TO SPECIFY THAT P.
I. COLLECTED BY BUSINESS HIS
EXAM IN THE CONTACTS WITH THE
PI IS COLLECTED AND USED SOLELY
FOR EMERGENCY CONTACT PURPOSES
AND WHAT THE P. I. IS NECESSARY
TO BE RETAINED FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION OF BENEFITS.
THREE ANY JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SUNSET TO THESE
EXCEPTIONS FOR AUTHORIZED THE
BUSINESS TO REQUIRE REASONABLE
AUTHENTICATION OF THE CONSUMER
AND TO USE EXISTING ACCOUNTS TO
CONVEY CCPA REQUEST. AND FIVE
MAKE OUR TECHNICAL CHANGES TO
AVOID CHATTERING OUT ISSUES
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
CHOW. SEEN OTHER MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION ON THIS
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
COMPARED IT
. MEMBERS WILL TAKE
UP FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SEVENTY SIX.
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE SEVENTY SIX BY FAMILY
MEMBERS CERVANTES AND ACTUALLY
TELL TURNED OF ENERGY TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY.
MISS CERVANTES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS WHEN AB ONE
SEVENTY SIX PASSED THE ASSEMBLY
THE BILL'S CALL FOR ADDITIONAL
REPORTING ON THE ADMINISTRATION
OF THE SALES AND USE TAX.
EXCLUSION PROGRAM INCLUDING A
RESPONSE TO THE LA A REPORT IN
THE SENATE THE BILL WAS AMENDED
TO ADDRESS ONE ISSUE. THERE WAS
SPECIFIC TO THE APPLICATION
EVALUATION PROCESS MORE
SPECIFICALLY THE JOBS COMPONENT
AS CALIFORNIA TRANSITIONS INTO
A LOW CARBON FUEL ECONOMY IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT THE STATE
INCENTIVIZE SUPPORT FOR QUALITY
JOBS COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE ON SENATE. TEN
MINUTES. THANK YOU MAY
CERVANTES. SEE NO DIGITAL
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WE DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
KNOWS ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT.
SCOTT YOU'RE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR MOTION THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE REFER
THE FOLLOWING THOSE COMMITTEE.
AB THREE FIFTEEN CRISTINA
GARCIA FROM THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE. AB THIRTEEN
NINETY EIGHT WALDRON FROM
ACCOUNTABILITY MINISTER THIS
MAN MINISTRY TO REVIEW
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE AB EIGHT FOURTEEN
SIXTY NINE LOW FROM THE PRIVACY
CONSUMER PROTECTION COMMITTEE
TO THE RULES COMMITTEE. AND SB
SIX THIRTY FOUR GLAZER FROM THE
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO
THE RULES COMMITTEE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND RURAL
SITUATE THE FILE NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
FOLLOWING COMMITTEES MEETING.
TODAY UPON CALL THE CHAIR. VIA
MENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS HERE. AB ONE EIGHTY
ONE MAIN SHINE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO HEAR AB ONE
SIXTEEN TING. AB SEVEN TWENTY
THREE QUIRK AND AB TWELVE
NINETY GLORIA. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER
. MEMBERS WILL STAND A
BRIEF RECESS IN ORDER TO ALLOW
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
TO ME. LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE WILL BE MEETING IN
THE RULES ROOM. THIS WOULD BE
THE RECESS ON A CALL THE
SPEAKER. YOU'RE NEVER THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE PLEASE GO
TO THE RULES COMMITTEE ROOM.
MEMBERS WERE STILL UNDER A CALL
YOU MUST STAY ON THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR
. MEMBERS A BRIEF
ANNOUNCEMENT THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE WILL BE
MEETING IN THE RULES ROOM. AT
THIS TIME THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE GEO WILL
BE IN THE RULES ROOM OFF THE
FLOOR AT THIS TIME
. MEMBERS THE
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS COMMITTEE. IS NOW
MEETING IN THE RULES COMMITTEE
ROOM ASTM. AND THE RULES ROOM
.
MEMBERS WE MAY ENTERTAIN VOTE
CHANGES AT THIS TIME. WHILE
COMMITTEES CONTINUE TO MAKE OFF
THE FLOOR. MISTER CUNNINGHAM
YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER VOTE CHANGE AB EIGHT
FIFTY SEVEN FROM I TO NOT
VOTING VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CUNNINGHAM ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN I IT'S NOT
VOTING. WE MAY ENTERTAIN
ADDITIONAL VOTE CHANGES AT THIS
TIME MEMBERS IF YOU WISH.
DOCTOR QUIRK. YOUR VOTE CHANGE
THEIR. IT'S THIRTEEN TWENTY I
TO NOT VOTING. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK AS LEGAL THIRTEEN TWENTY
I TO NOT VOTING. THANK YOU
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP
SOME CONCURRENCE ITEMS. MEMBERS
WE WILL MOVE THE FILE ITEM SIX.
FILE ITEM SIX. AB FIFTEEN SIXTY
THREE BY MISTER SANTIAGO THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN SIXTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO AND OTHERS AND
EXPLAIN TO THE CENSUS MR
SANTIAGO I THINK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THIS BILL COMES BACK
OFFER CONCURRENCE OF THE
SENATE. AND IT IN A NUTSHELL
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS ALLOWS
FOR EVERY PERSON TO BE COUNTED
FEAR AND INTIMIDATION FEAR
SOMEBODY IN PERSON A CENSUS
WORKER AND ARE ACTING TO
IMPERSONATE A CENSUS WORKER.
EXPECT LAST MY VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS SANTIAGO SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. MEMBERS THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF
A. ALL MEMBERS OF A RESERVE OF.
WORK WELL. CLOSER ALL TIES BUT
ICE FORTY NINE OH ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. WE
HAVE DISPENSED WITH FILE ITEM
SEVEN WHERE FILE ITEM NUMBER
.
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT. AB SIX SO TWO BY
MISTER BERMAN. AND THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL SIX OH
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN
AND OTHERS IN ACTUALLY TO
PRIVACY MR BERMAN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
DEPICT TECHNOLOGY CAN AND HAS
BEEN USED NEFARIOUS LEE TO
DEPICT BOTH CELEBRITIES AND NON
CELEBRITIES AND SEXUALLY
EXPLICIT MATERIAL WITHOUT THEIR
CONSENT OR PARTICIPATION.
SENATE AMENDMENTS TO AB SIX OH
TWO REQUIRE CONSENT TO BE
OBTAINED PRIOR TO DEPICTING A
PERSON AND DIGITALLY PRODUCED
SEXUALLY EXPLICIT MATERIAL AND
ALLOW AN INDIVIDUAL'S CONSENT
TO BE RESCINDED WITHIN SEVENTY
TWO HOURS AND LESS CERTAIN
CONDITIONS ARE MET. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLICK WELL ABOVE THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS LETTERS ARE THE CLERK
WILL. THOSE ARE ALL TALLY THE
VOTE. I SIXTY ONE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO PASS.
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM ELEVEN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE. CLICK
RATE ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
FIFTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TRIAL AND I PLAN TO CONSUMER
PRIVACY. MR CHOW THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE ADDRESSES
VARIOUS CLARIFYING CHANGES AND
DRAFTING ERRORS TO THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT
OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN OR CCPA. THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS TO THE
FOLLOWING ONE CLARIFY THE SCOPE
AND APPLICATION OF THE C. CPA'S
FAIR CREDIT REPORT ACT
EXEMPTION. TO CLARIFY
OBLIGATIONS OF BUSINESSES
AROUND COLLECTING AND RETAINING
PI IT WOULD NOT OTHERWISE
COLLECTO RETAIN IN THE ORDINARY
COURSE OF BUSINESS. THREE
ADDRESS THE APPLICATION OF THE
CCPA TO BUSINESS TO BUSINESS
COMMUNICATIONS AND TRANSACTIONS
AS SPECIFIED AND FOR AT DOUBLE
JOINTING LANGUAGE TO AVOID
CHAPTER RING OUT ISSUES.
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THINGS CHELSEA
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. IT IS OUT OF OUT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WORK WELL THOSE ARE ALL TIED
BUT I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO SENATE
MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED IN. FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN IS AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE BY SOME THE MEMBER WICKS
AND ACTUALLY TO HOUSING. THIS
WICKS THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS THIS BILL IS NOT
CONCURRENCE AT EIGHTY FOUR TO
EIGHTY FIVE EXPANDS CURRENT
STREAMLINING PROVISIONS FOR
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING FOR
THAT MISSING MIDDLE SO IF YOU
BELIEVE WE HAVE A HOUSING
SHORTAGE PROBLEM IN THE STATE
YOU WILL VOTE FOR THIS BILL. I
IT HAS. RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN BOTH THE SENATE AND
THE ASSEMBLY IT'S A PART OF I
CALIFORNIA BE HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY. AT THE VERY COUNSEL
AND MANY OTHERS AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THE AIM IS WICKS A NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CARPAL OF
THE ROLE. IT IS OUT OF THAT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE- ALL
NUMBERS LETTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL TELL YOU
WHAT I SEE SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB
SEVENTEEN TWENTY SEVEN CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN BY FAMILY MEMBER WEBER
AND ACTUALLY TO POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. DOCTOR WEBER. MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE RISE TO
PRESENT TO YOU AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN WHICH IS BACK ON
CENTER FOR CONCURRENCE THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS WERE MINOR IN
TECHNICAL AND INSURE PROPER
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BILL AB
TWO SEVENTEEN TWENTY SEVEN HAS
NO OPPOSITION AND HAS RECEIVED
NO NO VOTES AND I RESPECT FOR
YOUR- RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. ON CONCURRENT. THANK GOD
WEBER SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE CARPOOL OF ON THE ROLL.
OUT OF THOSE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THIS OUT OF THE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL TELL YOU ABOUT I
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO RECESS
UNDER CALL OF THE SPEAKER.
THERE WILL BE FOOD IN THE
LOUNGE FOR BOTH PARTIES. WHERE.
UNDER CALL THIS IS RECESS UNDER
CALL OF THE SPEAKER
. MEMBERS.
WE'RE BACK IN SESSION PLEASE
JOIN US ON THE FLOOR OF THE
ASSEMBLY SO WE CAN RETURN TO
BUSINESS
. MEMBERS WE ARE BACK
IN SESSION PLEASE RETURN TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR SO WE CAN RESUME
BUSINESS
. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING
TO MOVE TO THE DAILY FILE THIRD
READING FILE SENATE BILLS. FILE
ITEM TWENTY NINE SB TWO TWENTY
TO THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE
BILL TWO TWENTY TWO BY SENATOR
HILL AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
NEED TO DISCRIMINATION MR
GLORIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT SAID A BILL TO
TWENTY TWO ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
HILL. SB TWO TWO TWO WOULD
PROTECT VETERANS AND MILITARY
PERSONNEL FROM HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION ENSURE THAT
LANDLORDS CANNOT DENY HOMELESS
VETERANS HOUSING BASED SOLELY
ON THE FACT THAT THEY WOULD
RECEIVE A RENTAL. ASSISTANCE
VOUCHER US VETERANS AND THOSE
CURRENTLY SERVING IN OUR ARMED
FORCES ARE PROTECTED FROM
EMPLOYMENT DISCRIMINATION BY
THE CALIFORNIA FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING ACT WHOEVER THAT
LAW DOES NOT SPECIFICALLY
INCLUDE VETERANS OR MILITARY
PERSONNEL AMONG THOSE WHO ARE
PROTECTED. FROM HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION SB TO WHAT
ADDRESS THIS GAP BY ADDING
VETERANS AND MILITARY PERSONNEL
AS A PROTECTED CLASS IN THE
STATUTE RELATING TO HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION I ASK THE
MEMBERS COME TO THE FLOOR AND
VOTE IN FAVOR OF SENATE BILL
TWO. TWO TWO. THANK YOU MISTER
GLORIA AND I'M SURE WHEN WE
OPEN THE ROLE MEMBERS WILL
RETURN TO THE FLOOR TO VOTE. AT
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL. CALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO GO. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THIRTY DESIRE TO
VOTE. WHERE WILL CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTE EYES
FORTY EIGHT NEW ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS FOR THIS MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM TWENTY SEVEN
SB THREE TWENTY THREE THE CLERK
WILL READ SENATE BILL THREE
TWENTY THREE BY SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE SKI AND ACTUALLY THE
COMMON INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS MR
COLOR YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS SB
THREE TWENTY THREE AS MUCH TO
YOUR PET PARAMETERS AROUND HOW
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS WHEN
THEY'RE ELECTIONS THIS BILL
ENSURES H. AWAY BOARDS CANNOT
SIMPLY EXCLUDE OR
DISENFRANCHISE AGE WHERE
RESIDENTS AND BOARD ELECTIONS
AGE MAY BOARDS POSSESS THE
POWER TO FIND HOMER HOMEOWNERS.
TAKE THEM TO COURT AND EVEN FOR
CLOSE ON THEIR HOMES AND H.
AWAY ASSESSMENT BECAUSE
RESIDENTS THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
A YEAR SO IT IS CRITICAL TO
ENSURE THESE H. AWAY BOARD
MEMBER ELECTIONS. ARE HELD WITH
INTEGRITY. RESPECTFULLY ASK DR
A- THANK YOU MISTER KALRA
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
REQUIRES FORTY ONE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE
. THIS
GOVERNMENT THE CALL. WE'RE
GONNA GET. MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FIFTEEN AC
ARE ONE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA
RELATIVE TO THE IMMIGRATION AND
NATIONALLY NATIONALE THE ACT MR
BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES A C. R. ONE IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS IN
THE SENATE. AT A CO AUTHOR IS
AN UPDATED THE RESOLUTION TO
REFLECT THE FACT THAT THE
FEDERAL REGULATIONS REGARDING
PUBLIC CHARGE HAVE BEEN ADOPTED
OTHER MINOR AMENDMENTS ARE
TAKEN AS WELL. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON A C. R.
ONE. THANK YOU MISTER BONTA
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE. QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE EYES FORTY
FOUR NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN
. FILE ITEM
TWENTY SIX SB SEVEN FIFTY FOUR
MEMBERS. THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN FIFTY FOUR BY
SENATOR MORE LOCK AND ACTUALLY
IN A COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS. THIS
PETRIE-NORRIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER NUMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT SB SEVEN FIFTY FOUR
WHICH WILL ALLOW HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATIONS IN COMMON
INTERESTS DEVELOPMENTS TO
APPROVE BOARD MEMBERS. BY
ACCLAMATION UNDER CURRENT LAW
EVEN WHEN AN ANNUAL H. O. A
ELECTION IS AND CONTESTED THE
ADMINISTRATION MUST STILL
HIGHER ELECTION OFFICIALS
PRINTED MAIL BALLOTS AND
CONDUCT COSTLY ELECTIONS
SHIFTING PRECIOUS RESOURCES
AWAY FROM OTHER IMPORTANT
COMMUNITY NEEDS. THIS BILL
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AND SAVE OUR
COMMUNITIES MONEY RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE THAT. THINK
YOU'LL MISS PETRIE-NORRIS
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TELL YOU THAT I SIXTY FIVE
KNOWS HEROES PASSES
. MEMBERS I
ASK THAT YOU PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON IN IN GERMANY MEMORY I
PLEASE ASK YOU TO. TAKE YOUR
SEATS AND GIVE YOUR SPECIAL
ATTENTION. TO MISLI MON. SIMONE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER. ON SEPTEMBER
SECOND TWENTY NINETEEN. THIRTY
FOUR LIVES WERE LOST ABOARD THE
CONCEPTION A COMMERCIAL DIVE
BOAT THAT HAD SET OFF ON LABOR
DAY WEEKEND DIVE EXCURSION OFF
THE COAST OF SANTA CRUZ ISLAND
IN SANTA BARBARA COUNTY. WE
KNOW THAT THIS DEVASTATING TRAV
TRAGEDY HAS BEEN FELT
NATIONWIDE. THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT LOST THEIR LIVES WERE FROM
VARIOUS PARTS OF CALIFORNIA AND
AS FAR AS TENNESSEE. BUT THERE
IS ONE THING THAT UNITED EACH
OF THESE INDIVIDUALS THEIR LOVE
FOR THE OCEAN AND THEIR LOVE
FOR DIVING. IN MY ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT WE LOST THREE PRECIOUS
LIVES. ALEXANDER KURTZ CANDOR
CHAN AND WAIT TEN. ALEXANDER
KURTZ WAS TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF
AGE AND LIVED IN SANTA BARBARA
SHE WENT BY ALLEY AND WAS THE
SOLE CREW MEMBER THAT DID NOT
SURVIVE THE FIRE. ALLEY
GRADUATED FROM A PERFORMING
ARTS HIGH SCHOOL IN CINCINNATI
BEFORE PURSUING HER LOVE OF
DIVING FULL TIME. SHE WORKED AT
PARAMOUNT PICTURES PRIOR TO
THAT IN LOS ANGELES IN THE
CREATIVE ADVERTISING TEAM.
ALLEY WAS DESCRIBED BY HER
MOTHER SHERRY. AS A GO GETTER
SHE WAS JUST FOLLOWING HER
DREAMS SHE LOVED IT IN SANTA
BARBARA SHE LOVES THE BOAT SHE
LOVED DIVING. HER FATHER SAID
THE ONLY SENSE OF COMFORT HE
HAS IN THIS HORRIBLE TIME IS
KNOWING THAT SHE PASSED DOING
WHAT SHE LOVED. KENDRICK CHAN
WAS TWENTY SIX YEARS OF AGE AND
LIVED IN OXNARD. SHE WAS ON THE
BOAT WITH HER FATHER RAYMOND
SCOTT CHAN OF LOS ALTOS. THEY
BOTH WERE AVID DRIVE DIVERS.
TAKING MULTIPLE TRIPS TO THE
CHANNEL ISLANDS EVERY YEAR
TOGETHER. CHAN GREW UP IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY AND GRADUATED FROM
UC DAVIS IN TWENTY FIFTEEN WITH
THE DEGREES SPECIALIZING IN
EVOLUTION ECOLOGY AND BIO
DIVERSITY. AFTER GRADUATION SHE
BEGAN WORKING AS A WILDLIFE
BIOLOGIST WITH THE US FISH AND
WILDLIFE SERVICE. THOSE WHO
KNEW KENDRA DESCRIBED HER AS A
REMARKABLE HUMAN BEING HER
POSITIVE ENERGY ENRICH THE
LIVES OF THOSE SHE TOUCHED
THROUGH HER LOVE OF NATURE
WILDLIFE AND THE OUTDOORS. SHE
WAS A FORCE FOR GOOD AND LEAD A
LIFE THAT MADE THE WORLD AROUND
HER A BETTER PLACE. WAIT TEN
WAS TWENTY SIX YEARS OF AGE AND
MOVE TOOK A LEAD AT JUST FOUR
MONTHS AGO. SHE BOARDED THE
CONCEPTION BECAUSE SHE WANTED
TO EXPLORE HER NEW HOME. WE
GRADUATED FROM UC BERKELEY IN
MAY WITH A MASTERS IN
ENGINEERING AND ATTENDED THE
UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN MICHIGAN
AS AN UNDERGRADUATE. SHE HAD
RECENTLY TAKEN A JOB AS A DATA
SCIENTIST AT A HEALTHCARE
TECHNOLOGY COMPANY. WAY SISTER
SURE GREEN SAID SHE HOPES HER
SISTER WHO LOVE TO SPENDING
TIME OUTDOORS. BEFORE SETTLING
DOWN TO SLEEP THE NIGHT OF THE
FIRE. HER FAMILY IS COMFORTED
SOMEWHAT KNOWING THAT WAY WAS
DOING SOMETHING SHE LOVED IN
THE LAST FEW MOMENTS OF HER
LIFE. AS WE MOURN THEIR LIVES
AND THE LIVES. OF THE OTHER
THIRTY TWO THIRTY THREE. I HOPE
THEIR FAMILIES AND FRIENDS FIND
PEACE IN KNOWING. THAT EVEN
DURING THIS TRAGIC TRAGIC
SITUATION EACH OF THEM WAS
DOING SOMETHING THEY LOVED IN
THE VARIOUS LAST MOMENTS OF
THEIR LIVES. MEMBERS IT'S WITH
A HEAVY HEART THAT I ASK THAT
WE ADJOURN IN THE THIRTY FOUR
LIVES LOST MEMORY. THANK YOU
MISS LIMóN. MR BLOOM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THIS TO GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TO JOIN IN THE
MEMORY OF TO SANTA MONICA
RESIDENTS CHARLES MCILVAINE AND
MARY BETH GOING THE WHO WERE
AMONG THE THIRTY FOUR WHO
TRAGICALLY PERISHED. IN THE
CONCEPTION FIRE. CHARLES
MCILVAINE IN MARY BETH CORNY
WERE DIVING INTO THE US WHO
LIVED IN THE SAME CONDOMINIUM
COMPLEX IN SANTA MONICA CHARLES
WHO IS FORTY FOUR YEARS OLD
WORKED AS A VISUAL EFFECTS.
DESIGNER FOR WALT DISNEY
IMAGINEERING AND WAS KNOWN FOR
HIS WORK ON FILMS SUCH AS
SPIDER MAN WATCHMAN AND GREEN
LANTERN. HE WAS A RADIANT
BRIGHT LIGHT IN MANY PEOPLE'S
LIVES SAID CULVER CITY
COUNCILMEN ALEX FISH WHO HAD
BEEN HIS FRIEND. SINCE THEY
SHARE THE SAME DORM ROOM AT UC
BERKELEY. IN A FAMILY STATEMENT
MCILVAINE WIFE JASMINE LORD
SAID HER HUSBAND AND THEIR
CLOSE FRIEND CORNY LIVE THEIR
LIVES TO THE FULLEST SHE ADDED
HIS LAUGH WAS THE GREATEST AND
HIS SMILE COULD LIGHT UP THE
DARK. HE EMBRACED LIFE WITH
EXCEPTIONAL JOY OPENNESS AND
HUMOR AND ALL WHO KNEW FELT
THAT WARMTH. MARY BETH GOING HE
WAS FIFTY ONE YEARS OLD AND WAS
A SALES DIRECTOR AND OCEAN
DEVOTE T. WHO DEDICATED HER
LIFE TO THE PROTECTION OF
SHARKS. AND OTHER SEA LIFE. SHE
WAS HAILED BY FRIENDS AS AN
OUTGOING FIGURE THAT ALWAYS HAD
A SMILE. SHE WAS THE PERSON YOU
WANTED TO BE AROUND SHE WAS
FUN. THE BEST SMILE THE BEST
LAUGH SAID A FRIEND OF HERS.
ORIGINALLY FROM MASSACHUSETTS
MERRY BETH WORKED AS A SALES
EXECUTIVE FOR THE NEW ENGLAND
PATRIOTS. AND A FRIEND WHO
RECOUNTED MERRY BEST COMMITMENT
AND LOVE FOR THE OCEAN SAID
THAT SHE HOPES THAT MERRY BATH
IS OFF SWIMMING WITH THE
DOLPHINS AND SHARKEY'S
SOMEWHERE BEAUTIFUL. I JOIN MY
COLLEAGUES IN ASKING THAT WE
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF ALL
THIRTY FOR. VICTIMS OF THE
FIRE. AND SPECIFICALLY. IN
MEMORY ABOUT CHARLES AND MERRY
BATH. THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM IS
EGGMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN
THIS IS GERMAN MEMORY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BEEN A SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE ON BEHALF OF
FIVE OF MY CONSTITUENTS WHO ARE
ALSO ON THE BOAT THAT DAY.
OFTENTIMES THOSE OF US WHO LIVE
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THERE'S ONLY ONE
BEACH IN CALIFORNIA HAS ONLY
ONE OCEAN AND SHOW AS A STATE
WE ALL SHARE THAT TOGETHER. SO
MY CONSTITUENTS WERE DIVING
INTO CS THEY WERE THERE TO
CELEBRATE THEIR FATHER MICHAEL.
PUT A SOULS US SIXTY FOURTH
BIRTHDAY. HE AND HIS WIFE FOR
NASA WHO OR BOTH STOCKTON HIGH
EDISON HIGH GRADUATES THEY WERE
BOTH NURSES. MICHAEL HAD BEEN
STARTED OFF AS A PARAMEDIC AND
THEN I WENT TO SCHOOL THAT IS
NURSING DEGREE. AND THEN WAS A
TEACHER HAD THE STATE HIGH
SCHOOL. SOME OF MY FRIENDS HAD
WAS A TA IN HIS CLASS AND HAD A
GREAT LOVE FOR BRINGING THE ART
OF MEDICINE INTO EDUCATION. HE
HAD FOUR DAUGHTERS THREE OF
THEM WITH HIM ON THAT TRIP THAT
DAY. ANGELA ROSE SOLANO. CHRIS
ALL WHO IS A SEVENTH GRADE
TEACHER AT THAT SIERRA MIDDLE
SCHOOL. NICOLE STORM SOLANO
CHRIS ALL WHO WAS ACTUALLY ONE
OF MR GLORIA IS A CONSTITUENTS
WHO AS A YOUNG GIRL LOST HER
BOYFRIEND AND THEN HER MOM SAID
FROM THEN ON SHE LIVE LIFE
WITHOUT FEAR AND LOVE THE OCEAN
AND LOVE THE BEACH AND- MOVED
DOWN TO IMPERIAL BEACH IN WORK
THREE JOBS SO SHE COULD JUST BE
AROUND THE OCEAN AND DIVE IN.
LOVE THE OCEAN. AND THEN EVAN
MICHELLE SOLANO PUT US ALL ALSO
A NURSE. SO FIVE PUBLIC
SERVANTS WHO GAVE THEIR LIFE TO
OTHERS WHO SERVED AND LIVE TO
HAVE TIME TO GO OFF AND DO THE
THINGS THAT THEY LOVED. AND
TOGETHER WITH A VERY CLOSE
FAMILY THERE ONE THOSE
BEAUTIFUL BLENDED FAMILIES
PARENTS HAD DIVORCED. BOTH
PARENTS HAD REMARRIED AND KIND
OF FAMILY THAT DID ALL OF
THEIR- THEIR GRADUATIONS IN
THEIR FAMILY PARTIES WITH A BIG
BLENDED FAMILY. ALL TOGETHER
OUR HEARTS ARE HEAVY FOR THE
FAMILY FOR THE LOSS FOR THE
COMMUNITY OF STOCKTON FOR SAINT
JOSEPH'S HOSPITAL WHERE THEY
WORK FOR SIERRA MIDDLE SCHOOL
WHERE CHILDREN ARE MISSING
THAT. BLUE AND PURPLE HAIRED
SCIENCE TEACHER WHO ELECTRIFIED
EVERYBODY WITH HER ENTHUSIASM
FOR LEARNING. AND OUR HEARTS
ARE WITH THEIR MOTHER. SUSAN
SOLANO PROCESS ALSO A NURSE WHO
GRIEVES THEIR LOSS. AND SAYS
THAT HER GRIEF IS NOT THERE FOR
PEOPLE TO A TO FEEL SORRY FOR
HER BUT TO SHOW THAT THE GRIEF
IS REAL AND THAT THROUGH LOVE
AND COMMUNITY. WE CAN ALL FIND
WAYS TO COME TOGETHER AND THEN
THEIR SISTER KRISTINA WHO
WASN'T WITH THEM ON THAT TRIP
THEY WERE WORKING ON A BOAT AND
DIDN'T MAKE IT. SO WITH THE
REST OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
OUR HEARTS ARE HEAVY AND AS WE
CELEBRATE THE BEAUTIFUL OCEANS
OF CALIFORNIA WE KNOW THE
DANGERS INHERENT IN THINGS THAT
WE LOVE SOMETIMES AND WE CAN
ONLY. TAKE COMFORT AND HOPE THE
FAMILY TAKES COMFORT IN KNOWING.
THAT THEY WERE TOGETHER DOING
SOMETHING THAT THEY LOVED.
THANK YOU MISS EGGMAN MISTER
STONE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOUMADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
HAVING BEEN ON THE SISTER SHIP
THE TRUTH BEEN DIVING ON THAT A
FEW TIMES IT IS TRULY
FRIGHTENING TO THINK OF THE
SITUATION THESE PEOPLE FOUND
THEMSELVES IN ON THAT NIGHT AND
I RISE ASKING THAT WE JOIN IN
MEMORY OF ALL OF THE VICTIMS
AND I GET TO HAVE TO TALK.
ABOUT A FEW WHO COME FROM MY
PART OF. THIS GREAT STATE.
SELECT A FAMILY. FAMILY OF
THREE WE'RE CELEBRATING THEIR
DAUGHTER SEVENTEENTH BIRTHDAY.
THEY WERE ENVIRONMENTALLY
ORIENTED LOVE THE OCEANS WERE
DIVING FAMILY IN FACT. GO TO
FIJI QUITE OFTEN HAD GONE TO
FEED YOU QUITE OFTEN THEY WERE
PLANNING ON GOING THERE THIS
THANKSGIVING. AGAIN TO DO SOME
DIVING THERE. SO CAROL THE
MOTHER SIXTY. AN APPLE
EMPLOYEE. PASSION FOR DIVING
AND HELPING ANIMALS IN FACT IS
VERY MUCH INVOLVED IN THE SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY ANIMAL SHELTER.
STEPHEN. SENIOR MANAGER AT
APPLE IN FACT STEVE AND CAROL
MET AT APPLE AND STARTED THEIR
FAMILY THERE HIS FRIENDS AND CO
WORKERS SAID IS ENERGETIC.
ENTHUSIASTIC ENERGY TOUCHED SO
MANY PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE
COMPANY. THEIR DAUGHTER TIA.
SEVENTEEN STARTED DIVING AT A
VERY YOUNG AGE AND HAD BEEN
SNORKELING WITH THE FAMILY IN
FIJI SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT. AND BERNIE'S PHILIPPE
SIXTEEN OF PACIFIC BOTH THE
GIRLS WERE PACIFIC COLLEGIATE
SCHOOL. CLASSMATES THERE. SHE
WAS A LONG TO DIVE INTO
CELEBRATE IN TIAS BIRTHDAY. BY
CAMPBELL FORTY ONE A FELT AND
GREW UP A COMPETITIVE SWIMMER
DAHLE HER NEW HER SHE WAS THE
WATER PRINCESS. LOVE TO BE IN
THE OCEAN IN FACT WORKED IT SO
CREEK WATER AGENCY AS AN
EDUCATOR AS SOMEBODY VERY
CONNECTED IN THE COMMUNITY
EXPLAINING HOW WATER SYSTEMS
WORK AND WATERSHEDS AND VERY
VERY MUCH A PART OF. THE
COMMUNITY SHE IS KNOWN FOR
INFECTIOUS SMILE. AND VERY
PROUDLY SERVED ALL OF THOSE
WHOM SHE EDUCATED AND WORKED
WITH. CRISTINA FINSTAD WHO
OWNED CO OWNED WORLDWIDE DIVING
ADVENTURES WITH HER BROTHER.
SHE SAYS UNDER WEBSITE MY
MISSION IS TO INSPIRE
APPRECIATION FOR UNDERWATER
WORLD. SHE DESCRIBED AS
EXTREMELY STRONG WILLED AND
ADVENTUROUS SAID IT DONE
HUNDREDS OF DIES IN THE CHANNEL
ISLANDS AS WELL AS AROUND THE
WORLD HER FIRST DIVE WITH SCUBA
GEAR WAS AT THE AGE OF NINE.
SHE STUDY DAMSEL FISH AND
CORALS IN THE TATIAN ISLANDS GO
FOR BLACK PEARLS AND THE FRENCH
POLYNESIA AND COUNTED SELMON
IT'S FOR THE CITY OF SANTA CRUZ
WHERE SHE LIVES. AND IT DOWN
QUITE A BIT OF RESEARCH IN
AUSTRALIA AND ALSO WROTE THE
RESTORATION GUIDEBOOK THAT SOME
OF US MIGHT BE FAMILIAR WITH
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL
COMMISSION. SO ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF OTHER BAY AREA
LEGISLATORS LAS FOLKS FROM
MARIN. FROM SAN JOSE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO I ASKED THAT WE ALL
ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY OF
THOSE LOST IN THIS TRAGIC EVENT.
THANK YOU MISTER STONE MISS
WORKS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I TO
RISE TODAY. AND ASKED THAT WE
DURING THE MEMORY OF TWO OF MY
CONSTITUENTS FROM BERKELEY
YULIA QUESTION IDEA AND DANIEL
GARCIA WHO PERISHED IN THE
TRAGIC CONCEPTION BOAT FIRE.
REALLY IT WAS FORTY YEARS OLD
AND SHE WAS A PRODUCTION
PRODUCTION MANAGER AT SPIRALING
SO IT WAS AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF
BERKELEY'S IT BY NOTHING GROUP
THAT ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO GIVE
AWAY THINGS THEY DON'T NEED.
AND TO OFFER SERVICES TO THEIR
NEIGHBORS SHE IS ROB REMEMBERED
IS VERY THOUGHTFUL WELCOMING
AND KIND. DANIEL GARCIA WHO WAS
FORTY SIX YEARS OLD WAS AN
ENGINEER AT APPLE. AND IS
REMEMBERED BY THOSE WHO KNEW
HIM AS A BRILLIANT CO WORKER
AND A DEEPLY CARING FRIEND.
YULIA AND DANIEL ENJOY THE
WATER AND WERE AVID DIVERS AND
UNDERWATER PHOTOGRAPHERS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN DIVES AROUND
THE WORLD. IT WILL BE GREATLY
MISSED BY THEIR FRIENDS AND
FAMILY. I ASK THAT THIS HOUSE
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF YOU
LEAH AND DANIEL AND ALL OF THE
SIX VICTIMS OF THIS TRAGIC VOTE
FIRE. THANK YOU MISS WAX MISTER
KANSEN CHU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY ALL
FLEEING SCHUNK WHO WAS ONE OF
THE VICTIMS WHO LOST HER LIFE
ON ON THE BOAT. MISS LANE WAS
PHONE FREMONT AND SHOULD LIVE
LIFE TO THE FULLEST. SHOWN LOVE
TO ALL DOORS AND WAS OFTEN
FOUND HIKING WING SERVING AND
SCUBA DIVING SHE WAS A FELLOW
ENGINEERS AND WAS A STRONG
ADVOCATE FOR WOMAN IN TACK. MS
LANE SURVIVED BY HER FATHER
MOTHER AND OLDER BROTHER WHO
ALL LIVE IN BEIJING. IS MY
HEARTFELT CONDOLENCES TO SHOWN
SLOPE ONCE AND FAMILY MEMBERS
AND ALL THOSE WHO LOST THEIR
LIVES AND FRIENDS SAM AND LOVE
ONES DUE TO DO IS HORRIFICALLY
VOTE FIRE SOLD MEMBER PLEASE
HELP US. IN JORDAN IN MEMORY OF
ALL THOSE PEOPLE DIED LIFE GOT
TAKEN AWAY TOO SOON. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER TO MEMBERS
PLEASE RISE AS WE OBSERVE A
MOMENT OF SILENCE ON BEHALF OF
ALL THE VICTIMS OF THE
CONCEPTION DIVE BOAT FIRE
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS MADE MEMORIES
OF ALL THOSE LOST IN THIS FIRE
BE A BLESSING. MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAMES TO THE DESK TO
BE PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUESTS TO JOURNEY MEMORY WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL
. MEMBERS PRESENT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT TWO I'M REFERRING THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO COMMITTEE AB
NINE TWENTY PETRIE-NORRIS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. AND AB SEVEN
THIRTY BERMAN TO ELECTIONS AND
REDISTRICTING
. MISTER CALDERON
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. TO DO SEVEN SEVEN
TWO. THANKS. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ALL REAL SIXTY TWO IN THE FALL
NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
FOLLOWING COMMITTEES TO MEET
TODAY UPON CALL THE CHAIR
NATURAL RESOURCES HERE AB
THIRTY EIGHT WHAT
APPROPRIATIONS HERE A. B. NINE
TWENTY PETRIE-NORRIS AND
ELECTIONS REDISTRICTING TO HEAR
AB SEVEN THIRTY BERMAN WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER AND ALSO REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO WITHDRAW
AB FIVE NINETY A BLOOM FROM THE
FROM ENROLLMENT AND HOLD THE
BILL OF DESK. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER
.
MEMBERS. MR COOLEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED MISTER CALDERON
STATUS. COLLEAGUES IT SAY VERY
SINGULAR READING WE HAVE AS WE
WRAP UP OUR WORK OF TWENTY
NINETEEN. AND. MARKS THE
PASSING OF A LONG. PART OF OUR
INSTITUTION WITH DOTSON
WILSON'S RETIREMENT. AFTER
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS OF SERVING
IN THESE CHAMBERS. AND. YOU
KNOW WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT
THIS IS SUCH A UNIQUE PLACE WE
HAVE THE CHAMBERS WE HAVE THE
CARPET WE RESTRICT WHO CAN
ARRIVE HERE AS YOU WELL KNOW AT
THE END OF WHEN SESSIONS
CONCLUDED PEOPLE CANNOT COME
INTO THE CHAMBERS UNTIL THE
MEMBERS OF LAUGHED. WHICH WE
REFER TO THIS THE PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR. WE RISE FEARING
THESE OFFICES WE ARE THE
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. AND SO
FOR TWENTY SEVEN YEARS DOTSON
HAS PRESIDED IN A UNIQUE WAY.
OVER THIS INSTITUTION OVER THE
PROVISIONS OF THE FOR OVER THE
CONDUCT OF OUR BUSINESS. AND
HELPING US THROUGH ROUGH
PATCHES CHALLENGING PATCHES TO
MAINTAIN A EQUILIBRIUM IN A.
COLLEGIALITY AND AN ABILITY TO
MOVE FORWARD SO TONIGHT IS AS
WE MARK THIS OCCASION. AND THIS
SPECIAL PRIVILEGE ASSOCIATE
WITH THE CHAMBERS AND THE FLOOR
WE REALIZE THAT. AS SHE IS
ENTERED INTO OUR HEARTS SO OUR
HEARTS OF INTERNET HIM AND WE
HAVE A SPECIAL GIFT TO
RECOGNIZE HIM TONIGHT. SO
MISTER DOTSON WILSON
. THANK YOU
DODD SENATE'S OUR LAST NIGHT
TOGETHER WITH YOU AND IT I KNOW
THAT IS THIS IS YOUR FIRST TIME
I HAVE BENEFITTED FROM YOUR
WISDOM AND GUIDANCE AS HAS
EVERYONE ON THIS FLOOR. SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE
SERVICE
. MEMBERS THE ELECTIONS
AND REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE
WILL BE MEETING NOW IN THE
RULES ROOM IF YOU ARE ON THE
ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEE I ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
GO TO THE WORLD ROOM FOR. A
COMMITTEE HEARING
. AGAIN
ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING
WILL BE MEETING IN THE ROLES
ROOM
. THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WILL MEET
IMMEDIATELY IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE ROOM APPROPRIATIONS
MEMBERS PLEASE HEAD TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE ROOM THANK YOU
.
THE LABOR COMMITTEE WILL NOW
MEET IN THE ASSEMBLY RULES
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY LABOR COMMITTEE PLEASE
PROCEED TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
ROOM THANK YOU
. WITHOUT
OBJECTION MISTER MULLIN PLEASE
PROCEED
. MEMBERS WE ARE BACK IN
SESSION. MEMBERS PLEASE RETURN
TO THE FLOOR WE'RE BACK IN
SESSION
. MR BLOOM FOR WHAT
PURPOSE DO YOU RISE TO MAKE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT YES SIR MR Là I'D
LIKE TO ANNOUNCE THAT THE
NATIONAL LEAGUE CHAMPS FOR THE
SEVENTH CONSECUTIVE YEAR. THE
LOS ANGELES DODGERS AT JUST BE
IN THE NEW YORK METS NINETY TWO.
THAT IS OUT OF. MR LACKEY FOR
WHAT PURPOSE THE RICE HAVE A
QUESTION FOR THE ANNOUNCER.
WITHOUT OBJECTION MISTER LACKEY.
I KNOW OF THE BEDROOM MANY
WORLD SERIES IN THE RECENT PAST
HOW LONG IS A BIT SINCE THEY'VE
ACTUALLY SPORTED A READING THE
ONE I'M COUNTING IS THE ONE
THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IN
OCTOBER. FIFTY MEMBERS WE ARE
BACK IN SESSION WILL PROCEED
WITH THE SUPPLEMENTAL FILE. YES
FILE ITEM TO A ONE ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE THIRTY NINE LEE MON.
WORK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE THIRTY NINE BY SOMETHING
MEMBER LOW MOAN AND OTHERS AND
I PLAN TO CONSUMER LOAN. MISS
LIMóN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB FIVE
THIRTY NINE HAS HAD HAD A LONG
JOURNEY TO GET TO THIS ASSEMBLY
FLOOR FOR THE CONCURRENCE IT'S
BEEN DECADES IN THE MAKING AND
TWO YEARS OF AUTHORSHIP WITH
THE WORK OF MANY MEMBERS ON
THIS FLOOR MEMBERS REPRESENTING
CONSERVE CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
MEMBERS REPRESENTING SAN DIEGO
AND TO MEMBERS REPRESENTING THE
SAN JOSE AREA I WANT TO THINK
EVERYONE WHO'S BEEN INVOLVED IN
SUPPORTIVE. PREDATORY LENDING
HAS BEEN AN ISSUE IN OUR STATE
FOR A VERY LONG TIME AND AB
FIVE THIRTY NINE BRINGS FORWARD
A BILL THAT'S A COMPROMISE BILL
THAT WOULD CAP LOANS BETWEEN
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED AND TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS AT 36% THE
BILL HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN BOTH HOUSES AND
COMES TO YOU AS A HISTORIC BILL
SENATE AMENDMENTS AT
REQUIREMENTS FOR LENDERS A
SMALL DOLLAR INSTALLMENT LOANS
TO OFFER BARS A CREDIT
EDUCATION PROGRAM PRIOR TO
GIVING THEM LOANS. AND REPORT
BARS PAYMENT HISTORY TO GET
CREDIT BUREAUS SO THAT
CONSUMERS HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO IMPROVE THEIR CREDIT SCORES
AND EVENTUALLY CALL QUALIFY FOR
LOWER COST OPTIONS FROM BANKS
OR CREDIT UNIONS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. MR GRAYSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I ALSO RISE AS
A PROUD JOINT AUTHOR OF AB FIVE
THIRTY NINE. MY PARTNER HERE'S
BEEN ABSOLUTELY AWESOME PERSON
TO WORK WITH AND DELIGHT AND
I'M HONORED WE CAME HERE TO THE
CAPITOL TO HELP PEOPLE. AND
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL
OF US OR AS MANY AS CAN TO COME
TOGETHER TO PROVIDE THE HELP SO
THAT THOSE THAT FACE FINANCIAL
CRISIS. DO NOT BECOME VICTIMS
AGAIN AND WE HAVE TO ASK
OURSELVES ARE WE GIVING PEOPLE
ACCESS TO CAPITAL OR WE GIVING
DEBT COLLECTORS ACCESS TO
PEOPLE SO COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON AB FIVE THREE NINE.
MEMBERS IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK PLEASE RAISE YOUR MIND.
MISTER SPEAKER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
THIRTY NINE AS WELL THIS BILL
CONTINUES TO BE A MORAL ISSUE.
IF YOU SAY YOU'RE CONCERNED
WITH HIGH COSTS IN CALIFORNIA
YOU MUST BE DOUBLY CONCERNED
WITH PREDATORY LENDING
PRACTICES. PEOPLE WHO ARE
LIVING PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK AND
MUST BORROW FOR UNEXPECTED
EXPENSES FIND THOSE EXPENSES
RISE FASTER THAN EVERY OTHER
EXPENSE BECAUSE OF INDEFENSIBLE
INTEREST RATES AS I SAID MAY
BORROWING IS NORMAL WE ALL DO
IT WITH CREDIT CARDS ARE HOME
LOANS. MELONES OFFERED AT RATES
THAT COURTS HAVE ALREADY FOUND
UNDER REASONABLE DO NOT HELP.
BORROWERS AT RISK. THERE ARE
WAYS TO ENABLE FOR PROFITABLE
LOANS WITHOUT DRIVING PEOPLE
DEEPER INTO DEBT THIS BILL
HELPS US TO DO IT I ASK YOU TO
VOTE I ON AB FIVE THIRTY NINE.
THIS LIMóN YOU MAKE LESS.
MEMBERS AS HAS BEEN SAID MANY
AT DECADES THIS BILL HAS BEEN
IN THE MAKING AND I APPRECIATE
ALL THE EFFORTS THE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I HOPE THAT TODAY
WE WILL VOTE TO SEND THIS BILL
TO THE GOVERNOR WHICH WILL BE
THE RIGHT THING TO DO FOR
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS IT'S THE
RIGHT THING TO DO FOR OUR
STATE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. CLERK MAY OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRED ABOUT. THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN. LOCAL
CALLS CLOSE THE ROLAND TELL
ABOUT. AYE AYES FIFTY NINE NO
SEVEN THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED. AND YOUR TRUSTY
ASSISTANT SPEAKER PRO TEM IS
BACK. MOVING IN DOWN IN THE
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE WE WILL MOVE
TO FILE ITEM TWO OH TWO EIGHTY
FIVE TWENTY EIGHT. THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
TWENTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LOW AND ACTUALLY THE CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES MR LOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THIS IS. OUR TEARS
PRESCRIPTION DATA REPORTING
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY VOTE AYE AYES
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN BY
LEADING TO A THREE EIGHTY
FIFTEEN NINETEEN CLERK WILL
READ AS A LEGAL FIFTEEN
NINETEEN BY FAMILY MEMBER LOW
AND ACTUALLY THE HEALING ARTS
MR LOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS THIS IS THE DENTAL
BOARD SUNSET. EXTENSION WHICH
INCLUDES A NUMBER OF CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE SAFE ACCESS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS YOUR SPECTER THE
BILL THE TO PAY RESPECTFULLY
ASK PRIVATE. THANK YOU MISTER
LOS SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK. WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS ART OF THE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ON MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR
TO VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY VOTE I SIXTY NINE
NO ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM TO A FOR
A BI FIFTEEN TWENTY THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
TWENTY BY SOME THE MEMBER LOW
AND ACTUALLY TO PROFESSIONS AND
VOCATIONS MAKING A PREPARATION
THEREFORE THROUGH LOW YOU ARE
AGAIN RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MAN SPEAKER THIS IS THEIR
COURT REPORTERS BOARD SEND SET
EXTENSION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
LOWE SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL. OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERVE A.
FILE ITEM TWO OH FIVE A. B.
FIFTEEN TWENTY TO THE CLERK
WILL READ. AS A LEGAL FIFTEEN
TWENTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LOW AND ACTUALLY TO PROFESSIONS
IMPLICATIONS MR LOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS IS
THE FINAL BOARD SUNSET FOR THE-
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEERS LAND
SURVEYORS AND GEOLOGISTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER LOS
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALLY THAT I SEVENTY THREE NO
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. FILE ITEM TWO OH SIX AB ONE
SIXTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SIXTEEN VICE
ONLY MEMBER TING AND ACTUALLY
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT THIRTEEN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR SPEAKER
AB ONE SIXTEEN IS OUR WAS
ORIGINALLY PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET
PROPOSAL WHERE HE INTRODUCED
ENHANCED INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICT. IF THEY
FOLLOW UP FROM SENATOR BELLS
BILL SB SIX TO EIGHT WHICH
ENSHRINED. IN FRONT
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
ENHANCE INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING DISTRICTS INTO LAW IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN AND YOU'LL
RECALL THAT THIS WAS AN ANSWER
FOR US TO BUILD INFRASTRUCTURE
AFTER LOCALS LOST THE TOOL OF
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCIES ALL WHAT
THE TWENTY FOURTEEN LAW DID WAS
TO IN STRIDE INTO LAW A VOTE OF
THE PEOPLE. WHEN WE DO BONDS AN
ACTUAL CALL REBEL REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES DIDN'T HAVE THAT SAME
HURDLE THEY DIDN'T HAVE TO GO
AND ASK THE PEOPLE FOR A VOTE
WHEN THEY WANTED TO DO BOND SO
THIS WILL TAKE THAT VOTE OUT
BUT IT DOES PUT BACK INTO LAW A
PROCESS SIMILAR TO WHAT WE DO
WITH. ALL THE DIFFERENT LAUGH
CLOSE AROUND THE STATE SO THAT
IF THERE IS CONCERN OFFICER
NUMBER PEOPLE DO HAVE CONCERN
THAT THEY CAN GO AND PUT THAT
UP FOR A VOTE BY THE PEOPLE SO
WITH THAT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE ON AB ONE SIXTY.
YOU MISTER TANG SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLL. CALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE EYES FORTY TWO
KNOWS TWENTY TWENTY TWO. SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. BY
LATE INTO A SEVEN AB SEVEN
TWENTY THREE THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN TWENTY
THREE BY THE ONLY MEMBER QUIRK
AND ACTUALLY TAXATION. SIR
QUIRK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU SPEAKER IN MEMBERS AB SEVEN
TWENTY THREE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AFTER MAKING SOME
CHANGES TO THE BELL. WITH THE
ASSISTANCE OF THE GOVERNOR. AB
SEVEN TWENTY THREE MAKES
CHANGES TO HOW THE TRANSACTION
AND USE TAX. OUR CAP IS
CALCULATED FOR ALAMEDA AND
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY. MEASURES
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS CITY
OF SCOTTS VALLEY HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY. AND THE COUNTY OF
ALAMEDA I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DOCTOR
QUIRK SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. WHERE
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
VOTE AYE AYES FORTY SEVEN KNOWS
NINETEENTH SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM TWO
OH EIGHT AB TWELVE NINETY THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE NINETY BY SOMETHING
MEMBER GLORIA AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO WATER MR GLORIA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT TO YOU AB TWELVE NINETY
AUTHORED BY MYSELF AND SENATE
PRESIDENT PRO TEM TONI ATKINS
IT IS AN IMPORTANT PROJECT TO
SAN DIEGO'S WATER SECURITY IT'S
SUPPORT OF WHAT'S KNOWN BACK AT
HOME AS PURE WATER. THE DAY'S
BEEN LONG IT IS OUR FINAL DAY
SESSION YOU MAY NOT WANT THE
DETAILS AT THE END OF THE DAY.
THIS IS ABOUT WATER SECURITY
FOR SAN DIEGO WATER
INDEPENDENCE AND I PUT IT TO MY
COLLEAGUES WHO DON'T HAVE THE
HONOR REPRESENTS A DIEGO EVERY
GALLON OF WATER WE CREATE SAN
DIEGO IS A GALLON WE DON'T TAKE
FROM YOU YOUR VOTE TODAY WILL
HELP US. BECOME WATER
INDEPENDENT I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL ABOUT
MYSELF AND CENTER ATKINS PLEASE
VOTE HI. ON A. B. TWELVE NINETY.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THIRTY VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE EYES FIFTY FIVE KNOWS
FOURTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. BY LATE IN TWO
OWN NINE AB ONE EIGHTY ONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THAT'S ONLY A
ONE EIGHTY ONE BY FAMILY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN AND ACTUALLY THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE. MR MAIENSCHEIN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AB ONE EIGHTY ONE
RECONCILES THE CONFLICT BETWEEN
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW BY
CLARIFYING THAT MILITARY
HAZARDOUS WASTE FACILITIES ARE
NOT REQUIRED TO PAY ADVANCE
FEES FOR PERMIT APPLICATIONS TO
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL AB ONE
AB ONE WILL ENABLE MILITARY
HAZARDOUS WASTE FACILITIES TO
CONTINUE OPERATING THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERTED
BOTH. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
THEIR TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLAND TALLY VOTE I
SEVENTY NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM TO TEN AB EIGHTEEN
TWENTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN TWENTY
FIVE BY THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION AND
ACTUALLY THE ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE
CONTROL. MR GRAY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. MEMBERS WHEN.
YOU'VE GOT CHAPLAIN PROBLEMS IN
RF. LEADS THE B. C. TO BRING A
C. B. IT'S AT THAT MOMENT THAT
YOU REALIZE HI. EQUALS MP. FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO. DON'T KNOW
OUR GOOD FRIEND IRWIN. WHO IS
RETIRING THIS YEAR FOR THE
SENATE THAT'S IN HIS HONOR.
THIS IS BIGGER MEMBERS AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY FIVE ZERO SAN
WOULD YOUR COMMITTEE BILL IT
MAKES NON CONTROVERSIAL CHANGES
TO THE A. B. C. ACT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER GRAY SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE THIRD OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. QUIRK
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE
AYE SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM TO ELEVEN AB SIXTY
EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY TO LAND USE THE
THIRTEEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MUST BE GRAY BE SIXTY
EIGHT IS BACK ON CONCURRENT
SENATE AMENDMENTS PROVIDED
GUIDANCE. FOR APPROVALS OF
EIGHTY USE ON LOTS WITH SEPTIC
SYSTEMS AND THE MULTI FAMILY
BUILDINGS MOVING OPPOSITION
FROM CEASE ACT A. P. A. IN THE
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA
THE REST THE AMENDMENTS WERE
CLARIFYING. AN ADDRESS CHAPLAIN
ISSUES WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FIVE. THANK YOU MISTER KING
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE WRONG. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED AS ARE THE- ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE
MEMBERS THIRTY THIRTY VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY SEVEN
KNOWS FOR SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM TO
TWELVE EIGHTY SIX FIFTY ONE THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SIX FIFTY ONE BUY SOMETHING
MEMBER GRAYSON AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY AIR AMBULANCE SERVICES.
GRAYSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB SIX FIFTY ONE
WILL EXTEND FUNDING FOR
EMERGENCY ERR AMBULANCE
PROVIDER OF PROVIDERS AND
PROJECT CALIFORNIA PATIENTS
AGAINST BALANCE BILLING
PRACTICES. WELL I FULLY INTEND
TO FIND A LONG TERM SOLUTION IN
THE COMING YEAR BY WORKING WITH
ALL RELEVANT PARTIES THIS BILL
PROVIDES. AIR AMBULANCE
SERVICES THE FUNDING THEY NEED
TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THIS
LIFESAVING SERVICES IN THE
INTERIM SO THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER GRAYSON
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE WRONG. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRED. ALL
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE I SEVENTY TWO NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM TO
THIRTEEN AB SEVEN FORTY FOR THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN FORTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
ACTUALLY TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE. IS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB SEVEN FORTY
FOUR IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
WITH AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE
THAT DELAY IMPLEMENTATION AND
CLARIFY THE PROCESS FOR PLANTS
A PROVIDERS TO NEGOTIATE
REIMBURSES REIMBURSEMENT RATES
FOR TELEHEALTH SERVICES. ALL
CALIFORNIANS SHOULD HAVE ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE REGARDLESS OF
THEIR LOCATION AND PROVIDER
SHOULD BE INCENTIVIZE TO EXPAND
THE REACH WHETHER PROVIDER SEES
A PATIENT IN PERSON OR THROUGH
A VIDEO CONFERENCE THEY SHOULD
BE PAID FOR THE WORK. AB SEVEN
FORTY FOUR WHEEL PARTICULARLY
HELP CALIFORNIANS AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED AREAS AND THOSE
HAVE BEEN DISPLACED. BY NATURAL
DISASTERS I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ASIDE HERE
CURRY MISTER MATHIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. IN OUR
ROLE COMMUNITIES THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE WAYS WHERE WE CAN ENSURE
ACCESS FOR ALL. AND AS WE
APPROACH AND WE LOOK AT THESE
THINGS WITH HEALTHCARE THIS IS
THAT PIECE THAT WERE MISSING IN
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY THIS
IS THAT PIECE THAT ENSURES THAT
NO MATTER WHERE YOU'RE AT. IN
OUR GREAT STATE THAT YOU CAN BE
ABLE TO TALK TO YOU AND SEE A
DOCTOR. IT'S ABOUT TIME WE STEP
UP AND GET THIS DONE SO THAT
WAY EVERYBODY HAS ACCESS I ASK
YOU FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS GO
TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
WORK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THAT I SEVENTY TWO NEWS
HERE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN BY LIGHTING TO
FOURTEEN AB AT ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
AND ACTUALLY THE HOUSING MISTER
BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB EIGHT
EIGHT ONE IS HERE ON
CONCURRENCE. THE AMENDMENTS
WERE TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING
AND YES IRWIN THAT THEY ADDRESS
CHAPTER RING OUT ISSUES WITH
THE OTHER THREE A DO YOU BILLS.
SO THEY'RE ALL KOSHER THANKS
ARE NGUYEN. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I'VE A THANK YOU MISTER
BLOOM SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESERVE IT. ON MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
WILL PASS TEMPORARILY NINE TO
FIFTEEN ITEM TO SIXTEEN AB
ELEVEN SIXTEEN THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL LEVIN
SIXTEEN BY SELLING MEMBER
GRAYSON ANOTHER'S AND ACTUALLY
THE FIREFIGHTERS. THE REASON
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN SIXTEEN IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE THIS BILL
WILL STATUS STATEWIDE STANDARDS
FOR FIREFIGHTER PEER SUPPORT
PROGRAMS AND PROVIDE FOR
CONFIDENTIAL COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN TRAINED PEER SUPPORT
TEAM MEMBERS AND THEIR FELLOW
FIREFIGHTERS. SENATE AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY WHO WILL DELIVER THE
PEER SUPPORT TRAINING PROGRAM
GUIDELINES AND MERRY MERRILY
TAYLOR THE CONFIDENTIALITY
PROVISIONS OF THE PROGRAM'S
CURRENT OR CREATED PURSUANT TO
THE ACT SO AB ELEVEN SIXTEEN
WILL INCREASE THE AVAILABILITY
AND USE OF PEER SUPPORT
SERVICES. HELPING THEM TO
IDENTIFY A POTENTIAL HIGH RISK
SITUATION BEFORE THE CRISIS
EVENT OCCURS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER GRAYSON SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
DESERVE A. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESERTED BOTH. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. WHERE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
.
MEMBERS WERE AT FILE NUMBER
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO FIFTEEN AB
ONE TEN EIGHTY SIX THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
EIGHTY SIX BY FAMILY MEMBER
BARKING AND IN OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO PARKS AND
RECREATION. MISSED OUR CAN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER TODAY I'M PRESENTING AB
TEN EIGHTY SIX ON CONCURRENT
IT'S A DISTRICT BILL THE CLEARS
UP AMBIGUITY AUTHORIZING NOT
REQUIRING THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS TO SELL THE
ALAMEDA TESLA EXPANSIONARY AT
THE CARNEGIE STATE METICULOUS
RECREATION AREA. IF THE SALE IS
IN THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
PUBLIC THIS PARK IS RICH IN
BIOLOGICAL AND CULTURAL VALUE
AND THE SALE OF THE LAND WOULD
PROVIDE. QUALITY ECOLOGICAL
PROJECTIONS AND ALLOW ALL
VISITORS ACCESS TO THE LAND AND
THE BILL STATE THE LAND SHALL
NOT BE SOLD FOR LESS THAN WHAT
THE ORIGINAL PURCHASE PRICE WAS
AND THE PROCEEDS PROCEEDS OF
THE SALE SHALL GO TO THE OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE TRUST FUND.
THIS BILL DOESN'T AFFECT THE
CURRENT OFFERED VEHICLE PARKING
NEXT DOOR AND THAT PARK IS SEEN
A SIGNIFICANT DECLINE IN USE
OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS SO WE
WOULD LIKE TO GIVE PARKS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESERVE THIS
IMPORTANT IMPORTANT
ENVIRONMENTAL LAND. THE BILL
ENJOYS A BROAD RANGE OF SUPPORT
IT IS SUPPORTED BY THE SIERRA
CLUB THE LOCAL COUNTY AND CITY
EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT
THIS SOCIETY OF AMERICAN
INTERESTS INDIANS. THE NORTH
VALLEY YUCK IT'S TRIBE AND THEN
IT. AND I APOLOGIZE IN ADVANCE
FOR NOT SAYING THIS PROPERLY
THE NEW. TO WANT ME. NO.
CULTURAL PRESERVATION YOU'RE
ALL LISTENING WHO KNEW YOU ALL
LISTEN TO ME SO WELL I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
THAT. THANK YOU MS B<c.cyan> QUE</c>
HAN. SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLICK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTES AYE AYES FIFTY KNOWS
NINETEEN. THE MEMBERS OF THE
PERCENT AMENDMENTS ART
CONCURRED WITH
. MEMBERS WILL
TAKE A BRIEF RECESS UNDER CALL
OF THE SPEAKER. PLEASE REMAIN
ON THE CARPET. WE'LL CALL YOU
BACK AS SOON AS WE CAN
. MEMBERS
WE ARE BACK IN SESSION WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE UP THE
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE. WE'RE TAKING
OF SOMEONE FILE NUMBER TWO
MEMBERS PLEASE RETURN TO THE
FLOOR SO THAT WE CAN. CONDUCT
THIS BUSINESS
. MEMBERS. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE A FILE ITEM THREE
A ONE AB NINE TWENTY THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
TWENTY BY SOME THE MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS AND OTHERS
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC HEALTH. IS
PETRIE-NORRIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI NINE TWENTY.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS SPELL IS TO
PROTECTPATIENTS WHO ARE IN
RECOVERY SEEKING SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENTS. THE SCOPE AND
SCALE OF CALIFORNIANS AMERICA'S
OPIOID CRISIS IS STAGGERING
ACCORDING TO THE CDC EACH AND
EVERY DAY HUNDRED AND THIRTY
PEOPLE LOSE THEIR LIVES BECAUSE
OF OPIOIDS. THIS NOW MAKES W.
AIDS AT TOP FIVE LEADING CAUSE
OF DEATH ACROSS THIS NATION.
THE SIMPLE FACT IS THAT OUR
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK HAS NOT
CAUGHT UP WITH THE SCOPE AND
SCALE OF THIS CRISIS. EIGHTY
NINE TWENTY IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AB
NINE TWENTY WILL REQUIRE THAT
ALL OUT PATIENTS SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENT FACILITIES ARE
LICENSED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. THIS BILL
HAS ENJOYED BROAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS PETRIE-NORRIS SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER. DEBATE THE
CLERK MAY OPEN THE ROLE ALL
MEMBERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
MEMBERS THIRTY THIRTY VOTE.
WHERE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY ONE NO
ZERO SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM THREE OH TWO AB
FOURTEEN HUNDRED THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
HUNDRED BY SOME THE MEMBER
KAMLAGER-DOVE THAN OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO EMPLOYEE SAFETY.
COME OVER TO HAVE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU GOOD
EVENING MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED IS
BACK FROM SENATE CONCURRENCE.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
COMMISSION ON HEALTH AND SAFETY
AND WORKERS COMPENSATION IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES AND RELEVANT LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS. TO SUBMIT A
STUDY ON THE RISK OF EXPOSURE
TO CARCINOGENIC MATERIALS AND
INCIDENCE OF OCCUPATIONAL
CANCER AND FIRE EQUIPMENT
MECHANICS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISS
COME LONGER DEV SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE RESERVE A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED AS ARE THE- CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY VOTE I
SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING A FILE ITEM THREE OH
THREE AB TWO OH ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL TO A
ONE BY FAMILY MEMBERS CERVANTES
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR IT'S
AROUND HIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TO DAM PRESENT IN AB
TWO OH ONE FOR CONCURRENCE AND
SENATE AMENDMENTS THIS BILL
WILL ENSURE THAT THERE ARE
RULES REQUIRE AN APPROPRIATE
DISCLOSURES ON CAMPAIGN TEXT
MESSAGES. THIS WAS BURGER AS
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON
THE SENATE FLOOR RESPECTFULLY
ASK FREE AYE VOTE. INCLUDED MY
THREE BABIES. ON THE SENATE.
THANK YOU MESS AROUND HIS AND
HER THREE BABIES. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED DESERTED BOAT.
WHERE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES SIXTY
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM THREE OH
FOUR EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY ONE THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SIX EIGHTY ONE BY SOME REMEMBER
GONZALEZ AND ACTUALLY TO
ELECTIONS DECLARING THE URGENCY
THERE UP TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY RISK IN DALLAS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU AB SIX
EIGHTY ONE WOULD PROVIDE
CALIFORNIA VOTERS NOTICE BEFORE
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY WITH KEY
INFORMATION TO REDUCE VOTER
CONFUSION. OVER THE PRIMARY
PROCESS AND SIMPLIFY CERTAIN
UPDATES OF PARTY PREFERENCE IN
ADDRESS TO ENSURE ACCESS TO THE
BALLOT MEMANTINE SENATE
STREAMLINED THE NOTICES UNDER
THIS BILL WITH EXISTING
MAILINGS AND SIMPLIFY THE
PROCESS FOR VOTERS TO UPDATE
THEIR PARTY PREFERENCE OR
ADDRESS THIS BILL RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THE ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE A FEW MINUTES AGO AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER CELIS
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL. OPEN THE- ALL MEMBERS
VOTE RESERVE A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE HE DESIRED. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL. LOSE THEIR ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE I FIFTY SIX NO
THIRTEEN ON THE URGENCY EYES
FIFTY SIX NO THIRTEEN ON THE
BILL SENATE MEMBERS ARE
CONCURRED IN. FILE ITEM THREE
OH FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN THIRTY BY FAMILY MEMBER
BERMAN AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
TO ELECTIONS MR BERMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES. AB
SEVEN THIRTY SIX TO PROTECT THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTIONS AS
WE HEAD INTO TWENTY TWENTY. AS
MORE MORE BAD ACTORS TRY TO
INFLUENCE OUR ELECTIONS WITH
MISINFORMATION CAMPAIGNS THAT
SO CONFUSION AND DOUBT WITH
VOTERS I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE
THAT VOTERS HAVE A RIGHT TO
KNOW WHEN VIDEO AUDIO AND
IMAGES THAT THEY ARE BEING
SHOWN HAVE BEEN MANIPULATED AND
DO NOT REPRESENT REALITY. THIS
IS BECOME MORE CHALLENGING WITH
THE INVENTION OF THE FAKES
WHICH ARE EXTREMELY CONVINCING
FABRICATED PHOTOS VIDEOS AND
AUDIO RECORDINGS A SOMEONE
APPEARING TO SAY OR DO
SOMETHING THEY DID NOT ACTUALLY
SAY OR DO. AB SEVEN THIRTY
WOULD PROHIBIT A PERSON
COMMITTEE OR ENTITY WITHIN
SIXTY DAYS OF AN ELECTION FROM
DISTRIBUTING WITH ACTUAL MALICE
MATERIALLY DECEPTIVE AUDIO OR
VISUAL MEDIA WITH THE INTENT TO
INJURE THE CANDIDATES
REPUTATION OR TO DECEIVE A
VOTER. IN THE VOTING FOR OR
AGAINST THE CANDIDATE UNLESS
THE MEDIA INCLUDES A DISCLOSURE
STATING THAT IT HAS BEEN
MANIPULATED. WITH THE TWENTY
TWENTY ELECTIONS AROUND THE
CORNER WE MUST DO MORE TO CURB
THE PROLIFERATION OF DEEP
FAKES. AND OTHER MANIPULATE A
MEDIA I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
BERMAN. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS ARTICLE. THE CLERK
WILL. CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE AYE AYES SIXTY KNOWS
THREE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN
. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE BACK TO THE
SENATE THIRD READING
. WE ARE
GOING TO BE BACK TO THE SENATE
THIRD READING FILE FILE ITEM
NUMBER FORTY SB FOUR FORTY TWO
THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
FOR FORTY TWO BY SENATOR DODD
AND ACTUALLY THE STATE PARKS.
MR MEDINA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS. SB FOUR FORTY TWO
WOULD AUTHORIZE THE DEPARTMENT
OF PARKS AND RECREATION TO
PROVIDE A LIMITED IT A LIMITED
EXCEPTION FOR CERTAIN
INDIVIDUALS AND QUALIFIED
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION TO COMMERCIALIZE
DISCOVERIES DERIVING FROM
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS. SB FOUR
FORTY TWO WILL LIKELY GENERATE
REVENUE FOR THE DEPARTMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL LOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SEVENTY FOUR
NEWS ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MISS MELENDEZ IS VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THE NEXT MEASURE
APPARENTLY. ITEM FORTY ONE SB
FIVE NINETY FIVE THE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL FIVE NINETY
FIVE MESSENGER BRADFORD AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY CANNABIS MR
BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES SB FIVE NINETY FIVE
BY SENATOR BRADFORD WILL ENABLE
INDIVIDUALS FROM DIVERSE
BACKGROUNDS AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES TO PARTICIPATE IN
CALIFORNIA'S LEGALIZE CANNABIS.
INDUSTRY SPECIFICALLY SB FIVE
NINETY FIVE REQUIRES THE THREE
STATE LICENSING AUTHORITIES TO
DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT A PROGRAM
TO WAIVE ORDER FOR LICENSING
FEES FOR LOCAL EQUITY
APPLICANTS AND LICENSEES
ULTIMATELY THIS MEASURE WILL
HELP GROW AND DIVERSIFY
CALIFORNIA'S CANNABIS INDUSTRY
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF
SMALL BUSINESSES. BENEFIT
COMMUNITIES DEVASTATED BY
PROHIBITION AND INCREASE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND HEALTH BY
ENCOURAGING INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
OPERATING ILLEGALLY TO ENTER
OUR STATE REGULATED MARKET
PLACE SB FIVE NINETY FIVE HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER BONTA
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN. THE WRONG. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IZZARD VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHOSE ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY
FOUR KNOWS TEN THIS MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM FORTY TWO AB
SIX OH SIX THE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL SIX OH SIX MY
CENTER GLAZER AND ACTUALLY
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS MR
LOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MAN SECURE
MEMBERS THIS IS A SUNSET BILL
FOR THE CEMETERY AND FUNERAL
BUREAU AND THE BORDER OF
BARBERING IN COSMETOLOGY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE. THANK
YOU MISTER LOS SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON.
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
.
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA ENTERTAIN
VOTE CHANGES AT THIS TIME IF
YOU OF A CHANGE YOU CAN PUT
YOUR MAKE UP AND I WILL
RECOGNIZE YOU. MISSED CONOR
DOWN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR VOTE CHANGE. THANK YOU
BOTH CHANGE FROM I'D TO KNOW AB
SEVEN THREE ZERO. VOTE CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KAMLAGER-DOVE
IT'S ONLY BILL SEVEN THREE ZERO
I IT'S A NO. MISTER COOPER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. WILL CHANGE
FILE ITEM TWO ZERO ONE AB FIVE
THREE NINE FOR MISTER OF
STAYING. THE CHANGES ONLY
MEMBER COOPER ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE THIRTY NINE I IT'S NOT
VOTING. DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
VOTE CHANGES AT THIS TIME.
MISTER GIBSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR VOTE CHANGE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE OH FIVE
VOTE CHANGE. AB SEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT FROM I TO NOT VOTING. THE
CHANGES ON THE MEMBER GIPSON
ASSEMBLY WILL SEVEN THIRTY I
IT'S NOT VOTING. MR O'DONNELL
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. O'DONNELL
AB EIGHT EIGHTY ONE FROM IRAQ
TONIGHT VOTING. THE CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL IS
ONLY WILL EIGHT EIGHTY ONE I
IT'S NOT VOTING
. MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND THE RULES. AND WHEN I
LOOKED AT CHECK. TO SPEND THE
SUSPEND THE RULES TO WITHDRAW
SB ONE ATKINS FROM THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FREEDOM FRIEDMAN
TO TAKE UP THE BILL TODAY
WITHOUT REFERENCE THE FILE FOR
THE PURPOSE OF THIRD READING.
MR FLORA WE WITHHOLD UNANIMOUS
CONSENT. THERE IS A MOTION.
MISTER CALDERON IS SEEKING
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
THE RULES WE WILL. MR FLOOR IS
WITHHOLDING WE WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS
THERE TO VOTE MISTER CALDERON
IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
MISTER FLORA IS ASKING FOR A NO
VOTE. MR HOLDEN SECONDED.
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTES MR FLORA IS ASKING
FOR A NO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED AS OUR TO VOTE
. ALL
MEMBERS THERE IS THERE TO VOTE.
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR
AN I. VOTER MISTER FLORES
ASKING FOR NO BOTH IS A
PROCEDURAL MOTION. THE CLERK
WILL CLOSE. THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE ICE FIFTY ONE KNOWS
FOURTEEN. MISTER CALDERON MOVES
MOTION IS GRANTED
. MEMBERS
MISTER KALRA IS PREPARED TO
LIFT THE CALL ON FILE ITEM
TWENTY SEVEN SB THREE TWENTY
THREE THE COURT WILL POST. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THIRTY VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS
OUR TO VOTE. ON MEMBERS THIRTY
VOTE. YOU. HELLO THERE IS THERE
IS THERE IS FIRST FORTY ONE.
ALL MEMBERS. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
OUR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
DISPERSE FORTY ONE. YEAH
. ALL
MEMBERS. MYERS FORTY ONE
. AW
MEMBERS
. I FORTY ONE NEWS
TWENTY FOUR. THIS MEASURE
PASSES
. MEMBERS WHILE WE AWAIT.
ADDITIONAL BUSINESS I WOULD
LIKE TO NOTE. THAT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO WILL BE
CELEBRATING HER FIFTIETH
BIRTHDAY. WHICH IS AB COMING
THIS SUNDAY HAPPY BIRTHDAY THIS
RUBIO
. MR LACKEY FOR WHAT
PURPOSE DO YOU SIT DOWN. MR
LACKEY. REQUESTING INFORMATION
ON THE FILE THE CONDITION OF
THE FILE. I THOUGHT IT WAS
GONNA BE SOMETHING FUN. WE'LL
GET BACK TO YOU
. MR GALLAGHER
FOR WHAT PURPOSE YOU RISE.
THANK YOU SPEAKER REPORTING ON
THE CONDITION OF THE FILE
GIANTS ARE UP ONE NOTHING.
AFTER SEVEN INNINGS. POINT OF
INFORMATION WELL TAKEN
. MEMBERS
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE.
SENATE BILL ONE. CLICK READ.
SENATE BILL ONE BY SENATOR
ATKINS AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
THE PUBLIC WELFARE MISS
FRIEDMAN YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT SB ONE THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL PUBLIC HEALTH AND
WORKERS DEFENSE ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN SB ONE MAKES
FEDERAL BASELINE STANDARDS FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND WORKER
PROTECTION ENFORCEABLE AS A
MATTER OF STATE LAW WITH THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION IN
WASHINGTON DC. ROLES THEM BACK.
MEMBERS IT HAS BEEN ROUGHLY
THREE YEARS AND TWO MONTHS
SINCE THE NEW ADMINISTRATION
TOOK OFFICE IN WASHINGTON DC.
DURING THAT TIME ACCORDING TO
THE NEW YORK TIMES AND NUMEROUS
OTHER AUTHORITIES OVER THIRTY
FOUR DIFFERENT. KEY CLEAN AIR
CLEAN WATER AND ENDANGERED
SPECIES STANDARDS HAVE BEEN
WEAKENED OR ELIMINATED. AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER WAS ADOPTED TO
ROLL BACK WATER QUALITY
PROTECTIONS LIKE THE WATERS OF
THE UNITED STATES RULE ADOPTED
UNDER THE FEDERAL CLEAN WATER
IS ACT. ANOTHER EXECUTIVE ORDER
WAS ADOPTED TO ROLL BACK AUTO
FUEL EFFICIENCY STANDARDS
ADOPTED PURSUANT TO THE FEDERAL
CLEAN AIR ACT. ANOTHER
EXECUTIVE ORDER WAS ADOPTED TO
ALLOW IMPLEMENTATION OF IVORY
AND OTHER PARTS OF THREATENED
SECIES SUCH AS ELEPHANTS AND
RHINOS. STILL ANOTHER EXECUTIVE
ORDER WAS ADOPTED TO STOP
DISCLOSING TOXIC HAZARDS IN
WORKPLACES THAT DIRECTLY
AFFECTS THE HEALTH OF WORKERS.
AND SURPRISINGLY NO ONE. THE
FORMER COAL LOBBYIST NOW AT THE
HELM OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AGENCY AND THE
FORMER AGRIBUSINESS LOBBYISTS
IN CHARGE OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
THE INTERIOR ARE SYSTEMATICALLY
UNDER UNDER ENFORCING THE LAWS
THAT REMAIN. IN ADDITION I'M
FOR THE THIRD YEAR IN A ROW THE
FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION HAS
PROPOSED A BUDGET BLUEPRINT
THAT WILL REDUCE THE BUDGET OF
THE U. S. EPA. TO A POINT WHERE
THE AGENCY WOULD NO LONGER BE
ABLE TO MEANINGFULLY ENFORCED
CLEAN AIR AND WATER LAWS.
COLLEAGUES THE LIST GOES ON AND
ON. SB ONE SIMPLY PROVIDES THAT
WHATEVER ACTION THE NEW A NEW
FEDERAL THE NEW FEDERAL GENE
MAY TAKE CALIFORNIA WILL
CONTINUE TO ENFORCE THE SAME
ENVIRONMENTAL AND PUBLIC HEALTH
PROTECTIONS. THAT HAVE BEEN IN
EFFECT IN FOUR YEARS AS A
MATTER OF STATE LAW. THE
FEDERAL CLEAN AIR CLEAN WATER
SAFE DRINKING ENDANGERED
SPECIES AND WORKER PROTECTION
ACTS WERE ALL ADOPTED ON A
BIPARTISAN BASIS IN THIS
NINETEEN SEVENTIES OVER FORTY
YEARS AGO. SB ONE SIMPLY
ENSURES THAT NO BACKSLIDING
WHEN IT COMES TO THE PROTECTION
OF ARE IRREPLACEABLE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND NATURAL
RESOURCES HAPPEN. IT ALSO
ENSURES THAT WE MAINTAIN
IMPORTANT WORKER PROTECTIONS.
IT IS A. PORTER BY A BROAD
CROSS SECTION OF PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKER SAFETY ORGANIZED LABOR
BUSINESS AND ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS. MEMBERS WE ALL
REPRESENT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A DUTY 2% TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA AGAINST ALL
THREATS. INCLUDING THREATS
AGAINST THE QUALITY OF OUR AIR
OUR WATER AND OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES. SB ONE SIMPLY GIVES
CALIFORNIA THE TOOLS IT NEEDS
TO FULFILL THAT DUTY I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. NAME IS
FRIEDMAN MR MATHIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. YOU KNOW.
FROM THE ENVIRONMENTAL SIDE AND
ALL THE TALK ON THIS BILL IT IT
SOUNDS LIKE IT'S GONNA BE THIS
GREAT AMAZING THING FOR
CALIFORNIA. BUT IT'S NOT. WHAT
THIS BILL DOES. IS TURN MY AREA
OF THE STATE LITERALLY INTO A
DUST BOWL. I HAVE SOME OF THE.
HIGHEST POVERTY RATES I ONE OF
THE LARGEST LATINO IMMIGRANT
AREAS. IN THESE PEOPLE DEPEND
ON AGRICULTURAL WORK WHICH
MEANS THEY DEPEND ON WATER.
MOVING DOWN WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS A COMPLETELY ON HINGES.
DECADES. OF AGREEMENTS
ARBITRATION AND EVERYTHING ELSE
THROUGH THE WATER WARS. NOW MY
ANCESTORS AS I'VE SAID BEFORE
OR DUST BOWL LOKI'S BUT I DON'T
WANT US TO TURN INTO DUST BOWL
CALIFORNIANS. I WANT TO SEE THE
FAMILIES THAT HAVE IMMIGRATED.
INTO MY AREA. TO PURSUE A
BETTER LIFE. LOSE THAT. ALL
BECAUSE A FEW. DON'T LIKE THE
CURRENT PRESIDENT. BECAUSE
THEY'RE SCARED BECAUSE OF A
KNEE JERK REACTION. OVER KNEE
JERK REACTION BECAUSE YOU DON'T
LIKE THE CURRENT SITTING
PRESIDENT AND WHAT THEIR
ADMINISTRATIONS DOING. WE HAVE
A BILL. THAT WILL COMPLETELY
DESTROY THE AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY. IT WILL DESTROY SO
MANY DIFFERENT THINGS THOSE FOR
THE WAY OF LIVING AND YOU WANT
TO SAY IT'S GONNA HELP THE
ENVIRONMENT YOU'RE GOING TO
HARM THE ENVIRONMENT IN MY AREA
I CAN GET INTO THE ENVIRONMENT
I CAN TALK ABOUT HOW IRRIGATED
LANDS. REDUCE GLOBAL WARMING.
WE CAN HAVE THAT ARGUMENT I
HOPE WE HAVE A NEXT YEAR WE
TALK ABOUT HOW AG LANDS
SEQUESTER CARBON. BUT YOU DON'T
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THAT YOU
JUST WANNA TALK ABOUT YOU DON'T
LIKE PRESIDENT TRUMP. I DON'T
CARE IF YOU LIKE OR NOT. IT'S
NOT ABOUT THAT IT'S ABOUT THE
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WHOSE LIVES
DEPEND ON AGRICULTURE. WE'RE
GONNA HAVE THEIR LIVES RUINED.
EVERY SINGLE DAY WE TALK ABOUT
THIS I'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
WATER HERE IN CALIFORNIA SINCE
BEFORE EVEN GOT ELECTED. WE'RE
GOING TO DO THIS. THE SCIENCE
ISN'T EVEN A REAL HERE. YOU
DON'T HAVE A CAN SINCE IS A
MONTHS THE OTHER PARTY. IT THIS
IS. ONLY ONE OF THE WORST BILLS
I'VE EVER SEEN AND QUITE
FRANKLY WE'VE ALL BEEN AFRAID.
TO ACTUALLY SPEAK OUR MINDS OF
IT BECAUSE WHO THE AUTHOR IS.
WELL MEMBERS I'M ASKING YOU
TONIGHT. FRIDAY THE THIRTEENTH
OUR FINAL SESSION HAVE THE GUTS
TO STAND UP. THE PARTY
LEADERSHIP AND SEE YOU KNOW
WHAT YOU DON'T ALWAYS GET IT
RIGHT. WE HAVE FAMILIES THAT
ARE AT STAKE. LIVELIHOODS THAT
ARE AT STAKE. IN THIS IS JUST
GOING TO DECIMATE US. AND EVERY
YEAR WE TALK ABOUT HOW HOW MUCH
WE WANT TO HELP THESE PEOPLE
OUT. HOW BAD THEIR WALLET OR
QUALITY ALREADY IS. I KNOW YOU
WANT TO CUT IT OFF AND MAKE IT
WORSE. MEMBERS PLEASE. OPEN
YOUR HEARTS OPEN YOUR MINDS
REALIZE THIS IS NOT THE WAY TO
GO. WE CAN DO BETTER THAN THIS.
THE NEGOTIATIONS ON THIS DONE
IT IN THE DARK OF NIGHT GETTING
WORKED OVER ON THE FINAL OUR.
IT IS BREAKS MY HEART TO SEE
THIS. TO SEE THESE THINGS
HAPPEN HERE IN OUR BODY.
BECAUSE WE'RE BETTER THAN THAT.
THE MEMBERS I HOPE YOU CAN
FOLLOW YOUR HEARTS AND YOUR
CONSCIENCES IN FOLLOW EVERYTIME
YOU STAND UP INSECURE ABOUT THE
PEOPLE OF THIS STATE. DAMMIT DO
IT. HAVE THE GUTS TO VOTE THE
RIGHT WAY TONIGHT. AS FOR NO
VOTE. MR FONG YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. I THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS OF I RISE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
BECAUSE THIS WILL DO REAL HARM
TO THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NOT ONLY TO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY BUT SAID
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND TO
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. THIS IS
NOT THE TIME AT THIS HOUR TO BE
PASSING LEGISLATION TO MAKE
HERE POLITICAL STATEMENTS WATER
IS CRITICAL TO THE ECONOMIC
HEALTH OF OUR ENTIRE STATE.
THIS LEGISLATION THREATENS THE
WATER RELIABILITY OF OUR ENTIRE
STATE THIS BILL SPLIT WOULD
COST THE STATE WATER PROJECT
AND WATER USERS IN EXCESS OF
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND ACRE FEET OF WATER.
THAT IS TWO HUNDRED FORTY FOUR
BILLION GALLONS THAT COULD BE
GOING TO SUPPORT OUR ECONOMY TO
SUPPORT AGRICULTURE INDUSTRY
INTO SUPPORT EVERY DAY
CALIFORNIANS THAT IS ENOUGH
WATER. TO SUPPORT SEVEN POINT
FIVE MILLION CALIFORNIANS. THIS
BILL THREATENS ALL THAT. THIS
BILL WOULD SET OUR STATE BACK
WATER WISE TENNEY BACK TEN
YEARS. THERE IS BIPARTISAN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. NOT
ONLY FROM REPUBLICANS BUT FROM
DEMOCRATS THAT REPRESENT FROM
DIANNE FEINSTEIN. ALL THE WAY
DOWN TO THE CONGRESS MEMBERS IN
THE CENTER VALLEY. WE SHOULD
TAKE THE TIME TO MAKE SURE IT
THIS POLICY IS DONE RIGHT IF
YOU THIS BILL NEED TO MOVE
FORWARD THERE AMENDMENTS WE'VE
DRAFTED. THAT WOULD BE A WHAT
WOULD TAKE CARE OF THE CONCERNS
OF US IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND
IT WOULD FIX THIS PROBLEM. THAT
WOULD PRESERVE THE WATER
RELIABILITY OF THE ENTIRE STATE
BUT RIGHT NOW WE DON'T HAVE THE
TIME BECAUSE THIS BILL IS BEING
JAMMED UPON US. FOR SOME
POLITICAL STATEMENT. THIS IS A
NOT RESPONSIBLE THIS IS NOT THE
WAY WATER POLICY SHOULD BE MADE
IN OUR STATE WE SHOULD BRING
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS TOGETHER
AND FIND SOME FORM OF COMMON
SENSE BUT IF THIS BILL
CONTINUES YOU'RE JEOPARDIZING
THE WATER STABILITY OF THE
ENTIRE STATE AND THE ECONOMIC
HEALTH AND WELL BEING. OF ALL
OF US I URGE NO VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS FARMERS FLOOR YOUR
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I'M A KEEP
MY REMARKS VERY VERY SHORT BUT-
THIS BILL ACTUALLY BREAKS MY
HEART. THIS BILL IS A BILL
THERE'S A PARTICULAR SECTION IS
BILL TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN THAT
HAS BEEN. A HUGE BATTLE WITHIN
OUR AREA. FOR LAST FOUR YEARS
WE'VE BEEN HOLDING MEETINGS
WITH OUR CONSTITUENTS WORKING
WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY. TO TRY TO COME UP
WITH AN AGREEMENT. THIS BILL
TAKES IT ALL AWAY. COLLEAGUES I
JUST IMPLORE YOU. TO TAKE A
MOMENT. WITH RESPECT OF THE
AUTHOR BUT TAKE A MOMENT TO
PAUSE AND UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH. THIS IS OUR
LIVELIHOODS. THIS IS OUR WATER
WE CAN GET THIS RIGHT. WE JUST
NEED A LITTLE BIT MORE TIME I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN OVER.
AMOS PHARMACY PATTERSON YOUR
RECOGNIZE. MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS. TO DIRECTLY QUOTE THE
VOICES OF THE OPPOSITION. QUOTE
SB ONE GENERATE THAT WILL WILL
GENERATE YEARS OF LITIGATION.
QUOTE IN THE MIDST OF SUCH
FUNDAMENTAL UNCERTAINTY WILL BE
IMPOSSIBLE TO THE UP TO DEVELOP
ANY VOLUNTARY SETTLEMENT OF
SACRAMENTO AND SAN JOAQUIN
RIVER OUTFLOW STANDARDS. SB ONE
QUOTE WOULD PREVENT AND FREEZE
IN PLACE STATE AND FEDERAL
BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS DEVELOPED
OVER TEN YEARS REGARDLESS. OF
WHETHER THERE IS MORE SCIENCE
END OF QUOTE. SB ONE QUOTE
COULD UNDERMINE THE PROGRESS
BEING MADE ON VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS. WHAT THIS BILL
HURTS THE INCENTIVE TO CONTINUE
VOLUNTARY SETTLEMENT
NEGOTIATIONS AND WILL END UP
COSTING OUR COMMUNITIES IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY DEARLY. SB ONE
WOULD CODIFY IN STATE LAW THE
OUT DATED TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
AND TWO THOUSAND NINE
BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS WHICH
SHOULD BE REPLACED WITH A NEW
BIOLOGICAL OPINION THAT
UTILIZES. THE LATEST DATA
METHODS AND QUOTE. FURTHERMORE
BLOWING UP THIS PROCESS BY.
ENACTING THE ENDANGERED SPECIES
ACT PROVISION OF SENATE BILL
ONE WOULD RESULT IN THE MAJOR
PARTIES WALKING AWAY FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S COLLABORATIVE
PROCESS. INSTEAD OF WORKING
TOGETHER AND QUOTE. QUOTE THIS
COULD RESULT IN LITIGATION THAT
EXTENDS BEYOND THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION REGARDLESS OF
THE OUTCOME OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY ELECTION LITIGATION IN
THE WATER WORLD DOES NOT
RESOLVE CALIFORNIA'S LONG TERM
WATER PROBLEMS END OF QUOTE. SB
ONE QUOTE IN ITS PRESENT FORM
IS A STEP BACKWARDS QUOTE IT IS
JUST NOT PROPER AND GOOD. FOR
ANYBODY TO LOCK IN OUTDATED
SCIENTIFIC MODELS END QUOTE.
QUOTE SP ONE IS FLAWED AS THE
BILL REJECTS NEW SCIENCE THAT
WOULD CHANGE HOW WATER SUPPLIES
FROM THE CENTRAL VALLEY OR
MANAGED. VOTE I WANT TO ROLL
BACK THE SCIENCE TO RELY ON ONE
OUTDATED VERSION THE CALLS FOR
GREATLY INCREASED SERVICE WATER
BEING DIVERTED FROM THE DELTA
AND QUOTE. QUOTE I WILL
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE THE GOVERNOR
TO VETO. MEMBERS THESE ARE NOT
TO THE TALKING POINTS OF THE
REPUBLICANS. THESE ARE THE VOTE
THE VOICES OF THOSE FEDERAL
LEGISLATORS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO HAVE BEEN
ELECTED. BY THE VOTERS
INCLUDING SENATOR DIANNE
FEINSTEIN. OTHER KEY
CONGRESSIONAL DEMOCRATS LIKE
JOHN GARAMENDI JIM COSTA TJ
**** MEMBERS PLEASE. PLEASE DO
NOT ALLOW. YOUR HATRED FOR THIS
PRESIDENT. MOVE YOU TOWARD A
DECISION. THAT YOUR OWN
DEMOCRAT FEDERAL LEGISLATORS
OPPOSE. YOU ARE TAKING AN ANTI
TRUMP STEP WAY TOO FAR. AND
THESE WERE THE. QUOTED
SENTIMENTS OF YOUR DEMOCRATIC.
ELECTED. MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE
AND U. S. SENATE. LISTEN TO
THEIR VOICE PLEASE IF YOU WILL
NOT LISTEN TO MINE THANK YOU.
MR RIGHT YOUR RECKLESS. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I
RISE IN OPPOSITION. HOPEFULLY
TO. SHOW TO SELL ME ON THIS FOR
THAT THIS ISN'T A PARTISAN
ISSUE. IT CERTAINLY IS A BILL
THAT HAS A PARTISAN EDGE TO IT.
AND FRANKLY THOSE ELEMENTS OF
THIS BILL THAT I SUPPORT. BUT
SOME OF MY REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES FROM THE VALLEY OF
STOOD UP IN OPPOSITION TO THIS.
AS IT RELATES TO WATER. AND
THERE'S NOTHING MORE IMPORTANT
TO COMMUNITIES THE LARGELY.
EMPLOYED BY AGRICULTURAL
INTERESTS. SMALL FARMERS BIG
FARMERS GROWING COMMUNITIES
LIKE MY HOME TOWN MERCED NOT
HOME OF UC MERCED THAT DEPENDS
ON WATER IS THE VERY LIFEBLOOD
OF OUR ECONOMY. AND WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO TODAY IN THIS BILL
BECAUSE WERE LIVING IN A TIME
OF HARDEN PARTISANSHIP WHERE
SIDES ARE TOO FAR APART IS WAS
GOING TO DESTROY. THE PROGRESS
THAT I'VE WORKED FOR SEVEN
YEARS IN THIS OFFICE. THROUGH
TWO ADMINISTRATIONS TO ACHIEVE.
WHILE WE HAVE THOSE ON THE LEFT.
TO TAKE EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO
CRITICIZE THE CURRENT PRESIDENT.
AND THE POLITICS MAY BE GOOD
FOR THEM. WEEK WE HAVE THOSE ON
THE RIGHT. FOR MANY YEARS WERE
TOO STUBBORN TO COME TOTHE
TABLE. ON AGREEMENTS TO WORK
TOGETHER WITH PEOPLE ON THE
LEFT THAT THEY DIDN'T SEE THE
WORLD'S AND THEY COULDN'T SEE
IT THROUGH THEIR LIVES. THEY
SAW SOMEONE TRYING TO TAKE
THEIR LIVELIHOOD. FOLKS ON THE
OTHER SIDE LOOKING TO PROTECT
OUR ENVIRONMENT PROTECT OUR
NATURAL HABITAT THE- BEAUTIFUL
RIVERS THAT RUN THROUGH MY
DISTRICT. THROUGH BY CALLING
FOR REFERENCE DISTRICT AND THE
REST OF THE DELEGATION SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY. BUT WHAT I CAN
TELL YOU IS THROUGH TWO
ADMINISTRATIONS AND THROUGH
SEVEN YEARS OF DISCUSSION WE'VE
ACTUALLY. GOTTEN PEOPLE WHO SEE
THE WORLD VERY DIFFERENTLY TO
SIT DOWN AT THE TABLE WITH THE
JOB. AND WE'VE MADE GREAT
PROGRESS IN THIS NEW GOVERNOR
HAS REITERATED A COMMITMENT TO
THAT PROGRESS. AND
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT WE HAVE IN
PART OF THIS BILL TODAY. WILL
DESTROY THAT WILL SHOW BAD
FAITH WILL CAUSE PEOPLE TO WALK
AWAY FROM THE TABLE AND- THINGS
WILL GO ON. WATER. IN SOME
CASES WILL CONTINUE TO FALL IN
SOME CASES WON'T. WE ALL TO NO
END OF LITIGATION WITH OUR
WATER DISTRICTS AND SOME OF OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS AND
STAKEHOLDERS. IT'LL GO ON
DECADES AND DURING THOSE
DECADES. NOTHING CHANGES NO
IMPROVEMENT TO THE ENVIRONMENT
NO MORE SECURITY FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES. AND THAT IS
UNFORTUNATE. WHERE THE FIRST
YEAR OF A TWO YEAR SESSION
MEMBERS. THERE'S TIME. THERE'S
NO NEED THERE'S NO URGENCY
THERE'S NO DEADLINE THIS
EVENING THE REQUIRES US TO MOVE
THIS BILL TO THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK. AND FRANKLY IF WE'RE.
GOING TO MOVE THIS BILL THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK I HOPE THE
GOVERNOR'S THAT BACKSTOP THAT
WE NEED I HOPE THAT HE CAN
STAND UP AND SAY YOU KNOW WHAT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE PARKS
WE'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO EMBRACE
COMPROMISE AND CONSENSUS BAD
WORDS IN TWENTY NINETEEN
POLITICS MAYBE BAD WORDS IN
SOME OF YOUR- DISTRICTS. BUT
THEY'RE NOT BAD WORDS WHEN IT
COMES TO POLICY MAKING. SO
PLEASE CONSIDER BEFORE YOU TAKE
THIS IMPORTANT VOTE IT'S NOT A
PARTISAN ISSUE BIPARTISAN ISSUE
FOR THOSE OF US. IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES THEIR CULTURAL
COMMUNITIES. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE. HERE
TONIGHT. THING WAS GRAY MISTER
STONE. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
THIS IS TRULY A CALIFORNIA
ISSUE. AND FOR SOMEONE WHO HAS
LONG BEEN A FEDERALIST IT IS
ASTONISHING TO ME. THIS IS A
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TAKING DOWN
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS PROTECTIONS
CIVIL RIGHTS TIME AND TIME AND
TIME AGAIN. I HEAR THE RHETORIC
HERE I HEAR THE FEAR. BUT THIS
IS BEEN BLOWN UP TO BE MORE
THAN IT REALLY IS THIS IS
CALIFORNIA WHO HAS RELIED ON
FEDERAL POLICY FOR MANY YEARS
GOOD FEDERAL ENVIRONMENTAL
POLICY FOR MANY YEARS. AND WE
HAVE BUILT OUR OWN
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY. WITH GAPS
IN IT BECAUSE OF WHAT THE FEDS
IT DONE NOW THE FEDS ARE TAKING
AWAY SIGNIFICANT PIECES OF
WATER PROTECTION LAW OF AIR
PROTECTION LAW AND CALIFORNIA
HAS TO STEP INTO THE VOID. THIS
IS FILLING THAT VOID THERE IS
NO OTHER TIME TO BE DOING IT
RATHER THAN NOW BECAUSE THE
ADMINISTRATION IS FINDING ITS-
VOICE AND FINDING ITS- WAY OF
STARTING TO MAKE PROGRESS IN
TEARING DOWN WHAT WE HAVE LONG
VALUE. SO IF WE'RE NOT WILLING
TO SAY THIS IS ABOUT CALIFORNIA
LAW. AND ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S
STANDARDS IN SPITE OF WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. THEN THEN
DON'T KNOW WHAT CALIFORNIA IS
REALLY ABOUT OTHER STATES ARE
LOOKING TO US TO SET A
FRAMEWORK. TO SHOW HOW TO PUSH
BACK AND HOW TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HOLD ON TO WHAT IS
ABSOLUTELY VALUABLE. NOW THIS
BILL. PUTS IN PLACE CALIFORNIA
RULES WHERE THERE HAD BEEN
FEDERAL RULES THAT'S REALLY ALL
IT DOES. THERE ARE DISPUTE
RESOLUTION PROCESS IS THERE ARE
WAYS TO MAKE SURE THAT ANY OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT YOU'RE
AFRAID OF. CAN BE DEALT WITH
UNDER THIS AND IT RELIES ON THE
ADMINISTRATION TAKING STEP. BY
STEP BY STEP TO IDENTIFY. WHERE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
WALKING BACKWARDS IN WHERE
AREAS WE DON'T WANT THEM TO AND
CALIFORNIA BEING ABLE TO STEP
INTO. THAT VOID. THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT. IT IS TIME
WE STAND UP FOR OURSELVES IT IS
TIME WE MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
NOT SO DEPENDENT ON THE
VAGARIES OF FEDERAL POLICY THAT
UP TILL NOW HAD BEEN STALWART.
AND NEVER AN OUR ROADING FASTER
AND FASTER AND FASTER. THIS IS
A GOOD BILL MEMBERS AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST EITHER.
DOCTOR QUIRK. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU CHAIR ARM
I'D LIKE TO READ FROM THE
SALMON FISHER SAID ABOUT
OBJECTION INDUSTRY. UP THEIR
COMMENTS ARE GIVING IS CLEAR
THAT THE TWO THOUSAND NINE
PROTECTIONS BEEN AN ADEQUATE TO
STOP THE DECLINE LISTED BAY
DELTA SALMON RUNS. YET IN THE
PAST FEW MONTHS IT HAS BECOME
CLEAR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAS ABANDONED SCIENCE IN THIS
DEVELOPING NEW DRAMATICALLY
WEAKER BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS FOR
LISTED BAY DELTA SALMON SPECIES
SECRETARY OF THE INTERIOR DEVON
BERNHARDT FORMER LOBBYIST FOR
THE WEST PLAINS WATER DISTRICT.
HAS ENGINEERED THE REASSIGNMENT
OF TWENTY TO THIRTY FEDERAL
AGENCY STAFF WHO ARE EXPERTS ON
SALMON IN THE BAY DELTA IN
THEIR PLACE HE HAS APPOINTED
THE BUREAU OF RECLAMATION TO
THE TEAM RESPONSIBLE FOR
DETERMINING THE CONDITION
VERREAUX'S PERMIT. THIS
CONFLICT OF INTEREST WILL LEAD
TO A DRAMATICALLY FLAWED FINAL
FEDERAL BIOLOGICAL OPINION IN
FACT THAT NEW BIOLOGICAL
OPINION COULD PROVE TO BE
WEAKER THAN THE SCIENTIFICALLY
AND LEGALLY FLAWED RULES LED TO
THE SHUTDOWN EVERY INDUSTRY IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT NINE. SB ONE
IS A CENTRAL TO HELP THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA RESPOND IN A
TIMELY AND EFFECTIVE MANNER TO
THIS AND EVERY OTHER. FEDERAL
ROLL BACKS I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
MISTER KALRA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SP
ONE AND- THE REALITY IS. THAT
THIS IS NOT AND I AGREE EVEN
WITH THOSE BEGIN OPPOSITION
THAT THIS IS NOT AND SHOULD NOT
BE. AN ISSUE OF PARTISANSHIP
BUT IT IS AN ISSUE BASED ON
FACT. BECAUSE WE MUST REMEMBER
THAT EVEN. FOR DECADES WE THINK
ABOUT PRESIDENT NIXON THE BY
NOW PROTECTION PROTECTION
AGENCY WE THINK ABOUT LONG
STANDING LAWS INCLUDING A BILL
I HAD A THE MIGRATORY BIRD
TREATY ACT FOR A HUNDRED YEARS.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
SUPPORTED UNDER BOTH REPUBLICAN
AND DEMOCRATIC ADMINISTRATIONS
IT WAS THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
WITHIN A YEAR THE PULLED US OUT
OF THAT TREATY. SO IT'S NOT
ABOUT REPUBLICAN A DEMOCRAT IT
IS ABOUT AND MINISTRATION RIGHT
NOW. THAT IS DISMANTLING ONE BY
ONE DAY BY DAY. BUT NOT JUST
CALIFORNIA HAS BILL WHAT THIS
NATION HAS DONE TO SHOW THAT IT
HAS A COMMITMENT TO OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION THE
URGENCY. IS NOT IN MY CONCERN
THAT THE GOVERNOR OR THAT THIS
BODY OR THAT THE SENATE. ISN'T
WILLING TO WORK AND TO CONTINUE
TO WORK. WITH CONSTITUENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. WITH THE
SCIENCE WITH ENSURING THAT WE
CAN PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT AND
ENSURE THAT INDUSTRY CAN
CONTINUE TO THRIVE I'M NOT
CONCERNED WITH WHETHER. WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE WILLING
TO DO THAT THE URGENCY IS THE
FACT THAT EVERY DAY WE WAIT AS
WE SEE. COMING NOT JUST WITH
ADMINISTRATION A CABINET
MEMBERS THAT REPRESENT
INDUSTRIES THAT HAVE RAVAGED
OUR ENVIRONMENT FOR DECADES.
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO DISMANTLE WHAT CALIFORNIA
HAS FOUGHT FOR SO LONG WE CAN'T
CONTROL WHAT WASHINGTON DC IS
DOING A WHAT THE LEADERSHIP OR
LACK THERE OF IN THE WHITE
HOUSE IS DOING WE CAN CONTINUE
TO BE A LEADER IN OUR SO. IN
AND WHAT WE DO HERE ON THIS FOR
WHAT WE DO FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS
AND NOT JUST OTHER STATES OTHER
NATIONS ARE LOOKING AT US AND
WORKING WITH US. IN TERMS OF
FIGHTING GLOBAL CLIMATE CHANGE
IN TERMS OF AIR QUALITY IN
TERMS OF OUR ENVIRONMENT AND
WILDLIFE. NOW THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S NOT ONLY
DISMANTLING ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONS THEY'RE ALSO
DISMANTLING LONG STANDING
WORKER PROTECTIONS. INCLUDES
PROPOSING TO WEAKEN LIMITS ON
WORKPLACE EXPORT EXPOSURE TO
BRILLIANT. IT INCLUDES. IT
INCLUDES UP ROLLING BACK
WORKPLACE REPORTING. AND
INJURIES AT THE WORKPLACE SO
THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT ROLLING
BACK ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS
IT'S ROLLING BACK PROTECTIONS
FOR THOSE THAT WORK. TO MAKE
SURE THAT NOT ONLY OUR
ENVIRONMENT IS PROTECTED BUT
DOES NOT WORK IN INDUSTRIES
THAT ARE TRYING THEIR BEST TO
MITIGATE THEIR DAMAGE THAT THE
WORKERS ARE PROTECTED AND SO I
IMPLORE YOU TO SUPPORT SB ONE
WE'RE NOT GONNA STOP WORKING TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR GOVERNMENT
ARE LEGISLATION MATCHES THE
SCIENCE AND THERE ARE SIGNS OF
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO PROTECT
OUR ENVIRONMENT AND WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL
INDUSTRIES TO ENSURE WE MAKE
THAT HAPPEN. BUT TO SAY THAT WE
CAN TRUST THIS FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION TO HAVE OUR BACK
IS A JOKE. AS I EMPLOYEE TO
SUPPORT SB ONE. MS BARRICADE
HEN CORRECTNESS. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY AS
A MOTHER. THREE KIDS THAT ARE
GOING TO INHERIT THIS WORLD.
AND WHAT DO THEY DESERVE. THEY
DESERVE CLEAN AIR TO BREATHE
AND CLEAN WATER TO DRINK THEY
DESERVE A ONE WORLD AS LEAST AS
CLEAN AS THE ONE WE INHERITED.
USED TO ONE FOR THEM TO DO
THEIR TO GET A WORLD BETTER
THAN THE ONE WE INHERITED BUT
I'VE GIVEN UP ON THAT ALL
EXCEPT AT LEAST AS GOOD AS THE
ONE WE INHERITED. AND RIGHT NOW
THIS ISN'T A PARTISAN ISSUE I
WANT TO REMIND THIS BODY THAT
THE EPA WAS STARTED UNDER
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT. ACTING
THE ENTIRE MENTION VIETNAM
PARTISAN IN A BIPARTISAN ISSUE.
BECAUSE WE ALL HAVE TO DRINK
THIS WATER IN PRE THIS AIR. AND
SO I IMPLORE EACH AND EVERYONE
OF YOU TO TAKE THE PARTISANSHIP
OUT OF THIS AND TO REMEMBER.
WHAT IT IS WE ARE DOING HERE
TODAY AND THAT IS PROTECTING
THE WORLD THAT MY CHILDREN AND
YOUR CHILDREN YOUR
GRANDCHILDREN. ARE GOING TO
INHERIT. AND EVERY DAY THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION ROLLS BACK
THESE REGULATIONS. THE HARDER
IT GAPS TO PROTECT THAT
ENVIRONMENTS. AND I SAT IN
COMMITTEE AND I HEARD THIS AND
I HEARD THE OPPOSITION. AND I
SUPPORTED IT BECAUSE. WHEN WE
HEAR JUST THE WEEK ACTUALLY
THAT WE HEARD THIS ANY STM WAS
THE WEEK THAT THEY ROLL BACKS
MINDY INJURED SPECIES
REGULATIONS. AND AS I HEARD IT
ON MY DRIVE UP HERE I THOUGHT
GOD I WISH SB ONE WE'RE LAW
RIGHT NOW. BECAUSE I WOULDN'T
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THIS. BUT
IT WASN'T. BUT I HOPE IT WILL
BE. BECAUSE AT THE VERY LEAST.
WE SHOULD BE KEEPING OUR
REGULATIONS THAT ARE
PROTECTIONS OF THE ENVIRONMENT
AS GOOD AS THEY WERE. WHEN THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND FOR THE
GOVERNMENT AND THAT'S ALL THIS
BILL IS ASKING. AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS SAYING NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. MS FRIEDMAN YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AND I
APPRECIATE THE ROBUST DEBATE
IT'S APPROPRIATE THAT WE HAVE
THAT AND LEGISLATION THAT IS
SWEEPING AND IMPORTANT SUCH AS
THIS ONE. AND I WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED. FIRST OF ALL I WANTED
TO TALK ABOUT WHAT THE BILL
DOES TOO AND WHAT IT DOESN'T DO.
THE BILL DOES NOT. UNDERMINE
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS. IN TERMS
OF WATER. ISSUES THOSE
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS ARE NOT
REGULATIONS THERE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS THAT ARE AGREED TO
BY VARIOUS PARTIES AND
THEREFORE NOT AFFECTED BY THIS
BILL. AND IN FACT THOSE
AGREEMENTS ARE NOT EVEN IN
PLACE YET AS THEY ARE STILL
BEING NEGOTIATED. I REMEMBER.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT REGULATIONS
THAT EXIST TODAY. NOT REGULAR
NOT AGREEMENTS THAT ARE GOING
TO BE ENTERED INTO OVER A
PERIOD OF TIME. THIS BILL WILL
NOT TURN AREAS OF THE STATE
INTO A DUST BOWL. IF THEY'RE
NOT A DUST BOWL TODAY NOTHING
SHOULD CHANGE IN TERMS OF THE
WAY THAT THEIR WATER IS
DELIVERED IN THE WILL AND THEIR
WATER RIGHTS ARE ENACTED. THIS
BILL DOES NOT FREE SCIENCE. IN
FACT. WITH THE IN RESPONSE TO
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT WERE
RAISED BY SENATOR FEINSTEIN AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS THE VERY
IMPORTANT SECTION THAT DEALS
WITH WATER REGULATIONS WAS
CHANGE FROM SHOWER TO MAY TO
GIVE US THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THE FLEXIBILITY TO DECIDE WHICH
OF THOSE REGULATIONS AND WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO IMPOSE
RATHER THAN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TAKING THAT
RESPONSIBILITY AND THAT RIGHT.
AWAY FROM US. THE BILL DOES NOT
WAS NOT SPRUNG ON THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE LAST MINUTE
OR NEGOTIATE INNER DARKNESS IN
FACT THIS BILL WAS INTRODUCED
EARLY IN THE SESSION WAS
DEBATED MULTIPLE TIMES IN
COMMITTEE. THERE WERE HOURS AND
HOURS OF MEETINGS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ACROSS THE STATE
THAT RESULTED IN MANY
AMENDMENTS BEING TAKEN THE
ROUTE THE PAST YEAR AND I THINK
MANY OF YOU KNOW THAT BECAUSE
THIS BILL HAS BEEN DISCUSSED IN
THIS BODY SINCE IT WAS FIRST
INTRODUCED. GOING BACK INTO
LAST YEAR. WHAT THE BILL DOES
DO IS GIVE US TOOLS TO MAINTAIN
WHAT WE HAVE NOW. NOW. ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WAS BROUGHT UP
OVER AND OVER AGAIN WAS THAT
THIS IS A POLITICAL GESTURE
THIS IS HYPERBOLE THIS IS A
STATEMENT. THIS IS NOT A
STATEMENT. WHAT THIS IS A LACKS
JUST DITCH EFFORT FOR
CALIFORNIA TO PROTECT. WHAT WE
HAVE HAD IN PLACE IN IN SOME
REGARDS TAKEN FOR GRANTED FOR
DECADES. ACTIONS THAT WERE
NEGOTIATED FOR YEARS ON A
BIPARTISAN BASIS ON THE FLOOR
OF THIS CHAMBER IN THE FLOORS
OF WASHINGTON DC. BEEN
RESPECTED BY ADMINISTRATIONS
DEMOCRATIC AND REPUBLICAN GOING
BACK TO THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES
AND BEFORE WE WERE SO
COMFORTABLE AND SO SURE THAT
THOSE LONG STANDING REGULATIONS
I'M PROTECTIONS WOULD REMAIN.
THAT WE NEVER TOOK JURISDICTION
OF THEM INTO OUR OWN HANDS. AND
NOW IN A IN A PERIOD OF JUST A
COUPLE SHORT YEARS WE'VE SEEN
THOSE DECADES OF WORK ONE AFTER
THE OTHER BEING TAKEN AWAY AND
TOPPLE DOWN WITHOUT US HAVING
THE CAPACITY TO COME IN EVERY
SINGLE DAY. AND RESPOND THROUGH
LEGISLATION. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CAN TAKE AWAY
THROUGH EXECUTIVE ACTION OR
OTHER ACTIONS. IN A WEEK A LAW
THAT WILL TAKE US A YEAR TO PUT
BACK INTO PLACE AND WE ARE LEFT
MEANWHILE DEFENSELESS FOR OUR
WATER AND FOR OUR AIR AND FOR
OUR WORKERS LET'S JUST QUICKLY
JUST GO THROUGH A FEW OF THOSE
HAD BEEN IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS TO REMIND EVERYONE WHAT'S
REALLY AT STAKE THE CLEAN WATER
ACT TRUMP HAS PUT IT. OUT THERE
THAT THAT ENFORCING THE CLEAN
WATER ACT IS ONE OF THE EPA'S
MOST INTRUSIVE RULES AND SINGLE
THAT IS TRANSITION TEAMS
WEBSITE FOR POSSIBLE
ELIMINATION THE SAFE DRINKING
WATER ACT SOMETHING THAT
EVERYONE OF US. HAS TO CARE A
LOT ABOUT BECAUSE WE TALKED
ABOUT WATER QUALITY IN THIS
BODY AND HOW IMPORTANT IS THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO
RE EXAMINE THE SCIENCE BEHIND
THE STANDARDS WE HAVE FOR LEAD
CHROMIUM SIX ARCHERY ARSENIC
AND NITRATES IN DRINKING WATER
BECAUSE THEY DON'T THINK THAT
THE SCIENCES ESTABLISHED THAT
WE SHOULD KEEP THOSE
CONTAMINANTS OUT OF OUR WATER.
THE ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT THE
ANIMALS THAT I KNOW MY CHILD
CARE IS ABOUT PROBABLY YOURS OR
BECAUSE HUMPBACK WHALES
SOUTHERN SEA OTTERS SEA TURTLES
AND THE ICONIC RED LOG FROG
TRIGGERED A SECOND LISTEN THAT
HE WANTS TO WEAKEN OR REPEAL.
ALL TOGETHER THE ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT. TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANTS SAME THING THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SAYING THAT
THEY DON'T WANT TO ENFORCE THEM
FALL PROTECTION OSHA. SO CODE
IN SO ELATION PENALTIES FOR
WORKER SAFETY VIOLATION ALL ON
THE CHOPPING BLOCK FROM THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND IF WE DON'T
ACT WE ARE DEFENCELESS. MEMBERS
I URGE AN AYE VOTE ON SB ONE
THANK YOU. THE CORPORAL ALL
MEMBERS OF. BIZARRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO VOTE
.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF
AN ICE FORTY THREE KNOWS TWENTY
ONE THAT MEASURE PASS
. MEMBERS
THE HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE
HIGHER READ WILL BE MEETING IN
THE RULES COMMITTEE ROOM RIGHT
NOW. HIGHER RATE COMMITTEE IN
THE RULES COMMITTEE ROW
. MISTER
COLLEY MISTER COLLEY PLEASE
APPROACH THE ROSTRUM. NO HE'S
NOT A HIGHER AT
. MEMBERS
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT TWO I RE REFER IN THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO COMMITTEE AB
FORTY EIGHT O'DONNELL TO HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND AB ONE
SEVENTY GONZALEZ TO LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT. MISTER CALDERON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND JOINT WILL
SEE SITUATED FALL NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE HERE AB
FORTY EIGHT. O'DONNELL UPON
CALL CHAIR. WHICH IS NOT A JACK
XIN THE REQUEST IS GRANTED.
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SPEND JOINT WILL SIX TO A- THE
FALL NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO
ALLOW THE LABOR IN PLYMOUTH
COMMITTED HERE AB ONE SEVENTY
GONZALEZ UPON CULTURE. AGAIN
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE REQUEST
IS GRANTED
. COLLEAGUES THE
LABOR COMMITTEE WILL MEET
IMMEDIATELY IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE ROOM. ALL MEMBERS
11-3 PLEASE PROCEED TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE ROOM FOR
HEARING
. NOW BE TO TAKE UP AB
ONE SEVENTY O'DONNELL
. MEMBERS
NATURAL RESOURCES IS MEDIAN
RULES COMMITTEE ROOM RIGHT NOW
ALL MEMBERS PLEASE PROCEED TO
THE RULES COMMITTEE ROOM FOR
NATURAL RESOURCES
. MEMBERS WE
MAY ENTERTAIN THOUGH CHANGES AS
NEEDED
. MS BURKE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. IN THE CHANGE AB
FIVE THIRTY NINE I A TO NOT
VOTING. THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURKE ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
THIRTY NINE I TO NOT VOTING
. MR
BLOOM ARE YOU TAKING REQUESTS
.
MEMBERS PLEASE COME TO THE
FLOOR WE HAVE A PROCEDURAL VOTE
IN FRONT OF US
. MEMBERS PLEASE
AVOID THE FLOOR WE HAVE
PROCEDURAL VOTE PENDING
.
MEMBERS THE RULES COMMITTEE.
WE'LL BE MEETING IMMEDIATELY IN
THE RULES COMMITTEE ROOM THE
RULES COMMITTEE WILL BE MEETING
IMMEDIATELY AND THE RULES
COMMITTEE ROOM. MEMBERS WHO ARE
NOT ON THE RULES COMMITTEE.
THESE COME TO THE FLOOR AS SOON
AS PRACTICABLE
. THE RULES
COMMITTEE IS MEETING IN THE
RULES ROOM. RIGHT
. MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER THERE IS A
RULES COMMITTEE RESOLUTION AT
THE DESK TO SUSPEND THE JOINT
RULES TO ALLOW US TO PASS BILLS
AFTER MIDNIGHT I ASKED THAT WE
GO TO THAT RESOLUTION NOW.
MEMBERS DUE TO THE ACTIONS OF
PROTESTERS EARLIER TODAY WHICH
HAVE DELAYED LEGISLATIVE
PROCEEDINGS. WE WILL NEED TO
EXTEND OUR PROCEEDINGS BEYOND
MIDNIGHT MEMBERS THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE SUSPEND THE
RULES. IT IS NOT AVAILABLE AND
REQUIRES A ROLL CALL AT FIFTY
FOUR MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
READ. RESOLVED THAT JOINT WILL
SIXTY ONE A FIFTEEN BE
SUSPENDED TO PERMIT BILL TO BE
TAKEN UP AFTER MIDNIGHT ON
FRIDAY SEPTEMBER THIRTEENTH
TWENTY NINETEEN FOR FURTHER
ACTION. THE CLERK WILL OVER THE
ROLE ON THE RESOLUTION. MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FO AN AYE
VOTE. ON THE RESOLUTION THIS
TAKES FIFTY FOUR
. THIS TAKES
FIFTY FOUR. THANK YOU MEMBERS
THE CLERK WELL. CLOSE TO ROLAND
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY KNOWS
EIGHTEEN. THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED AND THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED
. MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA
LET ME
. SENATE THIRD READING
FILE. THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY
SEVEN. SENATE BILL FIFTY EIGHT.
COVERAGE SENATE BILL FIFTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR WIENER AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES MR SANTIAGO
I THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
RISE A PRESENT SB FIFTY EIGHT A
FIVE YEAR PILOT PROGRAM TO
EXTEND CLOSING HOURS IF THE
CITY APPLIES TO PARTICIPATE AS
A PILOT PROGRAM THE TASK FORCE
WOULD BE COMPLIES OF LOCAL C.
H. P. A MUST CREATE A PUT THAT
MUST CREATED A PUBLIC SAFETY
PLAN. EVEN WHEN THAT HAPPENS
THE APPLICATION MUST BE
SUBMITTED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
ALCOHOL BEVERAGE CONTROL AND IT
CAN BE APPROVED OR DENIED.
THANK YOU FOR A THINK FOR
LAUNDRY PERCENT EXPECT LASSEN
AYE VOTE. MR LACKEY OR
RECOGNIZE. OKAY I KNOW IT'S
ALMOST MIDNIGHT. HI THIS IS
REALLY. THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL FOLKS. AND IT'S
MY TURN TO SPEAK MAN. LET ME
JUST SAY THE MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE. UNIQUELY QUALIFIES
ME TO SPEAK TO THIS ISSUE.
BECAUSE NOT ONLY HAVE I DEALT
WITH. I THINK SAFETY. I WORK
THESE HOURS IN QUESTION FOR
OVER TWO DECADES. LET ME JUST
TELL YOU A REALLY QUICK STORY
AND I'LL TRY TO MAKE IT QUICK.
WHEN I WAS NINETEEN YEARS OLD.
I WOKE UP. IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
DESERT. WITH A BROKEN PELVIS.
AND A TRUCK DRIVER HOLDING MY
HAND I COULDN'T SEE BECAUSE
BLOOD HAD CAKED. ACROSS MY
FACE. MAKE A LONG STORY SHORT I
HAD LEARNED HOW TO WALK AGAIN.
BECAUSE THE DRIVER FELL ASLEEP.
DURING THESE HOURS FATIGUE IS
IMMENSE AND IT GETS.
EXPONENTIALLY WORSE AS THE TIME
TICKS AWAY. NOW WE ARE ALSO
WHAT WE THIS BILL CONSIDERS.
EXTENDING THE TIME THAT WE'RE
NOT ONLY GOING TO BE DEALING
WITH FATIGUE BUT ALCOHOL
IMPAIRMENT. ANOTHER ISSUE THAT
UP I NEED TO I FEEL RESPONSIBLE
TO SHARE WITH YOU. REALITY ALL
THE POLITICS OUT. BECAUSE THIS
IS NOT A RIGHT LEFT ISSUE THIS
IS A RIGHT OR WRONG ISSUE. LET
ME JUST TELL YOU. DEATH WILL
COME BECAUSE OF THIS POLICY
ADDITIONAL DEATH. THAT'S WRONG
I DON'T TALK ABOUT LOCAL
CONTROL I DON'T CARE WHO'S IN
CHARGE A POLICY THAT IS GOING
TO FACILITATE NEEDLESS DEATH.
BOOKS I'VE SAT IN THE IN THE
HOMES OF PEOPLE TO SHARE THE
ABSOLUTE WORST NEWS. HAVE LOST
LOVED ONES BECAUSE PEOPLE WERE
PAIRED. ALCOHOLISM PERRY
SUBSTANCE AND PEOPLE WILL
CHOOSE TO DRIVE IMPAIRED. AND
WHEN WE EXTEND THAT. JUST SOLD
THERE'S SOME KIND OF I DON'T
KNOW WHAT KIND OF GAME YOU
TRADE FOR LIFE. I REALLY DON'T
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY. THIS
IS A. LET'S SEE THAT IS SO
ALARMING TO ME THAT. IT'S COME
THIS FAR. I MEAN I REALLY DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE JUSTIFICATION
HERE BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT LOSS OF LIFE AND IT'S AN
ARGUABLE THAT THIS POLICY WILL
RESULT. THE POLICY WILL. IS
GOING TO ADD TO DEATH. TRAGIC
DEATH UNNECESSARY DEATH. I JUST
AS YOU PUSH THE GREEN BUTTON
BECAUSE I KNOW TOO MANY OF YOU
WILL. I JUST WANT TO STAND AS A
WITNESS TO YOU. THAT IT'S GOING
TO SEND SOME PEOPLE TO THEIR
GRAVE. HOW YOU RECONCILE THAT
I'LL NEVER KNOW. BUT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME BECAUSE I'M DONE
BEFORE MIDNIGHT. THANK YOU
MISTER LACKEY MISTER FRAZIER.
YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR SO LADIES AND GENTLEMAN.
YOU'VE SEEN US TRY TO GET AT
ADD ADDITIONAL CHP OFFICERS IN
THE LAST SESSION. YOU ALL
UNANIMOUSLY VOTED FOR ADDING
FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY OFFICERS
OVER FOUR YEARS WHICH WAS
VETOED LAST YEAR BY THE
GOVERNOR WE ARE DOWN ONE
THOUSAND CHP OFFICERS. IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. MOST OF
OUR CITIES ARE CONSTRAINED FOR
POLICE ENFORCEMENT. THEY'RE
GOING OUT TRYING TO DO SALES
TAX MEASURES AND ALL KINDS OF
THINGS TO BE ABLE TO CREATE
MORE OFFICERS. TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC SAFETY. WHY ARE WE GOING
TO PUT MORE LAWS ON THE BOOKS
TO ALLOW. A LARGER BURDEN ON
PUBLIC SAFETY. UNTIL WE FIX THE
MATTER OF THE PROBLEM FIRST. I
LOST A DAUGHTER IN A CAR
ACCIDENT. AND THANKS TO. THE
FIRST RESPONDERS THE HIGHWAY
PATROL MY LITTLE GIRL LIFT.
WE'RE UNDERSTAFFED UNDER MANNED.
AND WE CAN NOT CONTINUE TO ADD
A BURDEN TO PUBLIC SAFETY I ASK
YOUR NOVA. MISTER COOPER I'LL
BE QUICK IF YOU THINK ABOUT AND
HEARING THIS BILL EVERY HEARING
CHP NEVER OPPOSED IT. WHAT IT
SEES PETER TESTIFIED TO HEARING.
WHO SEES P. WORK FOR THAT'S A
BIG QUESTION IN THEIR TESTIFIED
THE SOCIALIZATION NEVER OPPOSE
THE BILL. AND FINALLY THEY BOTH
OPPOSE THE BILL THE FIFTY
MINISTRATION AND THE RECORD
FILED ASSOCIATION. BUT THERE'S
A REASON FOR THAT THAT'S WITH
THE BIGGEST THING IS A BIG
ISSUE PEOPLE DO DRIVE DRUG THEY
DO SILLY THINGS RIGHT NOW NOT
HAS NOT GONE DOWN. THE TALK
ABOUT THE MONEY AS FAR AS
FUNDING AND LOCALS GET TOGETHER
AND DO THAT BUT THE PAY FOR CH
PEACEFUL SACRAMENTO FIFTH
LARGEST COUNTY IN CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW GRAVEYARD. THERE ARE
TWO TWO MILLION UNITS SOUTH OF
THE RIVER AND ONE SERGEANT. TO
TOO MANY VETS NORTH THE RIVER
ONE SERGEANT YOU CAN ASK THAT
YOU COME TO JEOLLABUK SOMEONE.
YOU'RE OFF THE STRETS. THAT'S
WHAT IT IS A GREAT ROCK IS
GRAVEYARD MOST FOLKS ARE
ASLEEP. EXCEPT PEOPLE GOING OUT
AND YOU KNOW DOING SILLY THING
SO. YOUR STAFFING IS LOW. EVEN
FOR THE POLICE DEPARTMENT
DOWNTOWN IS LOW STAFFING
BECAUSE- GRAVEYARD YOUR SLOW
SHIFT. SO IT'S VERY EASY GET
TIED UP ON A CRASH. ON A
RESTRICTED VIEW FOR TWO HOURS.
AND LATER ON THE MORNING'S
GUESS LATER. ALSO TRYING TO
FINISH THE REPORTS. BEFORE THE
GOING TO WATCH BECAUSE I'M GRAY
YOU'RE GETTING OFFICE SIX OR
SEVEN. THEY'VE GOT TO FINISH
THE REPORTS. SO THEY'RE NOT OUT
THEIR HUNT FOR DRUNK DRIVERS AT
SOME POINT BECAUSE- THEY DON'T
WANT THEM HAVING OVER TIME IN
MY COLLEAGUES LOCALLY. HAS
TRIED TO GET SEIZE POSITIONAL
FUNDING. FOR MANY MANY YEARS
AND YOU SURE THEY'RE TURNED
DOWN. SO SEIZE PEOPLE TOOLS ARE
FREE BUT FOR SACRAMENTO ON THE
FREEWAYS. IN NIGHT. TIME YOU
HAVE A TOLD THINK ABOUT THAT.
TOLL OF TEN OFFICERS. IT'S NOT
VERY MANY OFFICERS AND IN THE
BAY AREA THE SAME THING LA
COUNTY THE SAME THING FOR
DRIVING ON FREEWAYS SO JUST
SOMETHING THINK ABOUT IT SOUNDS
GOOD BUT IT WHAT COST TO THINK
ABOUT IT YOU GO OVER THE JAIL
RIGHT NOW. EVEN A FRIDAY NIGHT
LOCALS AGAIN LOOK FOR DRUNK
DRIVING THAT'S A LABRYS PROCESS
TO GO DOWN THERE THE TODDLER'S
GONNA BLOW ON IT FILL OUT
PAPERWORK TAKE THE PROPERTY
HAVE THE NURSE EXAMINE THEM SO.
IT'S A VERY LENGTHY PROCESS IS
SOMETHING THINK ABOUT SO
JOURNAL VOTE. MISTER MESS YOUR
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU SPEAK YOUR
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL BUT NOT BECAUSE I
DON'T AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUES
WHO SPOKE IN OPPOSITION. ADD TO
THIS BILL BECAUSE I THINK THAT
THEY ARE A RIGHT. BUT
CALIFORNIA'S IN THE INCREDIBLY
DIVERSE STATE. THERE ARE OVER
WITH OUR FOUR HUNDRED AND MORE
THAN FOUR HUNDRED CITIES THERE
ARE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES AND
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES IS DIFFERENT I'LL
TELL YA I DON'T THINK THREE
O'CLOCK IS THE RIGHT NUMBER I
DON'T THINK TWO O'CLOCK IS THE
RIGHT NUMBER. IT STARTED OFF AT
FOUR O'CLOCK I THINK THAT OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES ARE THE ONES
THAT SHOULD BE ABLE TO DECIDE
WHAT THAT WHAT WHAT THAT OUR IS
AND IF YOU BELIEVE THAT
GOVERNMENT IS BEST THAT WHICH
GOVERNS CLOSEST TO THE PEOPLE
THEN WHY NOT GIVE OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THE ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE. THIS DECISION FOR
THAT REASON I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THIS MEASURE. THIS EVENING AND
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT AS WELL.
MISS KOREA YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIFTY EIGHT LATE NIGHT CLOSING
TIMES HAVE BEEN EXAMINED IN ALL
FIFTY STATES AND HAVE BEEN
COMPARED TO THE DO YOU AYE
STATISTICS PROVIDED FROM THE
NATIONAL HIGHWAY TRAFFIC SAFETY
ADMINISTRATION AND THERE IS
ABSOLUTELY NO CORRELATION
BETWEEN STATES WOULD LATER
CLOSING TIMES AND HIGHER RATES
OF DRUNK DRIVING IN FACT ONE
STUDY DONE BY THE AMERICAN
JOURNAL OF PREVENTIVE MEDICINE
ECHOED THIS FINDING EVIDENCE
THAT SHOWS EXTENDING DRINKING
HOURS. BY UP TO TWO HOURS DOES
NOT AFFECT EXCESSIVE ALCOHOL
CONSUMPTION OR INCREASED
ALCOHOL RELATED HARMS IT IS
ALSO IMPORTANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THIS BILL STRICT LOCAL CONTROL
AS NO CITY WILL BE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT THIS EXTENDING
CLOSING OUR WITHOUT THE CITY
COUNCIL FIRST VOTING TO APPROVE
THE ORDINANCE AND DEVELOPING AN
APPROVING A LOCAL PLAN SHOWING
THAT PUBLIC NECESSITY AND
CONVENIENCE WILL BE SERVED NEXT
THE CITY MUST CONVENE A PUBLIC
SAFETY TASK FORCE COMPROMISED
OF LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND C.
H. P. OFFICIALS TO DEVELOP. A
PUBLIC SAFETY PLAN OF ACTION TO
KEEP THEIR COMMUNITIES SAFE
THIS IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO
MY COMMUNITY OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES THIS PLAN MUST ALSO
EXHIBIT RESIDENTS AND BUSINESS
SUPPORT AND SHOW THAT
TRANSPORTATION SERVICES ARE
READILY ACCESSIBLE BEFORE IT IS
EVEN SUBMITTED TO THE STATE FOR
APPROVAL ESSENTIALLY SB FIFTY
EIGHT REQUIRES LOCALITIES TO GO
THROUGH NUMEROUS PROTECTION
MEASURES TO ENSURE THE ENTIRE
CITY IS AS PREPARED AS POSSIBLE
FOR THIS CHANGE IT IS TIME THAT
WE RE EXAMINE OUR STATE WHY
CLOSING HOURS. AND GIVE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THE FLEXIBILITY TO
DETERMINE WHAT IS BEST. FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THE
MYSTERY OF MS MELENDEZ. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
YOU KNOW I THINK THIS IS
SPEAKERS BEFORE ME WHO ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS MADE SOME VERY
GOOD POINTS I THINK THERE ARE A
FEW THAT WE WANT TO ADD TO THIS
NUMBER ONE GOVERNOR BROWN DID
VETO THIS BILL ARE READY AND
FOR VERY GOOD REASON I WOULD
URGE YOU TO GO BACK AND LOOK AT
HIS VETO MESSAGE NUMBER TWO THE
LA CITY COUNCIL. IS AGAINST
THIS MEASURE. UNANIMOUSLY I
BELIEVE. THE THIRD POINT THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE TO YOU IS. I
WANT TO APPEAL TO THE PARENTS
IN THIS ROOM. AND THIS IS A
YOUNGER LEGISLATURE NOW WE HAVE
A LOT MORE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
YOUNG CHILDREN AT HOME. SO IT'S
POSSIBLE THAT YOUR YOUNG
CHILDREN ARE GOING TO PLAY
SPORTS LIKE MINE DO. AND MY
CHILDREN WHEN THEY'RE SPORTS
LEAGUES STARTS DEREK PRACTICE
IF FIVE IN THE MORNING WHICH
MEANS THEY'RE ON THE ROAD A
FOUR THIRTY IN THE MORNING TO
GET A PRACTICE. TO SUGGEST THAT
THIS IS A LOCALIZED ISSUE
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
STAYING OUT LATER AND DRINKING
WILL ONLY STAY IN THAT LOCAL
AREA TO DRIVE HOME. IS A FALSE
ASSUMPTION THEY'RE GOING TO GO
INTO OTHER COMMUNITIES. IN DO
YOU WANT TO PUT YOUR CHILDREN
IN EVERYONE ELSE'S CHILDREN AT
RISK. BY HAVING MORE PEOPLE WHO
RIDE TOO MUCH TO DRINK ON THE
ROAD HE COULD POSSIBLY TAKE THE
LIVES. OF YOUR BABIES YOUR
CHILDREN YOU THINK VERY
CAREFULLY ABOUT IS IT WORTH IT.
TO ALLOW A FEW MORE HOURS OF
DRINKING ISN'T WORTH IT. TO PUT
CHILDREN AT RISK. I ORIGINAL
VOTE. MEASURE OF ARNOLDI THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM NOT A
PARTICULAR FAN OF BARS AND
THOSE OF YOU WHO KNOW ME KNOW
I'M PROBABLY AMONGST THE LEAST
LIKELY TO BE FOUND AT A BAR AT
THREE O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING.
HOWEVER I AM A FAN ALSO OF
LOCAL CONTROL LIKE MOST OF YOU.
I SERVED IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT I
WAS THE MAYOR OF A CITY AND I
REMEMBER VIVIDLY. HOW
FRUSTRATING IT WAS TO BE TOLD
BY PEOPLE IN SACRAMENTO WHAT
WAS RIGHT AND WHAT WAS WRONG
FOR MY COMMUNITY. AND THAT'S
WHY I'LL BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL TODAY AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE. THAT THIS IS
NOT A STATE WIDE LAW THIS IS A
NARROWLY TARGETED PILOT PROGRAM.
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE. THE CRUCIBLE OF
EXPERIMENTATION AND GOVERNMENT
AND THIS IS A WAY OF FINDING
OUT WHETHER OR NOT. SOME OF THE
OBJECTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED HERE TONIGHT ARE TRUE.
THESE COMMUNITIES HAVE ALREADY
EXPRESSED A WILLINGNESS TO BE
PART OF THE PILOT PROGRAM. THEY
HAVE ALREADY ARE DECIDED AT THE
CITY COUNCIL LEVEL THAT THIS IS
GOOD FOR THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
THEY WILL HAVE TO COMPLY WITH A
PAGES LONG LIST. OF PUBLIC
SAFETY REQUIREMENTS PUBLIC
HEARINGS I ENGAGEMENT WITH
THEIR COMMUNITIES BEFORE THEY
ARE ALLOWED TO JOIN. SO I THINK
THAT WE ARE TAKING A BALANCED
APPROACH HERE. I THINK THAT WE
SHOULD LET OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS DO WHAT'S BEST FOR
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND THEN.
WHEN THIS PILOT PROGRAM IS RUN
ITS COURSE. SEVERAL YEARS FROM
NOW WE CAN LOOK AT THE
STATISTICS AND FIND OUT WHETHER
OR NOT. THIS WAS A REASONABLE
POWER TO GIVE THEM. AND I
SUSPECT THE ANSWER WILL BE YES
BUT IF THE ANSWER IS NO. THEN
WE SHOULD TERMINATE THE PILOT
PROGRAM. BUT BECAUSE I'M A
BELIEVER IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT I
ORIGINAL VOTE. THIS MURATSUCHI.
I JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE.
THE IRONY THAT. WE HAVE. SO
MANY PEOPLE FROM BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE TALKING ABOUT LOCAL
CONTROL WHEN WE VOTED ON SO
MANY BILLS TODAY TO TAKE AWAY
LOCAL CONTROL YOU KNOW TO BUILD
MORE HOUSING AND YET HERE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT LOCAL CONTROL SO
THAT WE CAN SELL GIVE OUR
PURCHASE ALCOHOL BETWEEN THE
HOURS OF TO A AND A FOUR AM. I
BELIEVE. THREE AM. TO AIMED AT
THREE AM I STAND CORRECTED. I.
I HAVEN'T SEEN THE STATISTICS
THAT THERE ARE OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM YOU STILL A CITED BUT I
HAVE A HARD TIME BELIEVING
THOSE STATISTICS TO ME. IT
JUST. MAKES COMMON SENSE THAT
OFFERING SELLING ALCOHOL A
LATER HOUR WE'RE GONNA HAVE
MORE D. WISE WE'RE GONNA HAVE
MORE DEATHS I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANKS THANK YOU FOR
THE DEBATE MEMBERS SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM MISTER SANTIAGO YOU MAY
CLOSE. YEAH THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND I WANT TO THANK THE
ENTIRE BODY FOR PUTTING A
ROBUST ARGUMENT BEFORE US BUT
LET'S BE VERY CLEAR THIS IS A
MODEST BILL. COMPARED TO WHAT
THE LEGISLATURE'S PASSED BEFORE
ON THIS ISSUE. LET ME CORRECT
THE FAX IT'S THREE AM IT'S NO
LONGER FOUR AM. IT'S TEN CITIES
AND IT'S A PILOT PROGRAM. L.
LET'S ALSO BE CLEAR BECAUSE IT
WAS MENTIONED THAT LA PAST
RESOLUTE LUCIEN AGAINST IT. LA
ASKED TO BE IN IT OR IT WOULD
NOT BE IN IT. THE TEN CITIES
WERE IT IT REEKS WERE REQUESTED
TO BE IN ITS. YES OTHER THINGS
THAT HAPPENED BUT WE DO HAVE
THE LETTER THE REQUESTED TO BE
IN IT. LET'S ALSO BE CLEAR IT
WAS BROUGHT UP CONVERSATIONS OF
BEING BROUGHT UP ABOUT LAW
ENFORCEMENT. THE C. H. P.'S
NEUTRAL. LET'S BE VERY CLEAR
ABOUT THAT. NO THEY HAD A
CHOICE THEY CAN SUBMIT A
SUPPORT LETTER BECAUSE THE
MINUTE OPPOSITION LETTER AND
THEY CAN MAKE ARGUMENTS LIKE
ANYBODY ELSE BUT THEY'RE
NEUTRAL. BUT WE CAN ARGUE ABOUT
THAT AND WE CAN TABLE THAT FOR
SECOND. LET'S ALSO TALK ABOUT
THE WAY THE ECONOMY IS CHANGED.
PEOPLE HAVE CHANGED. IF YOU GO
DOWN AS SOME OF THESE
NEIGHBORHOODS. PEOPLE GET OFF
OF WORK AT TEN PEOPLE GET OFF
AT ELEVEN. WE'RE NOT EVERYBODY
GETS UP AT SIX IN THE MORNING
AND I BABIES TUCKED IN BED AT
NINE AT NIGHT. LET'S BE VERY
CLEAR. AND SOME OF THE
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT WE
REPRESENTS. IF YOU TALK ABOUT
LOS ANGELES YOU TALK ABOUT SAN
FRANCISCO SACRAMENTO OR SOME OF
THESE OTHER AREAS. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE POTENTIAL FOR
CONVENTION CENTERS. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE GETTING
OUT AT TEN ELEVEN O'CLOCK. WE
ARE NOTTALKING ABOUT FOLKS
RUNNING AMOK LET'S BE VERY
CLEAR. AND IT'S AND IT WAS SAID
BEFORE BUT I'LL RESTATE ITS
ABOUT PURE LOCAL CONTROL. NO
ONE IS GOING TO FORCE IMAGES A
PAL DID YOU DO ANYTHING. EVEN
THOUGH IT'S BEEN DISCUSSED
ALREADY THAT THERE IS A VERY
ROBUST. PROCESS TO BE ABLE TO
GET INTO THE IN INTO THIS PILOT
PROGRAM. LAW ENFORCEMENT WILL
BE INVOLVED. ABC WILL BE
INVOLVED AND THE LOCAL COUNCIL
WILL BE INVOLVED SO IT'S NOT
LIKE YOU PASS IS BUILT INTO
MORROW MORNING EVERYBODY'S
GONNA BE DRINK UNTIL THREE
O'CLOCK AT MORNING THAT'S NOT
WHAT THIS BILL DOES WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS A SAYS THE LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES WILL HAVE THE
ABILITY WHERE THEY DEEM
RESPONSIBLE. THROUGH A RIGOROUS
PROCESS THAT INVOLVES LAW
ENFORCEMENT THREE A RIGOROUS
PROCESS THAT INVOLVES ABC TO
DECIDE FOR THEMSELVES THEY
COULD DECIDE THAT IT'S
POTENTIALLY AT VENUES WORK
WHERE YOU HAVE A HOTEL ROOM
THEY COULD DECIDE THAT IT'S
ONLY ONE DAY A YEAR THEY COULD
DECIDE THAT THEY DON'T DO IT AT
ALL BUT THEY'VE REQUESTED. THE
ABILITY TO MAKE THAT DECISION
FOR THEMSELVES. SO TO BE VERY
CLEAR ABOUT WHAT THIS BILL
DOES. IT GIVES YOUR LOCAL
CONTROL. WITH A STRONG
FRAMEWORK IN A IN A VIGOROUS
PROCESS TO BE ABLE TO GET INTO
THIS THAT'S ALL IT DOES. THANK
YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I
BUILT. WITH THAT CLICK LIBERAL.
THE SENATE VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE
. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE ABOUT
. MR SANTIAGO.
MOVES A CALL
. MEMBERS WE ARE ON
SENATOR READING. FILE ITEM
THIRTY TWO. SB. THREE TWENTY
EIGHT. CARBURETOR SENATE BILL
THREE TWENTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE ATTENDANCE.
MR GLORIA YOU MAY OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. MEMBERS
TEENAGERS IN THIS COUNTRY ARE
SLEEP DEPRIVED IT IS A PUBLIC
HEALTH EPIDEMIC. AND ACCORDING
TO CONCLUSIVE MEDICAL RESEARCH
THE PRIMARY CAUSE OF THIS
EPIDEMIC IS THE EARLY SCHOOL
START TIMES THEY'RE NOT ALIGNED
WITH BIOLOGICAL SLEEP NEEDS OF
ADOLESCENT CHILDREN. SB THREE
TWENTY EIGHT WE'LL UPDATE THE
EDUCATIONAL CODE WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH PARAMETERS FOR MIDDLE
AND HIGH SCHOOL START TIMES.
THE REGULAR SCHOOL DAY
BEGINNING AT EIGHT THIRTY AM OR
LATER FOR HIGH SCHOOLS IN EIGHT
AM OR LATER FOR MIDDLE SCHOOLS
AS RECOMMENDED BY THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS THE
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND
PREVENTION. AND MANY OTHER
MINUTE MEDICAL ORGANIZATIONS.
MEMBERS DESPITE DECADES OF
OVERWHELMING AND COMPELLING
EVIDENCE OF THE HARM TO
TEAMMATE TEENAGERS FROM EARLY
WAKE UP TIMES THE VAST MAJORITY
OF THIS STATE'S SECONDARY
SCHOOLS ROUGHLY ABOUT EIGHTY
PERCENT. STILL BEGAN BEFORE
EIGHT THIRTY AM SO EARLY THAT
THEY PREVENT MOST TEENS FROM
GETTING THE DOCTOR DOCTOR
RECOMMENDED NINE HOURS OF SLEEP
FOR THEIR GROWING BODIES AND
BRAIN NEEDS. GOING THE CDC THE
AVERAGE SECONDARY START TIMES
IN CALIFORNIA IS EIGHT OH SEVEN
A. M. AND MANY START WELL
BEFORE SEVEN THIRTY IN THE
MORNING. RELEASE SECOND
SECONDARY SCHOOL START TIMES
HARM CHILDREN'S HEALTH AND
SAFETY AND MANY WAYS.
INSUFFICIENT HEALTH AMONG
ADOLESCENTS BECAUSE HIGHER
RATES OF DEPRESSION ANXIETY
SUICIDAL THOUGHTS AND ACTIONS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. OBESITY
DIABETES DROWSY DRIVING WHILE
DRIVE CAR ACCIDENTS SUBSTANCE
ABUSE AND SPORTS INJURIES. THIS
IS AN EXPANSIVE EVIDENCE
SPANNING DECADES THAT WHEN
SCHOOL STARTS LATER TEENS GET
MORE SLEEP THEY'RE HEALTHIER
THEY'RE HAPPIER THEY ARE LESS
LIKELY TO COMP AND CONTEMPLATE
SUICIDE LESS LIKELY TO GET IN
CAR ACCIDENTS AND THEIR TENETS
GO UP THEIR GRADES GO UP IN
GRADUATION RATES GO UP. MEMBERS
I WILL NOT BELABOR THE POINT
BECAUSE THE HOURS LATE BUT I
NEED YOUR VOTE ON THIS
PARTICULAR ITEM TODAY AND
YESTERDAY WE START A LITTLE
LATER IN THE LEGISLATURE AND
ALL OF YOUR HAPPY ABOUT IT. SO
IF YOU LIKED IT. I THINK IT'S
PLENTY GOOD ENOUGH FOR OUR
CHILDREN TO START LATER AS WELL
SO I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON
THIS MEASURE MISTER SPEAKER
PLEASE VOTE YES ON ON SAYS
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY EIGHT.
I'M NOT SURE OF THE WORD LATER
IS A SELLING POINT RIGHT NOW
MISTER GLORIA. DOCTOR CHOI YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. SPEAKER ON THE
MEMBERS I RISE IN OPPOSITION OF
IS SO SB THREE. TWENTY EIGHT
THIS BILL WAS BROUGHT. IS TO A
PROHIBITS THE MIDDLE SCHOOLS
AND HIGH SCHOOLS OF FROM
OPENING BEFORE EIGHT O'CLOCK OR
EIGHT THIRTY. AM. COLLEAGUES SO
WE DEALT WITH THESE SAME BILL I
BELIEVE LAST YEAR. I UNDERSTAND
THE ALSO SO INTENTIONS OF
BEHIND THIS BILL. AND THE
FEELING SELF THE CONCERN OF THE
CHILDREN OF THE CALIFORNIA.
HOWEVER I FEEL LIKE GOD THIS
BILL IS THE WRONG APPROACH TO
THE ISSUE. AS SO SOME OF US ARE
COLLEAGUES ARE ARE TRAVELING
LONG DISTANCES TO BE UP HERE AT
THE CAPITOL. AND THEN ALSO I
HAD TO GET UP EARLY TOMORROW
MORNING TO GET SAKIC OF FLIGHT
TO HOME. WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
CALIFORNIA IS THE LARGEST STATE
AND AS SUCH THE SUNLIGHT. AND
THE LIFE ACROSS THIS STATE IS
THE DIFFERENT DEPENDING UPON
WHERE YOU LIVE. WHAT I MEAN
COLLEAGUES SO IS THAT ON A DAY
OUT WE HAD THE SUN RISES IN SAN
DIEGO AT THE SEVEN FORTY. THE
SAME SUN NOT WOULD BE RISING IN
SOME FRANCISCO. AT EIGHT TWENTY
AM AND THE CRESCENT CITY AT THE
EIGHT FORTY AM. IN ADDITION TO
THIS. THIS STUDY THAT THE
INSPIRED THE DESPAIR Là HAS
BEEN ANALYZE THAT AND THE NAME
THE INCONCLUSIVE. THE EVIDENCE
IS SOME MIXED. THERE IS A
FURTHER NEED FOR RESEARCH. GIVE
ME FOR WE CHANGE TIMES FOR
SCORES THE TIME THAT THE
PARENTS SO CALLED WORK DOES NOT
CHANGE. SO THEREFORE CHILDREN
WOULD BE IN SCHOOL LONGER. WITH
THE LAST TIME TO DO HOMEWORK
AND THE LAST US TO THE BALL
ORDER TO GET THE. THEY CAN NO
JUST A DAY OR LIFESTYLE KNOWING
THAT THAT THEY HAVE TO GET UP
EARLY MORNING THINKING WATER
BED DAHLE EARLY. IN THE EVENING.
IN MY SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THIS
CITY A CITY OF IRVINE. THEY YOU
STOP THOSE SOME SCORES ARE HIGH
SCHOOL THAT THE MY CHILDREN
ATTENDED THE SEVEN THIRTY. THE
STATE. FOR THIS REASON SIZE
STRONG YOU HEARD YOU AND NOBLE.
LET THE GOVERNOR. MS BURKHARDT
BATH YOUR RECOGNIZE YES MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AS YOU
ALL KNOW. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION AS YOU ALL KNOW MY
YOU MET MY SON MONTEREY IS
ELEVEN YEARS OLD HE STARTED
MIDDLE SCHOOL THIS YEAR IF WE
HAVE PUT HIM IN THE SCHOOL IS
MEANT TO GO TO HE WOULD HAVE
HAD TO CATCH THE BUS AT SIX
FORTY FIVE IN THE MORNING. YOU
TELL ME THAT'S OKAY WE HAVE
SCIENCE WE HAVE DATA WITH THE
POWER TO CHANGE THIS SO THE FOR
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF OUR
CHILDREN IN THE STATE SO I
APPEAL TO YOU AS A MOTHER
APPEAL TO YOU AS A PARENT.
PLEASE VOTE YES ON THIS BILL.
WE NEED TO BE DOING THE RIGHT
THING TONIGHT THANK YOU. MR
O'DONNELL. YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER LET'S
SEE WHO SUPPORTS LOCAL CONTROL
NOW. I OPPOSE SB THREE TWENTY
EIGHT. IT HAS MANY UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES LET ME LIST A FEW
OF THEM JUST A FEW OF THEM. SB
TWO SB THREE TWENTY EIGHT OF US
RATES A LOW OVER THE ROLE OF
LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS AND SETTING
THE BELL SCHEDULES. I DENTURES
MANY PARENTS WILL HAVE CHILD
CARE PROBLEMS IN THE EARLY
MORNING. AND SOCIETY TELLS US
THAT BURDEN WILL TYPICALLY FALL
ON WOMEN. SB THREE TWENTY EIGHT
WILL REQUIRE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO PURCHASE AND OPERATE MORE
SCHOOL BUSES THIS IS COSTLY. SB
THREE TWENTY OR REQUIRE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO FLIP THEIR
SCHEDULES SO MENTERI SCHOOL
STUDENTS GO EARLIER THAN THEY
PRESENTLY DO. SB THREE TWENTY
EIGHT HAMMER IS A SCHOOL
DISTRICT'S ABILITY TO USE BLOCK
SCHEDULING SPECIALLY THE HIGH
SCHOOL LEVEL NOT THAT MEANS
MORE ACADEMIC TIME. FOR
STUDENTS SB THREE TWENTY EIGHT
THREATEN C. T. E. AGRICULTURAL
PROGRAMS THAT START IN THE
EARLY MORNING HOURS. SB THREE
TWENTY EIGHT HAS TECHNICAL
FLAWS THAT MAY LEAD TO A LOSS
OF EIGHTY EIGHT THERE SOME
UNKNOWNS THERE. SB THREE TWENTY
EIGHT KILLS EARLY MORNING
SPORTS SPORTS PROGRAMS LIKE
SURFING AND MY OWN COMMUNITY.
WE WON'T HAVE SERVE TEAMS
ANYMORE MY CHILD'S ON A SURF
TEAM SO I KNOW ALL YOU LAND
DOGS DON'T UNDERSTAND ABOUT
THIS PEOPLE THAT LIVE NEAR THE
OCEAN HAVE SERVE TEAMS. IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT ARE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND TO OUR KIDS. SB
THREE TWENTY EIGHT PUT PUTS
RURAL STUDENTS IN DANGER. AS A
NOW MAY TRAVEL ON A BUS IN THE
DARKNESS OF THE NIGHT TO GET
HOME IN FACT AS I UNDERSTAND IT
SOME THESE SCHOOLS ONLY OPERATE
FOUR DAYS A WEEK SO THEIR DAY.
IS ACTUALLY LONGER SO YOU'LL BE
PUSHING THOSE BUSING HOURS INTO
THE INTO IT INTO THE HOURS WHEN
IT'S DARK. RECENT STUDIES SHOW.
THAT LATER START TIME SIMPLY
LEAD TO CHILDREN GOING TO BED
LATER. AND IF YOU HAVE A
TEENAGER YEAH NO THAT'S VERY
TRUE. SO LET'S. LET'S SUPPORT
LOCAL CONTROL. VOTE NO ON THIS
WE SHOULD NOT SET. THE BELL
SCHEDULE FROM SACRAMENTO.
SACRAMENTO DOES NOT KNOW BEST.
MR GLORIA. MR. FOR THE BILL
MISTER CALDERON IS NOT AS DESK.
THIS YOUR OBERNOLTE. MISTER%
SPEAKER I RISE AS SEEMS TO BE
MY HABIT THIS EVENING TO ARGUE
IN SUPPORT OF ANOTHER
DEMOCRATIC BILL. SO I HAVE JUST
FINISHED MY SIX YEAR AND FINAL
YEAR AS THE PARENT OF A HIGH
SCHOOLER. AND WHERE WE LIVE IN
BIG BEAR LAKE FIRST BELL FOR
THE HIGH SCHOOL FOR FIRST
PERIOD RINGS AT SIX FIFTY FIVE
AM. AND I CAN TELL YOU FROM SIX
YEARS OF PERSONAL EXPERIENCE.
THAT MANY TIMES MY SONS WERE
NOT CAPABLE OF DRIVING SAFELY.
THAT EARLY IN THE MORNING AND
JUST IN THE LAST YEAR I HAVE
DRIVEN MY SON TO SCHOOL RATHER
THAN HAVE HIM DRIVE BECAUSE I
DIDN'T WANT HIM DRIVING AT THAT
EARLY HOUR. AND THIS LAST YEAR
MY YOUNGEST SON HIS FIRST
PERIOD WAS AP CALCULUS. SO
THINK ABOUT THAT WERE SENDING A
TEENAGER. BUT I DON'T EVEN
TRUST TO DRIVE AT THAT HOUR IN
TO DO AP CALCULUS I DON'T THINK
THAT'S GOING TO HAVE A GOOD
RESULT. HI TESTIFIED. IN FOR
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IN THE
PAST AND I HAVE CITED THE
NUMEROUS STUDIES ACROSS THE
WORLD THAT HAVE VERIFIED AGAIN
AND AGAIN AND AGAIN AND AGAIN.
THAT LEADER HIGH SCHOOL START
TIMES RELIEVED TO DECREASE
ABSENTEEISM. DECREASED TARDY'S
INCREASED SLEEP INCREASED
GRADES INCREASE TEST SCORES AND
BETTER HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION
RATES THE DATA IS ABSOLUTELY
CRYSTAL CLEAR. BUT WE'VE
ACTUALLY HAD A VERY EXCITING
DEVELOPMENT JUST IN THE LAST
YEAR AND THAT'S THAT IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN. THE ENTIRE
CITY OF SEATTLE. VOTED TO MOVE
OF THEIR HIGH SCHOOL START
TIMES FORWARD. BY ABOUT FIFTY
MINUTES. AND BECAUSE THIS IS
ONE OF THE LARGEST SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN THE WORLD TO MAKE
THIS MOVE THERE WAS A TEAM OF
RESEARCHERS. THAT ELECTED TO GO
IN AND DO A VERY COMPREHENSIVE
STUDY AND THEY STARTED BEFORE
THE CHANGE WAS MADE AND THEY
WANTED DETAILED EMPIRICAL DATA
SO RATHER THAN JUST ASKING
PEOPLE THEIR OPINIONS THEY
ACTUALLY FITTED GROUPS OF
STUDENTS WITH SLEEP MONITORS.
AND A MONITOR TO BEFORE AND
AFTER THE LOOK TO TEST SCORES
BEFORE AND AFTER AND THAT DATA
WAS JUST PUBLISHED A COUPLE OF
MONTHS AGO. AND YOU KNOW WHAT
THEY FOUND CONTRARY TO WHAT HAS
BEEN STATED IN OPPOSITION HERE
ON THE FLOOR THEY FOUND THAT
STUDENTS DID NOT GO TO SLEEP
LATER IN FACT OF THAT FIFTEEN
MINUTES THEY MOVED THE START
TIME BACK. THE AVERAGE HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT GOT AN EXTRA
THIRTY FOUR MINUTES OF SLEEP.
THEY FOUND THAT THE AVERAGE ARE
GRADE FOR THOSE HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS INCREASED BY ALMOST 5%
TO PUT THAT IN CONTEXT THAT'S
ALMOST HALF THE AGREED THAT
THEY THEY INCREASED ON AVERAGE.
THEY HAD SUBSTANTIALLY LESS
TARDY'S SUBSTANTIALLY REDUCED
ABSENTEEISM. THOSE ARE POWERFUL
RESEARCH RESULTS. AND THEY'RE
VERY APPLICABLE TO WHAT WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT DOING TODAY NOW
I HAVE HEARD. THE ARGUMENTS
AGAINST THIS BELIEVE ME I'VE
HEARD IT BECAUSE I THINK I'VE
GOT SOME SCHOOL DISTRICT
SUPERINTENDENTS THAT ARE GONNA
BURN BE AN EFFIGY. IF THE
GOVERNOR SIGNS THIS BILL THIS
YEAR. AND SOME OF THEM HAVE
VERY FIRST OF ALL I'VE HEARD. A
PARENT CONVENIENCE. WELL TELL
YOUR FOR THIS. I'M NOT GOING TO
WORK AT SIXTY FIVE FIFTY FIVE
IN THE MORNING SO IT'S NOT
TERRIBLY CONVENIENT FOR MY
PARENTS. BUT IT DEPENDS ON HOW
FAR YOU'RE DRIVING I THINK
THAT'S KIND OF A WASH.
CERTAINLY SCHOOL BUS SCHEDULES
IS GOING TO BE A REAL PROBLEM.
CERTAINLY HIGH SCHOOL ATHLETICS
IS GOING TO BE WROTE REAL
PROBLEM BUT EVEN IF WE HAVE TO
BUY A BUNCH OF MORE BUSES AND
HIGHER SO MORE BUS DRIVERS.
EVEN IF WE HAVE TO PUT LIGHTS
ON A BUNCH OF ATHLETIC FIELDS.
THIS WILL BE THE SINGLE MOST
COST EFFECTIVE THING WE CAN DO.
TO IMPROVE HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION RATES IN CALIFORNIA.
I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER ONE OF THE MISTER
MARTUCCI. YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YOU KNOW I FEEL
REALLY CONFLICTED ABOUT THIS
BILL BECAUSE YOU KNOW
ESPECIALLY MY STAFF KNOWS THAT
I LIKE TO SLEEP IN AND I'M A
LATE OWL AND YOU KNOW I KNOW
THAT THERE WAS SO MUCH. MEDICAL
EVIDENCE THAT THAT THAT
SUPPORTS THIS BUT I WANT TO
CITE.A STUDY EIGHT EIGHT A
CAUGHT CONTRARY STUDY THAT WAS
PUT OUT BY SLEEP SCIENTISTS BY
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
DAVIS WHICH A LOT WAS SUBMITTED
AND CIRCULATED BY THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION THAT ALSO OPPOSES
THIS BUT THERE THERE LETTER
INDICATES THAT BASED ON A
COMBINED EIGHTY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE IN THE FIELD OF
SLEEP RESEARCH IN OVER TWO
DECADES OF STUDY OF ADOLESCENT
SLEEP. WE WRITE AND OPPOSITION
TO SB THREE TWENTY EIGHT. THEY
CONCLUDED THAT THERE IS
CURRENTLY AN SUFFICIENT
EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT A STATE
WIDE LIMIT OF EIGHT THIRTY AM
FOR MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL
START TIMES. ON TOP OF THAT YOU
KNOW I WANT TO EMPHASIZE WHAT
THE ART THE CHAIR OF THE IS
EDUCATION COMMITTEE INDICATED
THE COST TO OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CASE IN POINT OAKLAND
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IS IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. THAT
THAT'S BECAUSE IF WE ADOPT THIS
BILL. IT'S GOING TO IMPOSE THE
BEFORE SCHOOL ARE YOU A CHILD
CARE EXPENSES IS GOING TO
IMPOSE THE BUSING EXPENSES ON A
READY STRUGGLING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS LIKE OAKLAND UNIFIED
THERE ARE DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE THAT ARE READY
STRUGGLING AND THIS IS GOING TO
IMPOSE ADDITIONAL COSTS. YOU
KNOW SO AGAIN I KNOW THAT THERE
IS THE STRONG EVIDENCE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BUT- I THINK
THERE IS THERE IS EVIDENCE TO
THE CONTRARY ARE ALSO AND THAT.
PRECISELY BECAUSE THERE IS SO
MUCH CONFLICT IN THE EVIDENCE
AS WELL AS THE FISCAL IMPACT ON
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT WE SHOULD
LEAVE IT TO LOCAL CONTROL. SO I
I'M NOT GONNA BE OPPOSE IN THIS
BILL BUT YOU KNOW I CANNOT
SUPPORT THIS BILL. MR GABRIEL
YOUR RECKLESS. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I'LL BE
BRIEF I JUST WANTED TO ECHO
SOME OF THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM MY END TO NEED
US AND FROM BIG BEAR I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I
WILL TELL YOU WHEN I FIRST GOT
ELECTED LAST YEAR IN THIS BILL
CAME UP I WAS VERY MUCH TORN ON
THE MEASURE. AND I HAVE A LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICT IT'S VERY MUCH
OPPOSED TO IT AND I DIDN'T KNOW
MUCH ABOUT IT SO I REALLY SAT
DOWN AND DUG INTO THE SUPPORT
LETTERS IN THE OPPOSITION
LETTERS IN THE RESEARCH IN THE
EVIDENCE IN THE DATA. AND I
WILL TELL YOU THIS TREMENDOUSLY
COMPELLING THERE'S A
TREMENDOUSLY COMPELLING CASE
HERE TO CHANGE SCHOOL SCOTT
START TIME AND WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
TORRANCE THE OPPOSITION THIS
YEAR HAS COME UP WITH A LETTER
FROM ONE RESEARCHER OPPOSING
THIS BILL BUT THERE IS VIRTUAL
UNANIMITY IF YOU LOOK AT THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
IF YOU LOOK AT THE AMERICAN
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IF YOU LOOK
AT ALL OF THE SCIENCE IN THE
RESEARCH AND THE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE LOOKED INTO THIS. THEY
TELL US ONE VERY SIMPLE FACT
THAT MAKING THIS CHANGE WILL
SAVE LIVES IT WILL SAVE LIVES
IN AVOIDED SUICIDES IT WILL
SAVE LIVES IN AVOIDED CAR
CRASHES THIS IS IN A MEASURE
THAT WE CAN TAKE THAT WILL HELP
SAVE LIVES I KNOW THAT THERE
ARE LOTS OF REASONS NOT TO DO
THIS THE INCONVENIENCE FOR SOME
FOLKS THE FACT THAT THERE ARE A
LOT OF PEOPLE THAT MIGHT BE PUT
OUT. BUT DO MAKING THIS CHANGE
IS A REALLY POWERFUL WAY FOR US
TO SAVE LIVES AND I WOULD
COURAGE ALL OF YOU TO. VOTE I
ON THIS MEASURE. MR KILEY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
WOULD ANY BELL WE HAVE TO ASK
WHETHER IT'S THE RIGHT POLICY
AND WHETHER WERE THE RIGHT
INSTITUTION. TO BE MAKING THE
POLICY. ON THE FIRST QUESTION
AS OTHERS HAVE MENTIONED. THE
OVERWHELMING WEIGHT OF THE
EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT WHILE
SCHOOL START TIMES ARE NOT A
PANACEA FOR OUR PUBLIC
EDUCATION SYSTEM. THEY DO LEAD.
MORE THAN MARGINAL. THEN
THERE'S THE INSTITUTIONAL
QUESTION AND MY OWN PHILOSOPHY
IS THAT DECISION MAKING PUBLIC
POLICY SHOULD BE MADE AT THE
MOST LOCAL LEVEL PRACTICABLE
WHERE THE DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCES AND VALUES OF
COMMUNITIES CAN BE ACCOUNTED
FOR WE'RE DECISION MAKERS ARE
CLOSEST TO THE PEOPLE WHO WILL
BE IMPACTED WERE FLEXIBILITY
ALLOWS FOR INNOVATION AND FOR
IMPROVEMENT THROUGH TRIAL AND
ERROR AND WE SHOULD REFRAIN
FROM TAKING ACTION ON THE CROSS
JURISDICTIONAL OR STATE LEVEL
IN LAST THERE'S A COMPELLING.
BASIS FOR DOING SO THAT'S WHY I
DID NOT SUPPORT PRIOR VERSIONS
OF THIS BILL. BUT I REACHED A
DIFFERENT CONCLUSION WITH THE
BILL THAT'S BEFORE US TODAY.
FOR ONE THING THIS BILL IS HAS
BEEN AMENDED IN WAYS THAT ADDS
A GREATER LEVEL OF FLEXIBILITY
AND GET CLOSER TO STRIKING THE
RIGHT BALANCE AND THE AUTHOR IS
COMMITTED TO WORKING IN THE
YEARS BETWEEN PASSAGE AN
IMPLEMENTATION DEFINED TO IT
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
BALANCE. IS STRUCK IN THE RIGHT
WAY. BUT MORE THAN THAT THERE
HAS IN MY VIEW A MERGED A
COMPELLING BASIS FOR STATE
ACTION AND THAT IS THE
DIFFICULTY. THAT THE BARRIERS
THAT EXIST DID DISTRICTS THAT
ACTUALLY DO WANT TO CHANGE
THEIR START TIMES. BECAUSE WE
HAVE A STATE WITH A THOUSAND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHERE YOU CAN
HAVE DOZENS OF DISTRICTS WITHIN
A GIVEN REGION AND THEY ARE
GOVERNED INDEPENDENTLY BUT- THE
AFFAIRS OF THESE DISTRICTS ARE
INTERTWINED WITH THINGS LIKE
TRANSPORTATION. AND
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES AND
SO FORTH AND SO THERE IS IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT THEIR
SCHEDULES ARE GENERALLY ALIGNED
AND IF YOU HAVE A PARTICULAR
DISTRICT THAT WANTS TO CHANGE
IT START TIME THAT MY THROAT SO
I TO SYNC WITH SCHOOLS IN THE
SURROUNDING AREA. THE BECOMES
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO DO SO AND
I'VE HEARD FROM DISTRICTS THAT
FACE THIS VERY DONNA. SO THE
TENDENCY IS FOR THE TIMES IN A
GIVEN REGION TO BE COORDINATED
IN THE MOST NATURAL
COORDINATION POINT IS THE
STATUS QUO. SO I HAVE YOU THIS
BILL AS PROVIDING A NEW
COORDINATION POINT THAT IS
BASED UPON RESEARCH AND BASED
UPON SCIENCE AND I ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THERE WILL BE SOME
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE CAREFULLY
THOUGHT THROUGH THE ISSUE OF
START TIMES. THERE WILL HAVE TO
MAKE CHANGES AND THAT WEIGHS
HEAVILY ON MY OWN THINKING. BUT
AT THE SAME TIME THERE ARE
DISTRICTS THAT WILL BE
EMPOWERED TO MAKE THE SORT OF
CHANGES THEY WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
TO BETTER REFLECT THE
PREDICAMENT AND THE DESIRES AND
THE INTEREST OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES SO IN OTHER WORDS.
THE LOCAL CONTROL ARGUMENT CUTS
BOTH WAYS. AND AT THAT POINT I
THINK WE CAN DEFER TO THE
EVIDENCE THAT OVERWHELMINGLY
SHOWS. THAT THIS WILL BE IN THE
BEST INTERESTS OF CALIFORNIA'S
KIDS I ASKED FOR A VOTE. MISS
SMITH. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I RISE AS AN
IMMEDIATE FORMER SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER. AND SOMEONE WHO
REPRESENTS A DISTRICT WHERE NOT
A SINGLE ONE OF MY LOCAL
DISTRICT CAN FIND THEMSELVES IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. AND
IT'S NOT SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY
FAVOR LOCAL CONTROL BUT A LOT
OF IT HAS TO DO WITH THE
PRACTICABILITY OF SCHEDULING IN
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY AND
SCHEDULING. ON A SCHOOL SITE.
WE STILL ARE REMINDED THIS BODY
REMAINS ONE OF THE LOWEST
FUNDED STATES IN PER PUPIL
SPENDING ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
MEASURE WILL COST MONEY IT IS
QUITE SIMPLY IT WELL INTO OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM BIG BEAR WHOSE
SON WAS ABLE TO TAKE AN A. P.
COURSE VERY EARLY IN THE
MORNING. VERY OFTEN THAT'S
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS FACE A CHALLENGE OF
MATCHING THE NEEDS OF THEIR
STUDENT POPULATION WITH THE
FACILITIES AND THE
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME THEY HAVE
AVAILABLE. SO FOR MANY MANY
KIDS MY OWN INCLUDED THERE
OPPORTUNITY PART OF HER
DISSIPATE IN BOTH ADVANCED
PROGRAMMING AND IN SOME
CHILDREN'S CASES REMEDIATION
PROGRAMMING DEPENDED ON A
SCHEDULE THAT WAS FLEXIBLE
THROUGHOUT THE SCHOOL DAY. AND
YES THE EVIDENCE IS COMPELLING
AND I HAVE SHARED WITH THE
AUTHOR THAT I DO BELIEVE IT'S
COMPELLING I DON'T YET BELIEVE
IT IS COMPELLING ENOUGH FOR US
TO COMPLETELY OVERRIDE ALL OF
THE LOCAL PRACTICAL CONCERNS
ASSOCIATED AN AFFILIATED WITH
THIS BILL. BECAUSE AMONG MY
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO HAVE THESE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THEM ALSO IS
IMPLEMENTING STUDENT MENTAL
HEALTH AND WELLNESS PROGRAMMING
NEXT YEAR IN ORDER TO ALSO
ADDRESS THOSE VERY KEY AND
CRITICAL STUDENT NEEDS. I JUST
URGE THAT WE EXT EXERCISE
EXTREME CAUTION HERE AND TO
ALLOW OUR LOCAL DISTRICTS TO DO
WHAT'S BEST IN OUR COMMUNITY
INTO THE POINTS OF MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE RISEN AND
SUPPORT. YOUR LOCAL DISTRICT
MAY FIND ITSELF IN SUPPORT AND
FIND THAT THIS IS THE BEST WAY
FOR THEM TO GO AND WE SHOULD
SUPPORT AND ENCOURAGE THAT
ALONG WITH THE PARENT COMMUNITY
BEING INVOLVED IN THAT
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS BUT FOR US
TO MAKE A SWEEPING DECISION
LIKE THIS HERE IN SACRAMENTO
WHEN IT REALLY HAS. SOME VERY
DETAILED PRACTICAL IMPLICATIONS.
FOR OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT I DON'T
THINK IT'S THE RIGHT VOTE TO
TAKE. MISTER CALDERON. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISS MEGAN
MEMBERS I AM PROUD TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE I
REPRESENT. THE CITY OF LOVE
POINT THEY IT IS THE POOREST
COMMUNITY IN THE SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY AND ONE OF THE SCHOOLS
IN MY DISTRICT ACTUALLY MOVE
THEIR START TIME. AN HOUR LATER
THIS IS A SCHOOL WHERE THEY HAD
TRUANCY THAT WAS REALLY BAD
THEY HAVE POOR ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE AND THEY HAD A LOT
OF DISCIPLINARY ISSUES. BY
MOVING THAT START TIME AN HOUR
LATER TRUANCY CAN SIGNIFICANTLY
DECREASE DISCIPLINARY ACTION
SIGNIFICANTLY DECREASED AND
ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE
SIGNIFICANTLY. INCREASED I
SUPPORT DOES NOT JUST BECAUSE
OF THE DATA AND ALL OF THE
IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO FOR
KIDS. BUT I SUPPORT IT BECAUSE
I'VE SEEN IT IN ACTION AND KNOW
THAT IT ACTUALLY WORKS AND I
WILL SAY. THAT MY BIGGEST. PET
PEEVE OF DEALING WITH THIS
ISSUE HAS EVERY TIME THAT I'VE
BEEN APPROACHED BY THE
OPPOSITION TO TALK TO ABOUT
THIS ISSUE. IT'S ALWAYS ABOUT
HOW IT'S GOING TO IMPACT THE
ADULT'S LIFE. HOW IT'S GOING TO
IMPACT THE MEMBERS OF THE
SCHOOL BOARD WHO ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO RESCHEDULE BUS TIMES
RESCHEDULE SCHOOL START TIMES
AND- EVERYTHING ELSE THE
PARENTS. EVERYTHING ELSE THAT'S
GOING TO IMPACT THE LIVES OF
THE ADULTS. SO EASILY WE THEN
THROW ASIDE WHAT IS CLEARLY THE
RIGHT MOVE WHICH IS THIS IS THE
RIGHT THING FOR KIDS I THINK
THAT THAT IS INCORRECT I DON'T
THINK THAT THAT'S WHAT WE
SHOULD. DO IN TERMS OF POLICY
BECAUSE WE KNOW BECAUSE OF THE
EVIDENCE AND THAT ALL OF THE
STUDIES IN THE DATA POINT TO
THIS BEING THE RIGHT THING. I
DON'T THINK THAT WE SHOULD BE
MAKING THIS DECISION BASED ON
HOW THIS IS GOING TO IMPACT
ADULTS LIVES MY KID. CHARLIE
SHE'S GONNA START PRESCHOOL
VERY SOON. AND I KNOW THAT MY
WIFE AND I WOULD DO ANYTHING TO
MAKE IT WORK REGARDLESS OF THE
TIME THAT SHE'S GOING TO BE
STARTING SCHOOL AND I KNOW
THAT. SURFING WAS BROUGHT UP AS
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITY THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE GONNA BE
ABLE THE IMPLEMENTERS OR
SCHOOLS ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
DO WHAT YOU GO EARLY IN THE
MORNING ANYWAY SO QUITE
HONESTLY THEY'RE GONNA HAVE
MORE TIME TO SURF. AND I THINK
THAT'S A GREAT THING TO SELL I
WILL SAY THAT THIS IS THE RIGHT
THING. IS THE RIGHT POLICY AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
AMOS CALDERON. MR A GLORIA. YOU
MAY CLOSE. YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND I THINK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
THE DEBATE ON THIS ISSUE AN
ISSUE THIS HOUSE OR SEEN FOR
SEVERAL YEARS NOW I THINK THE
FIRST YEAR I JOCKEY THIS WE
WEREN'T ABLE TO GET THIS OFF
THE FLOOR SECOND YEAR WE DID
BUT IT DID NOT PASS THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. NOW HERE WE
ARE. AND I WOULD JUST SAY THAT.
I HEARD THE CONVERSATION I
AGREE WITH OUR MAJORITY LEADER
YOU KNOW. IF YOU CARE ABOUT
CHILDREN THE QUESTION BEFORE
YOU TONIGHT IS EXTREMELY SIMPLE
YOU VOTE FOR THIS BILL. YEAH
THERE ARE PARENTS WILL SAY THIS
IS DIFFICULT THEIR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THEY'LL TALK ABOUT
IMPLEMENTATION THERE IS
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT THIS WILL
COST BUT I ASK EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF YOU IS THERE ANY GREATER
COST. TO US IN THE IMPACT ON
OUR CHILDREN. AND THE SCIENCE
IN THIS DEBATE IS ABSOLUTELY
CLEAR. DATA SPANNING DECADES
NOT JUST A YEAR NOT JUST ONE
LITTLE FLIMSY STUDY NOT A
TWITTER POLL DATA OVER DECADES
HAS PROVED THAT NGUYEN SCHOOLS
START LATER TEENS GET MORE
SLEEP. THEY'RE HEALTHIER
THEY'RE HAPPIER THERE MORE
LIGHT LET'S THEIR MORE LESS
THEY'RE LESS LIKELY TO
CONTEMPLATE SUICIDE THEY'RE
LESS LIKELY TO GET IN CAR
ACCIDENTS THERE TENANTS GO UP.
THEIR GRADES GO UP THEIR
GRADUATION RATES GO UP SO
MEMBERS I THINK THIS IS A NO
BRAINER BUT I KNOW FOR MANY OF
YOU YOU ARE STRUGGLING WITH
THIS QUESTION. SO IF YOU ARE
NOT ELECTED HERE TO PUT
CHILDREN FIRST. AND WHY IN THE
HELL ARE YOU HERE. RIGHT. RIGHT
AND FOR THE DEMOCRATIC MEMBERS
OF THIS CAUCUS MANY OF YOU HAVE
MARCHED IN SIGHT IN MARCHES FOR
SCIENCE WITH SCIENCE IS
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR THE SCIENCES
ON THE SIDE OF VOTING HI ON
THIS MEASURE. OKAY. AND IF ANY
OF YOU PREFER A TWELVE A CLOCK
STARTING TIME FOR THIS
LEGISLATURE AS COMPARED TO NINE
AM THEN YOU HAVE NO CHOICE BUT
TO VOTE HI ON THIS MEASURE
MEMBER OUR CHILDREN ARE LOOKING
TO US FOR LEADERSHIP THE DATA
IS CLEAR. TEENS AND HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS NEED TO START LATER SO
I ASK YOU ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SET ASIDE THE
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT THE MONEY I STATE
PEOPLE WHO WILL TELL YOU WHY WE
SHOULD NOT DO THIS AND DO WHAT
IS RIGHT BY THE CHILDREN OF
THIS GREAT STATE AND VOTE I ON
SENATE BILL. THREE TWENTY EIGHT
MEMBER MEMBERS I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. MEMBERS. CLICK OVER
THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS OF.
RESERVE OUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A- ALL MEMBERS OF. TO
DECIDE OF
. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL. CLOSER
ROLE. TELL YOU THAT AYE AYES
FORTY FOUR NO SEVENTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASS. BETTER LATE THAN
NEVER
. YEAH. MEMBERS WE WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM
THIRTY NINE. SENATE BILL TWO
EIGHTEEN. CLICK RATE SENATE
BILL TWO EIGHTEEN BY SENATOR
BRADFORD AND ACTUALLY
DISCRIMINATION MISTER JONES
SAWYER THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE ON BEHALF OF CENTER
BRADFORD PRESENT SB TWO
EIGHTEEN SB TWO EIGHTEEN ALLOWS
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO ENFORCE
STATE LAW PROHIBITING
EMPLOYMENT DISCRIMINATION AND
THAT THEIR OWN ANTI
DISCRIMINATION ORDINANCE
RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT
CURRENTLY DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING IS THE
ONLY BODY IN THE STATE
AUTHORIZED TO ENFORCE TO STATES
ANTI DISCRIMINATION LAWS THE
DEPARTMENT RECEIVES AN AVERAGE
OF TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
DISCRIMINATION CLAIMS PER YEAR.
ONLY A FRACTION OF THESE
COMPLAINTS ARE FULLY
INVESTIGATED EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION AND RAMPANT IN
CALIFORNIA AND A CONSEQUENCES
ARE FELT GREATEST IN BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES THIS BILL WAS
ORIGINALLY A STATEWIDE MEASURE
HOWEVER THE BILL WAS NARROWED
IN THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE TO THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES LOS ANGELES COUNTY HAS
THE RESOURCES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE TRUCKS ARE
NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT LOCAL
ENFORCEMENT IS SUCCESSFUL.
FURTHER MEMBERS WERE MADE TO
CLARIFY THE PROCESS AND
PROCEDURES FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT ENACT THEIR
OWN ANTI DISCRIMINATION
ORDINANCE IN ASSURING THAT
WORKERS RIGHTS ARE PROTECTED IF
THEY FOLLOW AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
SB TWO EIGHTEEN FILLS A
CRITICAL ENFORCEMENT GAP AND
ENSURES THAT PEOPLE RETURN TO
WORK FASTER RECOVER LOST WAGES
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR LOCAL ECONOMY
AND APPLY FOR. THEIR FAMILIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
BOAT. THANK YOU MISTER JONES
SAWYER. SAYING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLICK LIBERAL. MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THEM ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. CLARK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES
FORTY SIX KNOWS THIRTEEN. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE UP THE
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE. SUPPLEMENTAL
NUMBER THREE. FILE ITEM FOUR OH
ONE. AB SEVEN FIFTY FOUR. CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
FIFTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GRAYSON ANOTHER'S AND ACTUALLY
TO REGIONAL NOTIFICATION
CENTERS RESTORATION MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES AB SEVEN
FIFTY FOURS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
WERE DESIGNED TO ENHANCE
PROTECTIONS FOR PEOPLE WHO
EXCAVATE. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MONEY.
THANK YOU MISTER GRAYSON SEE NO
DISCUSSION OF A CLERK LIBERAL
MEMBERS. THE CEREMONY ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL TIME
ABOUT I SEVENTY THREE. NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS PARKING KERN
IN. FILE ITEM FOUR OH TWO ON
THE SUPPLEMENTAL NUMBER THREE
IS AB ONE SEVENTY ONE.
KERKORIAN ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
SEVENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ AND OTHERS AND EXPLAIN
TO EMPLOYMENT. THIS IS ALICE
THANK YOU AND FIRST I WANT TO
APOLOGIZE TO THE MEMBERS
BECAUSE I FINALLY GOT MOST OF
MY BILLS OVER HERE SO YOU'RE
GOING TO HEAR FROM ME A LOT. I
RISE TO PRESENT AB ONE SEVENTY
ONE ON CONCURRENCE MOMENTS IN
THE SENATE ADDED A SIX MONTH
DELAY IN CLARIFIED THAT THE
PRESUMPTION THE BILL MAY BE
READ. BUT IT BY AN EMPLOYER IF
THE REASON FOR TAKING THE
ADVERSE ACTION WAS NON
RETALIATORY BUSINESS REASON.
THE AMENDMENTS ALSO CLARIFIED
THAT A CONFIDENTIAL REPORT
SUBMITTED TO A THIRD PARTY DID
NOT CONSTITUTE. AS AN EMPLOYEE
PROVIDE A NOTICE TO THE
EMPLOYER RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE. THANK YOU MS GONZALEZ
SENIOR DISCUSSION OF A- LOCAL
OF THE ROLE. MODELS ARE VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL
TALLY THE VOTE EYES FIFTY TWO
KNOWS TEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT. THIS IS FILE ITEM
FOUR OH THREE AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY SEVEN. ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ AND
OTHERS AN ACTUAL INTO LAW
ENFORCEMENT MS GONZALEZ THANK
YOU ARE AT THIS IS A LATINO
CAUCUS PARITY BILL THE
AMENDMENTS AND SENATE NARROWED
THE SCOPE OF THE BILL TO CLASS
AND CHANGE IMPLEMENTATION DATES
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
AGAIN MISS CONVULSING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK LIBERAL.
VOTERS ARE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
A DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF A RESERVE A CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL TELL YOU THAT I
SHOULD YOU KNOW SIXTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT. FILE
ITEM FOR A. B. TWELVE NINETY
SIX CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE NINETY SIX BY FAMILY
MEMBER GONZALEZ AND ACTUALLY TO
THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY. MS
GONZALEZ THANK YOU AB TWELVE
NINETY SIX HIS BACK FROM THE
SENATE ON CONCURRENCE
AMENDMENTS NEAR THE SCOPE OF
THE PROGRAM AND QUALIFIES
EXISTING TRUE INVESTIGATIVE
TEAMS. BASED IN SACRAMENTO AND
LOS ANGELES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I WROTE. THANK YOU SEE
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLICK
LOCAL THE ROLE. CEREMONY ALL
MEMBERS MEMBERS OUT OF A- ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL TOLIVER
I SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS. OUR CONCURRED IN
.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
ALLOW THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS TO
PRINT A LETTER IN THE JOURNAL
FOR THE FOLLOWING BILLS THESE
HAVE A SUPPORT SUPPORT POSITION
READING CLERK READ THE LIST OF
BILLS. THE CLERK WILL READ THE
SUPPORT SUPPORT LIST OF BILLS
AND AUTHORS. AT SOME LEVEL ONE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER IS
ILLEGAL FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ AS SOME PEOPLE THIRTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ IS
UNABLE ONE FIFTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TEAM AS A MALE ONE
SEVENTY NINE BY SOMETHING
MEMBER IS. SENATE BILL TWO
HUNDRED BY SENATOR MINING SOME
PEOPLE FOR TWENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA SOME OF
THE SIX FIFTY EIGHT BY
SOMETHING MEMBER ARAMBULA ISN'T
ABLE SEVEN A ONE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER AS SOME PEOPLE
SEVEN FORTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE TWENTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
AS A NAVAL TEN SIXTY SIX BASED
ON THE NUMBER GONZALEZ AND SOME
PEOPLE TWELVE SIXTY FOUR BY
SOME REMEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
IT'S ONLY WILL THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE BY SOME HUMOR MCCARTY AS
A MIDDLE FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER OR WHEN ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS. AS A MALE
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX BY
SOMETHING MEMBER TEAM AS A
MIDDLE FIFTEEN OH FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL AS A
MIDDLE FIFTEEN ELEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM AS ONLY
BOTH IT SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CREO. AS I'M
ABLE SEVENTEEN SIXTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CREO. AND
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY NINETY BY
SOME NEW MEMBER WICKS. OPPOSED
SAY NAY. AYE AYES HAVE IT
MOTION CARRIES. MISTER CALDERON
YOUR AGAIN RECOGNIZED FOR
ADDITIONAL MOTION SAY NOTHING
GOOD EVER HAPPENS AFTER
MIDNIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO ALLOW THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS TO PRINT A LETTER IN
THE JOURNAL FOR THE FOLLOWING
BILLS A. B. FOURTEEN THIRTEEN
GLORIA AB FOURTEEN A SEVENTEEN
AND A. B. SIXTEEN FIFTY EIGHT.
CARILLO MR FLORA YOUR RECOGNIZE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER WE
OBJECT AND ASK FOR A ROLL CALL
VOTE ON THE MOTION. WE WILL
TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE ON THE
MOTION THE MOTION IS SECONDED
BY MISTER BONTA. MISTER
CALDERON YOU'RE GONNA RECOGNIZE.
CLARIFICATION AB FORTY SEVEN
TWO DAVID CHIU. THE CLERK WILL
NOTE. WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR AND A SECOND BY MISTER
BONTA. THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE ON THE MOTION. CALDERON IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE MISTER
FLORA IS ASKING FOR A NO. VOTE
ON THE MOTION. MISTER CALDERON
IS ASKING FOR AYE MR FLORA NO.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE THE ROLE. I
SHOULD YOUR NOSE EIGHTEEN THE
MOTION CARRIES AND THE CLERK
SHALL KNOW
. MEMBERS. MEMBERS
ARE MOVING TO THE SUPPLEMENT A
FILE. WE'LL TAKE A FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE OH ONE. ASSEMBLY
BILL. ONE SEVENTY. NO
. FORGIVE
ME MEMBERS. I DON'T KNOW WHAT
OUR DIZZINESS ELEVEN ALL RIGHT
SO WE'RE GOING WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE. IT IS NOT
IT'S ONLY SEVEN OF FILE IT'LL
APPEAR ON THE BOARD. HAS
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE. THE
CLERK WILL I'M SORRY. MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR MOTION THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND THE RULES TO
ALLOW AUTHORS TO TAKE UP THE
FOLLOWING BILLS WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF. CONCURRENCE. THANK
YOU MISTER CALDERON
. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. THE REGISTRAR FILE
NUMBER FIVE OH ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
SEVENTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO EMPLOYMENT. IT'S
GONZALEZ GOOD MORNING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED GOOD MORNING MISTER
SPEAKER I AM I BRINGING UP AB
ONE SEVENTY I WILL START BY
TELLING YOU THIS IS A TERRIBLE
BILL AND I DO NOT PLAN TO VOTE
FOR IT HOWEVER. I DID IN FACT
AGREED TO TAKE THIS BILL AS THE
ONLY CONDITION IMPOSED UPON ME
BY THE SENATE IN ORDER TO GET
AB FIVE TAKEN UP EARLIER THIS
WEEK. AB ONE SEVENTY PROVIDES A
ONE YEAR EXTENSION FOR
NEWSPAPERS TO COMPLY WITH THE
DYNAMAX AND AB FIVE RULING. AND
WHILE THAT MAY SEEM INNOCUOUS.
IT IS SOMETHING IT'S FOR
NEWSPAPER CARRIERS IN
PARTICULAR. NEWSPAPER CARRIERS
IF YOU DON'T KNOW IN NEWSPAPER
PUBLICATIONS HAVE A LONG
HISTORY OF MISS CLASSIFYING
THEIR WORKERS IN FACT THE FULL.
FOUGHT OFF AND ACTUALLY PAID
OFF MULTIPLE LAWSUITS UNDER THE
PREVIOUS FOR ELLO TEST. THE
CASE IS THAT THEY'RE NOW FACE
SEEN INCLUDE WE JUST HEARD
ABOUT A SEVENTY YEAR OLD WOMAN
WHO. WORKS THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE DAYS A YEAR. EVERY SINGLE
DAY OF THE SEVEN DAYS A WEEK
AND GETS PAID ABOUT THREE
DOLLARS AN HOUR. IF SHE MISSES
THE DAY SHE ACTUALLY HAS TO PAY
THE DISTRIBUTION CENTER HUNDRED
DOLLARS IF SHE MISSES AYE HOW
SHE HAS TO PAY AT A DOLLAR.
THIS IS PROBABLY ONE OF THE
MISS MOST EXPLOITIVE. JOBS THAT
WE HAVE IT WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
THE DYNAMICS RULING IT REALLY
WAS MADE FOR SITUATIONS LIKE
THIS. THE VISUALS WHO HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY MISCLASSIFIED. WHO
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE NO ABILITY
TO SEARCH THE RIGHTS EXCEPT
THROUGH MASSIVE CLASS ACTION
SUITS AND THEY'RE OFTEN SETTLED
INTO NIGHT JUSTICE SO WE ARE
GOING TO DELAY IN TONIGHT
JUSTICE FOR ANOTHER YEAR. TO
THESE POOREST OF POOR WORKERS
MOST OF WHOM ARE WOMEN MANY OF
WHOM ARE IMMIGRANTS. BUT
BECAUSE THE NEWSPAPERS HAVE
DECIDED TO WEAPONIZE OR
EDITORIAL BOARDS IT IS
SOMETHING THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
THINK ARE VERY IMPORTANT. WITH
THAT. THAT'S MY BILL WHICH I
PLAN VOTE AGAINST AB ONE
SEVENTY. THANK YOU MISS
GONZALEZ. WE'LL TAKE THAT AS
YOUR CLOTHES. MR A O'DONNELL
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED I THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE SEVENTY
NEWSPAPERS ARE GETTING A ONE
YEAR REPRIEVE FROM AB FIVE
BECAUSE OF US SENATE REQUEST.
WE WAS HOLDEN NEWSPAPERS
ACCOUNTABLE DURING THIS ONE
YEAR THE NEWSPAPERS MUST SHOW
US THE FAIR CONTRACTING POLICY
AND THEY SHOULD NOT WASH THEIR
HANDS OF RESPONSIBILITY THEY
MUST ENSURE THAT THESE WORKERS
ARE TREATED FAIRLY OR CONVERT
THEM. TO EMPLOYEES I ASKED FOR
AND I HAVE A- THANK YOU MISTER
O'DONNELL. MR COOLEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. I'LL ALSO RISES FOR
JUST ON THE LEVEL OF I DO HAVE
AN INTEREST IN HOW THESE
SYSTEMS WORK FORGET IN THE NEWS
IN THE HANDS OF RURAL
INDIVIDUALS I KNOW THERE IS
THERE IS IN A STATE WHERE
CARRIERS MAY ACTUALLY CARRY
SEVERAL PAPERS AND SO WHO
EXACTLY THE OTHER EMPLOYEE FOR
I THINK THERE ARE SOME WRINKLES
ASSOCIATED WITH ALL THE NEWS
GETS DISTRIBUTED. AND I
SUPPORT. THIS WORK OUT FOR ONE
YEAR. THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY
MR FUNG YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. I
THANK YOU SPEAKER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE SEVENTY ARE
PRESSING PRINT MEDIA IS A
CRITICAL PART OF HOLDING OUR
GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABLE AND
BRINGING TRANSPARENCY TO OUR
POLITICAL PROCESS OUR
COMMUNITIES NEED STRONG
NEWSPAPERS WE KNOW THE
STRUGGLES OUR NEWSPAPERS ARE
CURRENTLY FACING FINANCIALLY.
IS IMPORTANT AT NEWSPAPERS HAVE
THIS RELIEF FROM THE DYNAMICS
INCISION IRISH NIVEAU. THANK
YOU MISTER FONG. MS RIVER US
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
VOTED TONIGHT FOR AB ONE
SEVENTY AND ASSEMBLY LABOR
COMMITTEE AS A COURTESY VOTE TO
GET THE BILL OUT OF THE
COMMITTEE I DID THIS TO PROVIDE
ALL OF YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE YOUR OWN DECISION ON THIS
LEGISLATION GIVEN THE STATE
WIDE IMPLICATIONS. I CAME TO
SACRAMENTO REPRESENT MY COMMUTE
MY CONSTITUENTS IN MY
COMMUNITIES PEOPLE IN MY
DISTRICT ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
WORKING THREE OR FOUR PART TIME
JOBS JUST TO MAKE ENDS MEET AND
THESE ARE WORKERS THAT FOR THE
MOST PART DON'T HAVE UNION
REPRESENTATION OF THIS
EXEMPTION. PROVIDES FOR WORKING
CLASS PEOPLE WHO NEED THE
PROTECTIONS THE MOST GOES
AGAINST Y. RAN FOR OFFICE IN
THE FIRST PLACE THEREFORE I
WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING AB ONE
SEVENTY TODAY. THANK YOU MS
REVERSE THIS CALL MADRE THAT
YOU'RE RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND GOOD MORNING
TO ALL OF YOU ALL I RISEIN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE SEVENTY I'M I
HAVE A NUMBER OF SMALL ETHNIC
BASED FAMILY OWNED NEWSPAPERS
IN MY DISTRICT THEY ARE LOCATED
IN THE DISTRICT THEY SERVICE
THE DISTRICT AND BEYOND I THINK
IT IS FAIR TO GIVE THEM A ONE
YEAR EXTENSION SO THAT THEY CAN
DO WHAT THEY NEED TO DO TO FIND
COMPLIANCE WITH THIS LAW AND
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE. THEIR
COMMUNITIES MY COMMUNITY WITH
THE INFORMATION THAT WE RELY ON
THANK YOU I ASK FOR YOUR EYE ON
AB ONE SEVEN. THANK YOU MS
KAMAGRA THAT DOCTOR WEBER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. YES MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE SEVENTY
AND THIS IS BEEN A VERY
DIFFICULT SITUATION
PARTICULARLY WITH THE WITH AB
FIVE AND ALL THE ISSUES IN THE
COMPLEXITIES AND THE CONFUSION
SURROUNDING THE BILL. SOME OF
YOU MAY HAVE SEEN ON ON YOUR
DESK FOR MY DESK THAT THERE
WOULD NUMBER OF BLACK
NEWSPAPERS OPPOSED TO THIS AND
THAT THEY IN DOUBLE ACP AND
OTHERS HAVE TAKEN POSITIONS
AGAINST AB FIVE. I WAS UNDER
THE IMPRESSION IT THAT THERE
HAD BEEN AN AGREEMENT REACHED
AS A RESULT OF THAT THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS PULL BACK THEIR
OPPOSITION TO AB FIVE BASED ON
THE FACT THAT AB ONE SEVENTY
WAS GOING TO BE THERE FOR THEM
TO GIVE THEM A ONE YEAR
REPRIEVE TO GET ORGANIZED IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE LIVE UP TO
THE AGREEMENTS THAT WE MAKE
WITH INDIVIDUALS I THINK THAT
IS VERY IMPORTANT. I'VE LEARNED
THAT AT THE ON THIS HOUSE ANY
TIME I'VE HAD A BILL WE JUST
DID THAT WITH THREE NINE TWO
WHEN YOU MAKE A DEAL AND YOU
MAKE AN AGREEMENT YOU'RE
SUPPOSE YOU SHOULD LIVE UP TO
IT AND I THINK THAT THE BLACK
PRESS HAS CALLED ME SEVERAL
TIMES A DAY TO MAKE SURE. THAT
AB ONE SEVENTY WAS COMING TO
THE FLOOR I THOUGHT EVERYTHING
WAS FINE I DID NOT KNOW THAT
THE THAT THE AUTHOR ROBERT WAS
NOT IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
BECAUSE I WAS ON THE IMPRESSION
THAT THAT AGREEMENT HAD BEEN
MADE AND THAT IT WASN'T A
PERFECT BILL BUT MANY OF YOU
HAD ISSUES WITH THE BILL. AB
FIVE AND SOLD UNDERSTANDING WAS
THAT THERE WAS SOME AGREEMENT
SO WILL COMING FORTH
PARTICULARLY FOR THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE SO I STRONGLY
SUGGESTED WE LIVE UP TO THE
AGREEMENT THAT WAS REACHED
OBVIOUSLY WITH THE PRESS FOR A.
B. R. ONE SEVENTY IT'S A ONE
YEAR EXTENSION IT'S NOT PERFECT
GOD. I WAS NOT I WAS CONCERNED
WITH THE PRESS BASICALLY
RAISING A NUMBER OF ISSUES
BECAUSE I DIDN'T THINK ALL
THOSE ISSUES WE'RE GOING TO BE
TRUE IN TERMS OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BILL SO
BUT BECAUSE THE AGREEMENT WAS
MADE I WAS GOING TO BOTH AB
FIVE ANYWAY. BUT BECAUSE THE
AGREEMENT WAS MADE THAT THEY
WOULD BE PROTECTED FOR ONE YEAR
UNTIL THEY WORKED OUT THIS
ISSUE I THOUGHT OKAY FINE THEN
THEY WHAT THEY PULL BACK THEIR
OPPOSITION. SEVERAL OF YOU
ASKED ME ABOUT WHAT ABOUT THE
IN DOUBLE ACP AND I SAID I
THINK THAT HAS BEEN PULLED
BACK. THE BLACK PRESS IS PULL
BACK THEIR OPPOSITION AND I
RECOMMEND IT TO SEVERAL
INDIVIDUALS THAT THEY BOTH AB
FIVE. SO I THINK AT THIS POINT
AB ONE SEVENTY IS THE LEAST
THAT WE CAN DO WITH A ONE YEAR
EXTENSION TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
LIVE UP TO THE AGREEMENT. THAT
THAT PRESS THINKS THAT WE MADE
TO THEM. AND I'VE HAD AS A SAID
SEVERAL CALLS FROM THE
PRESIDENT OF THE BLACK PRESS
AND A HOST OF OTHERS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE. CONCERNING AB
FIVE IN THEIR PERCEPTION OF HOW
IT WAS GOING TO HAVE A NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON THEM. AND THE ONE
YEAR EXTENSION WOULD PROVIDE
THEM WITH THE ABILITY. TO
ADJUST BECAUSE MANY OF THEM
BELIEVE IN MAYBE AND THE
PROBLEM IS NOT TRUE. BUT IF
THEY DO THAT IF. THE WAY AB
FIVE WAS PUT IN PLACE. THEY
WOULD HAVE TO GO OUT OF
BUSINESS BECAUSE IT WAS SMALL.
NEWSPAPERS RUN BY JUST
SOMETIMES THEIR FAMILIES AND IT
WAS A LOT OF. COMPLICATED
ISSUES ABOUT THE COURIERS AND
THIS AND THAT. AND THIS GAVE
THEM THE ASSURANCE THAT THEY'D
HAVE A YEAR. TO RESPOND TO IT
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU
BOTH AB ONE SEVENTY. I'M NOT
SAYING IT'S A PERFECT MEAL BUT
I THINK THERE WAS AN AGREEMENT
MATE. AND THEY HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS WAS
GOING TO COME FORWARD. TO
HANDLE THE ISSUES AND ANSWER
THE QUESTIONS THEY HAVE. BUT AB
FIVE. I HOPE THAT WE BOTH FOR
AB ONE SEVENTY. THANK YOU
DOCTOR WEBER. MR HOLDEN. IF YOU
LIKE TO FOLLOW DOCTOR WHETHER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT MY COLLEAGUES TO
BASICALLY LAID OUT THE ARGUMENT
IN FAVOR OF. THIS PARTICULAR
BILL AB ONE SEVENTY I CONCUR
WITH THEM AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR I DON'T. THANK YOU
MISTER HOLDEN. MISTER BASS
THANK YOU IS BRB QUICKLY WITH
THIS LATE HOUR OF I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL MY FIRST
JOB WAS DID WAS A PAPER BOY AND
I TURNED TO MY ONE ROUTE INTO
SIX OR SEVEN ROUTES AND I WELL
I HEARD THE STORY ABOUT OTHERS
WHO WEREN'T ABLE TO MAKE ENDS
MEET WITH THEIR PAPER OUT I
BOUGHT MY FIRST VEHICLE IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE DOTS AND
PICK UP. WITH THE MONEY THAT I
MADE IT SO THAT I INSTEAD OF
RIDING A BIKE COULD USE A TRUCK
OF FOR THAT ROUTE AND I TURNED
THAT TRUCK INTO. MY VEHICLE
WHICH WAS A JEEP WRANGLER WHICH
WAS PRETTY FANTASTIC BUT NOT
JUST THE BUYING VEHICLES IT
ALSO PUT ME THROUGH COLLEGE NOT
ONLY DID IT PUT ME THROUGH MY
FIRST COUPLE YEARS OF COLLEGE
IT PUT SOME FRIENDS OF MINE
WHO. WERE STRUGGLING TO MAKE
ENDS MEET AYE AYE ALLOWED THEM
TO BE ABLE TO USE THAT ROUTE
AND HELP TO HELP THEM OUT AND
I'LL STILL NEVER FORGET WHEN MY
MOM CAME TO ME WITH TEARS IN
HER EYES BECAUSE SHE WASN'T
ABLE TO MAKE THE MORTGAGE
PAYMENT THAT MONTH THAT SHE HAD
TO BORROW FROM HER EIGHTEEN
YEAR OLD SON. BECAUSE OF WHAT
THAT PAPER OUT DID SO I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE THIS
EVENING KNOWING THAT ONE SIZE
DOESN'T FIT ALL AND SOMETIMES
THERE ARE OPTIONS FOR US
OPTIONS FOR WORKERS AND FOR ME
THAT PAPER OUT OF MADE A HUGE
IMPACT IN MY LIFE AND TAUGHT ME
THE DIGNITY OF WORK I RISE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER MAYES.
SENIOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION IS GONZALEZ
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE DESERT IPAD I BELIEVE
IN THE YEARS PAST SINCE YOU
WERE EIGHTEEN MAYBE THE FOLKS
WHO HAVE TAKEN ON THOSE JOBS
MIGHT CHANGE A LITTLE I ALSO
HAD A PAPER ROUTE. WHEN I WAS
TWELVE IT WAS AN INTERESTING
WAY TO START WORK I'M I WILL
SAY THIS IN IN REGARDS TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO THERE
WAS A DEAL CUT APPARENTLY THE
DEAL BETWEEN THE NEWSPAPERS WAS
NOT A DEAL WITH ME. AND IF I
HAD CUT THAT DEAL I WOULD NOT
STAND UP AND SAY. I DON'T
SUPPORT A BILL I'M TAKING. I
WAS FORCED. TO ADD NEWSPAPERS.
NEWSPAPER CARRIERS. TO A BILL
IN ORDER TO BRING UP MAYBE
FIVE. I WAS VERY CLEAR WITH THE
FOLKS IN THE SENATE. THAT I
WOULD DO THAT AND I SAID FILLED
MY RESPONSIBILITY IN FACT BY
NOW PRESENTING THIS FOR THE
THIRD TIME. BUT I WAS ALSO VERY
CLEAR THAT I PERSONALLY WOULD
NOT BE VOTING FOR IT. AND THAT
I WOULD EXPRESS THAT IN SO I
WOULD BE. I I'M NOT ASKING
ANYBODY TO NOT VOTE FOR IT I'M
NOT ASKING ANYBODY TO VOTE OR
SOMETHING I CAN'T VOTE FOR. SO
I JUST WANT TO BE ON IS THAT
WHILE THERE MIGHT HAVE BEEN AN
AGREEMENT. THE NEWSPAPERS NEVER
TALK TO ME ABOUT THAT
AGREEMENT. OF MY GREEN MEANT
WAS SIMPLY WITH THE SENATE TO
BRING UP A BILL THAT I STILL
BELIEVE IS A VERY BAD BILL. AND
THE REASON I A I AM SO STRONGLY
PERSONALLY OPPOSE QUITE FRANKLY
IS BECAUSE WHEN I APPROACHED I
KNOW MAX WOULD TAKE A LOT OF.
CRITICISM FOR. IN THE AB FIVE.
WE HAD A SPECIFIC TASK WE
THOUGHT ABOUT YOU KNOW WE
THOUGHT ABOUT. THE JOBS THAT
SHOULD BE EXACT. FROM FROM
DYNAMAX JOBS WITH HIGH BARRIER
TO ENTRY. SO THAT INDIVIDUALS
COULD BARGAIN FOR THEMSELVES.
JOBS WHERE THAT WORKERS GETTING
AT LEAST TWICE THE MINIMUM
WAGE. JOBS WHERE IT TAKES A
LITTLE BIT MORE TO ACTUALLY GET
INTO A JOB AND YOU HAVE. OUR
THAT IS NOT WHAT THIS IS. WHEN
YOU READ THE DYNAMICS DECISION
IF YOU EVER HAVE. THIS IS
EXACTLY WHAT THE SUPREME COURT
WAS TRYING TO GUARD AGAINST THE
NEWSPAPER INDUSTRY I WANT TO
POINT OUT HAS A LONG HISTORY. A
MISS CLASSIFICATION THEY KNEW
WHAT THEY WERE FACING. WHEN
THEY BROUGHT THIS OFFER TO THE
SENATE THEY KNEW THE NUMBER OF
LAWSUITS THAT THEY'RE FACING
AND THE NUMBER OF THEIR
CARRIERS THAT THEY WERE GOING
TO JUST AND POWER. I'M EATING
THAT'S JUST THE FACTS IN I
WOULD BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T
STATE THEM UNFORTUNATELY WE
DON'T GET TO HEAR THE STORIES
ABOUT THOSE DELIVERY FOLKS AND
SO IT IS MY AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
MY PASSION TO REPRESENT WORKERS
AND I'M JUST DOING MY BEST TO
MY OBLIGATION TO THE SENATE
WHICH WAS TO BRING ONE SEVENTY
UP. AND WITHOUT AYE AYE YEAH
SAVE YOU KNOW. BUT AS YOU WELL.
THANK YOU MS GONZALEZ. MEMBERS
ACTUALLY CLICK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED OF A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY
THE VOTES HI SIXTY TWO KNOWS
FOR THE MEASURE PASSES. SEVEN
MINUTES ARE CONCURRENT
. FILE
ITEM FIVE OH TWO AB THIRTY
EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY EIGHT BY
FAMILY MEMBER WOULD AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY IN A FIRE SAFETY
MISTER WOULD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB THIRTY EIGHT IS
PROPOSING THE FIRST EVER FIRE
RETROFIT PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA
TO HELP OWNERS OF OLDER HOMES
HARDEN THEIR HOMES AND MAKE
THEM MORE LIKELY TO SURVIVE
FUTURE FIRES. SENATE AMENDMENTS
NEAR THE BILL TO A FIVE YEAR
PILOT PROGRAM PROGRAM THE BILL
HAS NOT NO HOUSE NO OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
IT THAT SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROOM
ALL MEMBERS WHO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS GO TO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW YOU VOTE I SIXTY NINE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM FIVE
BOTH THREE AB FIFTY FOR THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTY FOUR BY SOME A MEMBER
TING AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY DO
RECYCLING MAKING APPROPRIATIONS
AIRPORT THERE IT'S EITHER UP
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
SEARCHING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THINK ABOUT SPEAKER AB FIFTY
FOUR IS IN THE EMERGENCY SHORT
TERM BILL TO DO WITH OUR
RECYCLING CRISIS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AS WERE WHERE WE'VE
HAD ALMOST THREE HUNDRED
RECYCLING CENTERS AROUND THE
STATE CLOSE AB FIFTY FOUR
APPROPRIATE UP TO FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR RECYCLING CENTERS
ACROSS THE STATE. PROFITS FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FROM MOBILE
RECYCLING CENTERS ACROSS THE
STATE AND ALSO TAKES AWAY THE
FINES FOR THE CONVENIENCE
STORES AND GROCERY STORES
BETWEEN NOW AND MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY HI SO GIVE US TIME TO DO
A BIGGER FIX REGARDING OUR
BOTTLE BILL NEXT YEAR. WITH
RESPECT AS RIVAL FOR A. B.
FIFTY FOUR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHANG SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THE- ALL
MEMBERS THAT YOU DESERVE IT. ON
MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A. WORK
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE
EYES SEVENTY NO ZERO SAN IN
MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE AB
SEVEN NINETY TO THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
NINETY TO BUY SOMETHING MEMBER
TING AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
RECYCLING. MR TING YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I AB SEVENTY TWO IS THE
MOST AGGRESSIVE RECYCLING
PROGRAM REGARDING RECYCLE
PLASTIC IN BOTTLES IN THE
COUNTRY YOU ESTABLISHES A CALL
A 50% BY TWENTY THIRTY AND
ASKED THAT WE CREATE A MINIMUM
RECYCLE CONTENT IN OUR BEVERAGE
BOTTLES. WE ALL KNOW THAT IF WE
DON'T DO SOMETHING ABOUT THE
AMOUNT OF PLASTICS WE HAVE IN
OUR SOCIETY BY TWENTY FIFTY
WILL ACTUALLY HAVE MORE
PLASTICS IN THE OCEAN THEN FISH
SO I AB SEVEN NINETY TWO IS A
PROGRAM THAT REALLY WE WORKED
VERY VERY HARD WE WERE ABLE TO
REMOVE THE INDUSTRY OPPOSITION
WE SPENT A YOU CAN REALLY THIS
YEAR WORKING WITH THE DEVICE
BUT THAT'S DOABLE REALISTIC WE
ALSO PUT IN OFF RAMPS TO
ENSURE. THAT IF I RECYCLE
PLASTIC WASN'T AVAILABLE THE
CHARISMATIC WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY IN THE OPTION TO
PUT A PART OF THE PROGRAM AGAIN
WE'RE VERY VERY PROUD OF THIS
AND WE WANT TO THANK MY AND MY
JOINT AUTHOR WHO SPEAK NEXT ON
THIS ISSUE AND THANK THANK HER
FOR ALL THE HARD WORK THAT WE
DID TOGETHER FISHER WITHOUT
RESPECTFULLY I ASKED. THE CLASS
RIVAL ON A. B. SEVEN NINETY TWO
THANK YOU MISTER TING MISTER
WHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER AND
I WILL MAKE THIS QUICK AB SEVEN
NINE TUNE IS AN IMPORTANT BILL
TO INCREASE THE CONTENT OF
RECYCLED MATERIALS AND BOTTLES
BUT ALSO TO CHANGE THE MARKET
WITHIN THE RECYCLING INDUSTRY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING AND I
WORKED EXTENSIVELY WITH
INDUSTRY STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE
THAT THE BILL IS BOLD. AND
WORKABLE AND WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION AND THE RESULT IS
THE MOST AGGRESSIVE RECYCLED
CONTENT MANDATE NOT ONLY IN THE
UNITED STATES IS MISTER TING
MENTIONED BUT IN THE WORLD. OF
FOR PLASTIC BOTTLES 50%
RECYCLED CONTENT BY. TWENTY
THIRTY PLEASE JOIN US IN
SUPPORTING THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE. THANK YOU MISTER ONE
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THEIR- ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESERTED THE- ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESERVE A- ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE EYES FIFTY THREE KNOWS
TWELVE SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE AB
TWELVE OH TO THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE OH
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TRIAL AND
ACTUALLY TO PRIVACY MR CHOW YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS A.
B. TWELVE A TWO REQUIRES DATA
BROKERS TO REGISTER WITH AND
PAY A REGISTRATION FEE TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS IT ALSO REQUIRES THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO MAKE THIS
INFORMATION AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC ON IT SO WEBSITE. SENATE
AMENDMENTS ADDED DEFINITIONS
AND MATE TECHNICAL CHANGES TO
THE BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAO
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESERTED THE- ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. OUR
MEMBERS VOTED TO CERTIFY A.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY EIGHT
KNOWS FOURTEEN SENTIMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN
. MEMBERS IF ANYONE
WOULD LIKE TO BE RECOGNIZED FOR
A VOTE CHANGE WE CAN ENTERTAIN
Và CHANGES AT THIS. TIME. MISS
PORTER HER BACK YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YES VOTE CHANGE AB
FIFTY FOUR FROM I'D NOT VOTING.
VOTE CHANGE IT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTY FOUR I TO NOT VOTING. MR
WHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IRWIN
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY YES NOT
VOTING. THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN SOME ABLE THIRTEEN
TWENTY I IT'S NOT VOTING. MR
CHOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED CHANGE
SB THREE TWENTY EIGHT FROM I TO
NOT VOTING. VOTE CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAU SENATE
BILL THREE TWENTY EIGHT I IT'S
NOT VOTING
. MEMBERS WE WILL
TAKE UP FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT. THE CLERK
WILL READ THAT'S ON THE BILL
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GALLAGHER AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
BUSINESS. MR GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MEMBERS
I. AB ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT IS
BACK FOR FROM CONCURRENCE IN
THE SENATE. THE MEMBERS TAKING
THE SENATE ENSURE THE BILL
FUNCTIONS AS INTENDED. THIS
BILL IS A CRITICAL STEP TO
ENSURING THAT THE INTENT IN
PROTECTIONS FOR YOUTH OUTLINED
IN THE C. C. P. A. R.
MAINTAINED AS THEY APPLY TO
SOCIAL MEDIA. EVERY DAY KIDS
ARE TARGETED. AND ABUSED ON
SOCIAL MEDIA. HUMAN TRAFFICKERS
USE THESE PLATFORMS TO TARGET
OUR KIDS. BULLIES DRIVE KIDS TO
SUICIDE. ON THE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS. IN AB ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT HELPS ENSURE THAT PARENTS
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO EDUCATE
THEIR KIDS ABOUT SAVE SOCIAL
MEDIA USE BEFORE THEY ARE
BULLIED OR EXPLOITED ONLINE.
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE
REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION TECH NET
AND THE INTERNET ASSOCIATION
HAVE ARE NOT IN OPPOSITION HAVE
GONE NEUTRAL. THIS BILL
RECEIVED THIRTY ONE VOTES. IN
THE SENATE IT IS SUPPORTED BY
COMMON SENSE MEDIA AND THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION.
AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE THE.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER
MISTER LOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
UNFORTUNATELY IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION AS WE
SAID BEFORE ON THIS FOR BUT I
DO THE LATENESS OF THE HOUR I
WOULD JUST URGE AND REAFFIRM
THE IMPORTANCE OF YOUNG LGBT
YOUTH TRYING TO FIND
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR
IDENTITY AND MANY OF TIMES TO
WHICH IS. THE INTERNET AND
SOCIAL PLATFORMS IS THE ONLY
WAY THAT THEY CAN FIND A
POSITIVE INFORMATION ABOUT
MAKING SENSE OF WHAT IT MEANS
TO BE AN LGBT Q. MEMBER OF OUR
SOCIETY WITHOUT FEAR OF PARENTS
PERSECUTION OF WHO THEY ARE AS
INDIVIDUALS AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK. FOR A NO VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER MISTER O'DONNELL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED MATTERS FIGURE
THERE'S A GOOD BILL THAT
PROTECTS KIDS. VOTE AYE. THE
CUNNINGHAM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I KNOW
IT'S LATE BUT I'D OFFER THIS
DATA POINT FOR THOSE YOU ON THE
FENCE ACCORDING TO A RECENT
STUDY. BY THE JOURNAL OF
ABNORMAL PSYCHOLOGY TEENAGE
DEPRESSION RATES OF THE PAST
YEAR INCREASE 52% AND OVER THE
PAST DECADE TEENAGE DEPRESSION
HAS INCREASED SIXTY THREE
PERCENT. THIS IS IN PART DUE TO
THE RISE OF SOCIAL MEDIA USE
KIDS ARE GETTING BULLIED. LIKE
CRAZY ON SNAPCHAT AND ON FACE
BUT WHY THEY DON'T USE FACEBOOK
THAT'S FOR ALL PEOPLE. BUT ON
SNAPCHAT AND INSTAGRAM AND ALL
SORTS OF OTHER THINGS I DON'T
EVEN KNOW THE NAMES OF BUT THAT
OUR- OUR KIDS ARE GETTING
BULLIED ALL WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS CREATE A SITUATION WHERE
THERE'S A CONVERSATION. BEFORE
SOMEBODY TWELVE AND UNDER.
STARTS A SOCIAL MEDIA ACCOUNT
WITH THE PARENT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE USING THIS. MEDIUM
IN A RESPONSIBLE WAY. I THINK
IT'S A POSITIVE STEP FOR
CHILDREN OUR STATE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE THE.
THANK YOU MISTER CUNNINGHAM
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER MISTER
GALLERY MAKE CLOTHES. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER IN YEAH WE'VE
WE'VE DEALT WITH SOME IMPORTANT
ISSUES THIS YEAR WE'VE- WE'VE
TAKEN ON PREDATORY LENDING
WE'VE TAKEN ON THE OPIOID
CRISIS IN THIS STATE AND IN
DOING SO WE'VE TAKEN ON
POWERFUL INTERESTS. AND REQUIRE
THEM TO BE RESPONSIBLE. WITH
THE GREAT POWER THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN GIVEN. THIS IS ANOTHER
STEP IN THAT PROCESS AND IN
HOLDING PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE
HOLDING THESE CUT TECH
COMPANIES RESPONSIBLE. FOR
ABUSES THAT ARE GOING ON WITH
OUR YOUTH. SO TODAY I ASK YOU
TO HELP IMPORT HELP PASS THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE. AGAIN THIS
IS HAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THERE
IS NO REGISTERED OPPOSITION. TO
THIS BILL AND AGAIN I WOULD ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE. SCORES FORTY ONE
. ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ART ABOUT THIS
REQUIRES. MISTER CALDERON MOVES
A COUGH. MOVING TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY FOUR SB SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AND ACTUALLY
THE STATE PROPERTY AND HIGHWAYS.
MISS CAREER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE 2% SB
SEVEN ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
PORTANTINO SB SEVEN RESTRICTS
CALTRANS FROM CONSTRUCTING A
FREEWAY TUNNEL SURFACE FREEWAY
OR EXPRESSWAY FOR STATE ROUTE
SEVEN TEN BETWEEN INTERSTATE
TEN AND STATE ROUTE TO TEND AND
AS OF JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR REDEFINES PARTS OF THE
STATE ROUTE SEVEN TEND TO
INCLUDE. THE PORTION BETWEEN
INTERSTATE TEN AND INTERSTATE
TWO TEN ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL
PROVIDES PROTECTIONS FOR
CURRENT CALTRANS TENANTS
SPECIFICALLY IT ALLOWS CALTRANS
TO SELL THE PROPERTIES TO SIX
NON PROFITS AT A VALUE IN USE
OR FAIR MARKET VALUE WHICHEVER
PRICE IS THE LOWEST SECOND IT
DELETES A SUNSET THAT WOULD
REQUIRE CALTRANS TO UNFREEZE
THE RENTS OF AFFORDABLE RENT
PROGRAM TENANTS. AND LASTLY IT
OPENS UP THE AFFORDABLE RUN
PROGRAM TO ANY TENANT WHO HAS
BEEN RECITING AS A TENANT ON OR
BEFORE JULY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN I LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR PORTANTINO FOR WORKING
SO DILIGENTLY ON THIS ISSUE AND
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS CARILLO MR
HOLDEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I WOULD
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AS
WELL LET ME JUST TELL YOU AS A
MEMBER WHO REPRESENTS THE
PASADENA AREA AND FOR THE LAST
THREE YEARS WE'VE BEEN WORKING
ON A NUMBER OF ISSUES A GOOD
NUMBER OF THEM ARE IDENTIFIED
IN THIS BILL. WE HAVE A
COMPANION BILL AB TWENTY NINE
THAT'S BEING ADDRESSED NOW IN
THE SENATE AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO THESE BOTH BOTH OF THESE
BILLS MOVING FORWARD. I THINK
THE COMMUNITY AFTER SIXTY YEARS
OF SORT OF PUSHING AGAINST A
PROJECT THAT WAS GOING TO HAVE
A DETRIMENTAL IMPACT ON THE
SURROUNDING AREA THE SOLUTION
WHERE WE FIND OURSELVES IN
RIGHT NOW IS GOOD FOR ALL
PARTIES AND SO I WOULD. ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ON THE SP SEVEN.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER. THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. OF ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE HE'S THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. LAW MISTER CALDERON MOVES
A CALL
. DO ANY MEMBERS HAVE
CHANGES ANY VOTE CHANGES FROM
YOUR DESK MEMBERS. MR ADD SHALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER OF A CHANGE SB SEVEN
FROM I TO NOT VOTING. CHANGE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHILD SENATE
BILL SEVEN I IT'S NOT VOTING.
MISERIA. I'M BLANCA RUBIO SB
THREE TWENTY THREE FROM I TO
NOT LOAD. THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO SENATE BILL THREE
TWENTY THREE I IT'S NOT VOTING.
MS QUIRK SILVA. SB TWENTY FOUR
FROM AN I TO NOT VOTING. VOTE
CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
SILVA SENATE BILL TWENTY FOUR I
IT'S NOT VOTING
. MEMBERS ARE
PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL. ON
SB SEVEN. THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A
.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A
BECAUSE IT. WE'LL CALL
. MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND THE RULES TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ TO TAKE
UP AB TWO EIGHTEEN WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FOLLOW FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CONCURRENCE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. BUT I
. WITHOUT
REFERENCE THE FILE AB TWO
EIGHTEEN GONZALEZ CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO EIGHTEEN BY
FAMILY MEMBER GONZALEZ AND
ACTUALLY THE CHILDHOOD SEXUAL
ASSAULT. MS GONZALEZ. YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB TWO EIGHTEEN
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE WITH
MINOR TECHNICAL CHANGES MADE IN
THE SENATE AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN ID GIVE VICTIMS
FINELY A VOICE IN A I HAVE LONG
OVER DUE PROCESS. SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE MEMBERS OTHERS
OUT OF VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. THE WORK WELL.
AS A ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY TWO
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN
. MEMBERS I'M
PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL. ON
SB SEVEN CARPOOL POSTS. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSER ROLE.
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY ONE NO
SEVEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND THE RULES
WILL ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN TO
TAKE UP AB TWENTY NINE WITHOUT
REFERENCE THE FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CONCURRENCE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION THAT REQUEST IS
GRANTED THIS IS WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE. AB TWENTY
NINE COVERAGE. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINE BY SOME REMEMBER
HOLDEN AND ACTUALLY THE
HIGHWAYS THIS YOUR HOLDEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER LET ME
JUST SAY THAT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINE WE WERE ABLE TO
REFERENCE ID AND SENATE BILL
SEVEN THAT WAS BROUGHT BEFORE
US A LITTLE WHILE AGO. AND AS I
SHARED WITH ALL OF YOU AT THAT
TIME THIS IS A LOCAL PROJECT IT
HAS BEEN A CHALLENGING PROJECT
OF THE LAST SIXTY YEARS THE
COMMUNITY HAS COME TOGETHER. I
HAD MADE IT VERY CLEAR WHEN I
JOIN THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY AND
STARTED TAKING POSITIONS THAT
SUPPORTED CARBON REDUCTION.
THAT THIS PROJECT WAS ONE THAT
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE. WAS
STOPPED IN THAT WE WOULD MOVE
IN A DIRECTION THAT WAS
BENEFICIAL TO COMMUNITIES.
MOVING TOGETHER AND WORKING
TOGETHER GOING FORWARD AND SO
WITH THAT IT'S BACK ON
CONCURRENCE AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. MS
CARILLO. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY NINE I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FROM PASADENA
FOR WORKING SO DILLON
DILIGENTLY. ON THIS ISSUE AND
ON THIS BILL THE FIGHT TO BUILD
OR NOT BUILD THE SEVEN TEN
FREEWAY EXTENSION HAS BEEN
ONGOING FOR DECADES. MUCH
LONGER THAN I'VE EVEN BEEN
ALIVE IT'S A FIGHT MY OFFICE
HAS INHERITED AND NOW THAT WE
KNOW FOR CERTAIN THAT THE SEVEN
TEN FREEWAY EXTENSION IS NOT
HAPPENING. WE'RE WORKING VERY
HARD TO RESOLVE THE PENDING
LOCAL ISSUES I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FOR BEING. SO OPEN TO
A DIALOGUE OF MY OFFICE MADE
SURE TO INCLUDE CAL STATE LA
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES AND
METRO WHICH REPRESENTS THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES. A TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY WERE INCLUDED IN
CONVERSATIONS VERY EARLY ON WE
HELP DRAFT LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
THAT INCLUDED THE NINE DOUBLE
OH THREE TWO. COMMUNITY OF EL
SERENO THE NINE DOUBLES SIX
THREE COMMUNITY OF CITY TERRACE
IN EAST LA. AS WELL AS CAL
STATE LA IN ANY CONVERSATIONS
MOVING FORWARD THAT WOULD
IMPACT THE NEIGHBORHOODS AROUND
THE VALLEY EXIT OF THE SEVEN
TEN FREEWAY. MY INTENT WAS TO
MAKE SURE MY DISTRICT WAS
REPRESENTED SADLY THESE
AMENDMENTS WERE REMOVED AS THE
BILL MOVE FORWARD AND THE
SENATE. AND ALTHOUGH THE
REMOVAL OF THE LANGUAGE IS
UNFORTUNATE THIS BILL
GUARANTEES THAT THE DECADES
LONG FIGHT OVER THE FREEWAY IS
DONE. THERE WILL BE NO
EXTENSION AND IT ENSURE THAT
THE SURROUNDING NEIGHBORHOOD
STAKEHOLDERS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HAVE A SEAT AT THE
TABLE WHEN IT COMES TO ANY
FUTURE COMMUNITY PROJECTS SUCH
AS A LOCAL PARK. WE WILL
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORED STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
FUTURE. AND NIGHT RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK
THANK YOU MISS GRAHAM THIS
FRAZIER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER JUST WANT TO COMMEND
OUR MY COLLEAGUES FOR HIS DOG
WITH A BONE OF WITH THIS THIS
PROJECT IN UNDERSTANDING THIS
PROJECT WAS UNATTAINABLE IN ON
AFFORDABLE AND GOING TO ANOTHER
DIRECTION TOO BIG TO BETTER THE
PEOPLE'S OPPORTUNITIES FOR
TRANSPORTATION METHODS I WANT
TO APPLAUD YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR STICKING WITH THIS AND
MAKING SURE. THAT YOUR
CONSTITUENTS ARE REPRESENTED
WELL. THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER.
THANK YOU MEMBERS MISTER HOLDEN
YOU MAY CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR I WILL TACKLE OF
MINERAL. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THOUGH. THE
CLERK WILL. CLOSER ALL TALLY
THE VOTE EYES FIFTY SIX KNOWS
FIVE. SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN
. MEMBERS. IF WE
COULD HAVE YOUR ATTENTION
PLEASE MEMBERS. WE DO HAVE
REMAINING BUSINESS BEFORE THIS
HOUSE BUT AS WE WIND DOWN. WE
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
PROPERLY KNOWLEDGE THE WORK OF
THE ENTIRE MINISTRY OF STAFF OF
THE ASSEMBLY MAKE SPECIAL NOTE.
FIRST OFF THE WORK OF OUR
SERGEANTS TO KEEP THE BUSINESS
OF THE HOUSE MOVING. AND I LIKE
TO THINK RANDY IN PARTICULAR
FOR HIS ASSISTANCE DOWN THE
STRETCH LET'S GIVE THEM ALL A
ROUND. AND AS YOU WELL KNOW
MEMBERS AFTER TWENTY SEVEN
YEARS TONIGHT AS HE DOES SO
WELL SINCE FINAL SESSION HAS
CHEAPER. UNDER JOHNSON'S
GUIDANCE THE CLERK STAFF SETS
THE NATIONAL STANDARD AND WE
ARE SO VERY PROUD OF ALL. OF
THEIR WORK. IT DOESN'T HAVE
ALREADY SAID MY PIECE FROM THIS
ROSTRUM BUT I WILL ONLY ADD
THAT IT IS NOW COLLECTIVELY OUR
CHARGE. TO CARRY FORWARD YOUR
LEGACY BY INSURANCE WITH
OPERATIONS AND ADHERENCE TO THE
RULES. AND THE HIGHEST
STANDARDS ON THIS FLOOR. AND WE
WILL ENDEAVOR TO MAKE YOU PROUD
THANK YOU SIR
. MEMBERS SAVE
SOME OF THAT APPLAUSE WE'RE NOT
DONE YET MISTER CALDERON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS REALLY
QUICK I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
FLOOR TEAM AND EVERYBODY THAT
WORKED REALLY HARD TO MAKE SURE
THIS SESSION WENT AS SMOOTHLY
AS POSSIBLE WITH THE EXCEPTION
OF TODAY WE ARE VERY EFFICIENT
WHEN WE- ARE ON THE FLOOR. VERY
RARELY DO WE SIT AND WAIT WITH
NOTHING TO DO EXCEPT FOR TODAY.
BUT AGAIN WE'RE DEALING WITH
THE SENATE THAT'S JUST THE WAY
IT GOES. SO I JUST WANT TO TAKE
A MOMENT TO RECOGNIZE THE FLOOR
TEAM. FOR ALL OF THEIR HARD
WORK FIRST OF COURSE. WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE BEST IN THE
BUSINESS MISTER KEVIN MULLIN.
FOR PRESIDING. NEXT I WANT TO
THANK OUR ASSISTANT PRO TEM
REBEKAH BAUER QUE HAN WHO TOOK
NO TIME AT ALL. FILLING IN AND
DOING AN AMAZING JOB THANK YOU
SO MUCH. NEXT I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE OUR MAJORITY WHIP WHO
DOES A GOOD JOB OF MAKING SURE
EVERYBODY GETS THE FLOOR AND
TIMELY MANNER AND GETTING THESE
VOTES. MAKE SURE WE GET THESE
VOTES DONE IN AND BILLS OFF THE
FLOOR MISTER TODD GLORIA. WE
ALSO HAVE OUR ASSISTANT
MAJORITY WHIP TO WORK REALLY
HARD MAKING SURE ALL OF YOUR
GET HERE MAKING CALLS OR
OFFICES AND MAKE SURE BUSINESS
FLOWS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER JESSE
GABRIEL. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
POSSIBLE KNOW MORE ABOUT.
MEMBERS I JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CALL COOPERATION
SOMETIMES THINGS GET A LITTLE
BIT CRAZY BUT YOU GUYS ARE
ALWAYS THERE MAKING SURE THAT
THE PEOPLE'S HOUSES RUNNING
SMOOTHLY UNDERSTANDING THAT
WHAT WE DO HERE IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AND THAT TO QUORUM IS
ALWAYS MAINTAIN ON THE FLOOR
FOR THAT I APPRECIATE YOU.
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH. MISS WALDRON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND IT'S A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE TO SERVE
HERE IN THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE AND
AS WE CLOSE OUT THIS SESSION I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
RECOGNIZE OBVIOUSLY THE GREAT
TEAM BEHIND ME HERE ARE CLERK'S
OFFICE AS WELL AS THE
SERGEANTS. AND THE PEOPLE WILL
MAKE HIS HOUSE HOUSE WORK FOR
US IN ADDITION OUR FLOOR TEAM
WORKS ON HARD AND DILIGENTLY TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR CAUCUSES ON
TOP OF THINGS AND HEATH. FLORA
IS OUR FLOOR LEADER AND LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE. WORK THAT HE DOES AS
WELL AS OUR CHIEF WHIP OVER
THERE FILL CHEN. AND DEVON
MATHIS OR WHIP WHO ROUNDS OUT
OF WORKING ALL THE TIME TO MAKE
SURE WE GET IT ACCURATE COUNT
ON WHERE WE ARE. AND OUR FLOOR
TEAM IN THE BACK WE HAVE FULL
DRESS GREAT MORAL PONY IN THEM.
MEMBERS OF FLORENCE BACK THERE
WHO WORKING ALL THE TIME BEHIND
THE SCENES AND HOW MUCH THEY
WORK WITH THE DEMOCRATS FLOOR
TEAM. WE REALLY DO WORK IN
UNISON AND WORK TO GET THINGS
DONE AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
FLOW OF THE HOUSE. REALLY WORKS
FOR US. COULDN'T DO WITHOUT THE
SPEAKER I REALLY APPRECIATE OUR
RELATIONSHIP AND THE WORK WE'VE
DONE TOGETHER. DURING THE
SESSION. I REALLY WISH EVERYONE
A GREAT BREAK. AND THAT THEY
GET A LOT OF WORK DONE IN THE
DISTRICT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS WALDRON. AND MISTER
SPEAKER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS IT THAT NOTE NO TIME
FOR LONG SPEECHES BUT I TO
WANNA ADD MY THANKS WE HAVE.
SENT THE GOVERNOR A NUMBER OF
BILLS. THAT WILL HAVE A LASTING
IMPACT FOR CALIFORNIA. AND IN
SOME CASES WERE A LONG TIME
COMING. FOR BEING SO PRODUCTIVE
I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
MEMBERS. I ALSO WANT TO THANK
MY FRIEND SENATE SENATE PRO TEM
TONI ATKINS. I HAVEN'T ALWAYS
BEEN ABLE TO CALL THE SENATE
PROTON MY FRIEND BUT NOW I CAN.
I ALSO WANT TO TAKE THE
GOVERNOR GAVIN GAVIN NEWSOM AND
HIS TEAM. I WANT TO REITERATE
HOWEVER THAT IT IS THE MEMBERS
OF THIS ASSEMBLY ALL EIGHTY
MEMBERS THROUGHOUT THE YEAR
SEVEN NINE NUMBERS NOW. WHO
HAVE MADE THIS AN EXTRAORDINARY
YEAR SO THANK YOU. NEVER THE
LESS THERE IS A LOT TO BE DONE
NOT JUST LET US NOT JUST
LEGISLATIVE. BUT WE MUST NOT
FORGET EVER. THAT IT IS OUR
COMMITMENT TO CHANGING THE
CULTURE OF THE LEGISLATURE SO
THAT EVERY PERSON I FEEL SAFE
HERE THAT IS AN ONGOING GOAL.
WITH THAT I TO WANT TO MAKE
MAKE NOTE AND SPECIAL THANKS TO
THE ASSEMBLY SERGEANTS. AND TO
SEE HP WHO'VE WORKED FOR SAFETY
IN ORDER NOT JUST AREN'T UNDER
TODAY'S TRYING CIRCUMSTANCES
ESPECIALLY UNDER TODAY'S TRYING
CIRCUMSTANCES. BUT EVERY DAY
THANK YOU TO THE CHP IN THE
SERGEANTS. I ALSO WANT TO THINK
THE RULES COMMITTEE FOR UNTOLD
LABORS BEHIND THE SCENES I WANT
TO THANK THE STAFF TELEVISING
THE ASSEMBLY AND ALL OF ITS
COMMITTEES THE FACILITIES STAFF
THAT KEEPS THIS BUILDING IN
GOOD SHAPE THAT ARE HERE RIGHT
AWAY AFTER WE LEAVE THANK YOU
TO THE FACILITY STAFF. I WANT
TO THINK LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL
FOR TURNING WISHES INTO CODE
SECTIONS I WANT TO THANK
REVEREND REVEREND BOB AND PATTY
OSHA. FOR THEIR PEACEFUL VISION
FOR SENDING US INTO EACH
SESSION. I PARTICULAR THANKS TO
SENATE PRO TEM KEVIN MULLIN FOR
IS UNFLAPPABLE ABILITY TO RUN
SESSION SMOOTHLY. AND ADD HUMOR
WHATEVER NEEDED THANK YOU KEVIN.
THANKS TO OUR MAJORITY LEADER
IAN CALDERON HIS BUSINESS WHOSE
PRE SESSION SESSIONS SET THE
STAGE FOR WHAT WE DO ON THE
FLOOR HE IS OUR STAGE MANAGER
AND HE MADE SURE THAT WE PUT
OUR BEST FOOT FORWARD. THANK
YOU IAN. I'VE HAD THE PLEASURE
OF SERVING NOW WITH THREE
REPUBLICAN LEADERS I WANT TO
THANK REPUBLICAN LEADER MARIE
WALDRON FOR FRIENDSHIP. FOR HER
STEADY AND THOUGHTFUL
LEADERSHIP THANK YOU MARIE. I
WANT TO THINK THE REPUBLICAN
FLOOR MANAGER HEATH FLORA FOR
STUDY WORK IN AND FAILING
PRESENCE THANK YOU HE. IN A TWO
ONE A THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
REBEKAH AMERICAN A HAND AND
TODD GLORIA FOR TAKING UP THE
GAVEL AND BREAKING THE GAVEL.
WHENEVER ASKED THANK YOU TODD
THANK YOU REBEKAH. AND I WANNA
THINK MY FLOOR STAFF ASSIST
ESPECIALLY BRIAN EBERT AND
BRANDON SAFECO WHO ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR KEEPING
LEGISLATIVE TRACKS CLEAN AND
FREE OF OBSTACLES THANK YOU.
AND OF COURSE ALL OF OUR STAFF
THE STAFF OF ALL ALL OF OUR
MEMBERS NOT ONLY A MEMBER
OFFICES IN MY OFFICES AND
COMMITTEE OFFICES AND DISTRICT
OFFICES. UP AND DOWN THE STATE
IN THE OFFICES OF THE
DEMOCRATIC AND REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS. THOSE PEOPLE HAVE IT
EQUALLY ESSENTIAL TO ALL OF OUR
SUCCESS THIS YEAR THANK YOU TO
THOSE FOLKS. FINALLY OF COURSE
WE MUST ALL THINK THE STAFF TO
WORK BRILLIANTLY UNDER THE
LEADERSHIP OF OUR CHIEF. CLERK
HE DOTSON WILSON. DOTSON THANK
YOU I SEE YOU THANK YOU
DOESN'T. WHEN THIS BODY
RECONVENES IN JANUARY YOU WILL
BE THE MISS MISSING PIECE. FROM
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO WE'LL
MISS YOU THANK YOU DOCTOR. I
WILL SEE THE REST OF YOU BACK
JANUARY SIX TO MARK YOUR
CALENDARS JANUARY SIXTH TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. GET SOME REST
HAVE A GOOD RECESS. CONTINUE TO
DO ALL OF THE GOOD WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE HERE DO THAT WORK
IN THE DISTRICT THANK YOU FOR
EVERYTHING THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER WE STILL HAVE
BUSINESS BEFORE THE HOUSE SINCE
I HAVE THE MICROPHONE AT THE
MOMENT I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
MY- FLOOR STAFFER LORE
FITZGERALD WHO DID AN
INCREDIBLE JOB THIS YEAR
PULLING US ALL TOGETHER. AND
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AND AGAIN IT'S LATE
AND I BLAME THE SENATE BUT I.
ALSO NEED. TO THANK OUR
MAJORITY ASSISTANT MAJORITY
LEADER MISTER ROB BONTA FOR
EVERYTHING ANYTHING THAT HE
DOES KEEP IN THIS BODY RIGHT. I
AND ALSO I JUST WANTED TO KNOW
A LOT OF WORK GOES IN SO WHEN
EVERYBODY WE NEED TO FLOOR
MANAGERS FOR BILLS ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR WE NEED FOR
MANAGERS FOR SENATE BILLS ON
OUR FLOOR SOMEBODY WENT AND
REACHED OUT TO EVERY SINGLE
OFFICE. MY CHIEF OF STAFF TOM
WHITE DOES A LOT. THANK YOU TOM.
DON'T GO ANYWHERE MEMBERS. WE
STILL HAVE A COUPLE OF ITEMS
BEFORE THE BODY
. CURRENTLY.
WELL MAYBE
. MEMBERS. ONE FINAL
THANK YOU. MEMBERS WHO WANT TO
RECOGNIZE MY RETURN ARE ON THE
SPEAKERS FLOOR TEAM FOR HER
HARD WORK ON CEREMONIES IN GAS
SHE HELPS US DO OUR BUSINESS ON
THIS WAR. THANK YOU MADAM
.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL. ON SENATOR WINNERS
BILL S. B. FIFTY EIGHT THE
CARPOOL POST. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. YEAH
. MR
SANTIAGO MOVES A CALL. REPLACES
A CALL
. MEMBERS I PREPARED TO
LIFT THE CALL ON FILE ITEM.
ELEVEN AB ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT I
MISTER GALLAGHER CLERK OR POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRABLE. ALL
MEMBERS OF A RESERVE A
. REPLACE
THE CALL. MEMBERS I AM GOING TO
LIFT THE CALL AGAIN ON SB FIFTY
EIGHT CARGO POST. CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE. TALLY THE VOTE AYE
AYES TWENTY NINE KNOWS THIRTY
FOUR THAT MEASURE FAILS. MR
SANTIAGO NOTICES
RECONSIDERATION
. MEMBERS I AM
PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL ON.
AB ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT CARPOOL
POSTS. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO'S
OUT OF A
. THE CLERK WILL CLOSER
ALL TALLY THE VOTE I WAS THIRTY
SIX KNOWS TWELVE THAT MEASURE
FAILS AND MISTER GALLAGHER
NOTICES RECONSIDERATION. THIS
IS WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE.
AB. FORTY EIGHT. CLICK AWAY.
ASSEMBLY WILL FORTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL AND
OTHERS AND I PLAN TO EDUCATION
FINANCE BY PROVIDING THE FUNDS
NECESSARY THERE FOR THROUGH AN
ELECTION FOR THE ISSUANCE AND
THE SALE OF BONDS OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA FOR THE HANDLING
AND THE DISPOSITION OF THESE
FUNDS. MR O'DONNELL. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB FORTY PLACES
A FIFTEEN BILLION DOLLAR
PRESCHOOL. THROUGH HIGHER
EDUCATION BOND ON THE MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY BALLOT. LET ME GO
OVER WHAT IS IN THE BOND NINE
BILLION FOR PRESCHOOL THROUGH
TWELFTH GRADE THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME PRESCHOOL EARLY EDUCATION
WILL BE ELIGIBLE. TO RECEIVE
STATE BOND MONEY SO THAT'S A
GOOD THING TWO BILLION FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TO BILLION FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM AND TWO
BILLION FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. UP FOR A PRE K.
THROUGH TWELFTH GRADE INCREASES
THE STATE GRANT AMOUNT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WILL GET MORE MONEY
THAN THEY PREVIOUSLY DID. FOR
THE FIRST TIME SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WILL BE ALLOWED TO USE STATE
BOND DOLLARS FOR PRESCHOOL
CLASSROOMS. DISASTER ASSISTANCE
TO HELP SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AFFECTED BY NATURAL DISASTERS
SUCH AS MANY FIRES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
OTHER TRAGIC EVENTS. FUNDS TO
TEST ELIMINATE A LEAD IN THE
DRINKING WATER. A PROCESS TO
HELP SMALLER SCHOOL DISTRICTS
APPLY FOR AN ACCESS STATE BOND
FUNDS WE CAN BE A VERY
TECHNICAL PROGRAM SO THERE IS
HELP FOR THAT INCREASE FUNDS
FOR ENERGY EFFICIENCY PROJECTS
INCREASE FUNDS TO HELP REPLACE
SCHOOLS OLDER. THAN FIFTY YEARS
OLD. IT ALLOWS SCHOOLS ON A
MILITARY BASE ST PLACE
PORTABLES AND BE ABLE TO ACCESS
FEDERAL FUNDS. TECHNICAL
EDUCATION FACILITIES TO REPAIR
OUR STUDENTS FOR CAREERS AND
THERE IS MONEY FOR CHARTER
SCHOOLS. ON THE HIGHER
EDUCATION SIDE THE BILL
PRIORITIZES FUNDING FOR THE UC
AND CSU PROJECTS THAT ADDRESSES
FIRE. AND LIFE SAFETY SEISMIC
AND CRITICAL DEFERRED MEIJIN
MAKE MAINTENANCE ISSUES AND
REQUIRES UC AND CSU TO ADOPT A
FIVE YEAR AFFORDABLE STUDENT
HOUSING PLAN. MEMBERS OF OVER
THIS BILL IS A VOTE TO INSURE
THAT WE HAVE EARLY EDUCATION
FACILITIES ACROSS OUR STATE A
VOTE FOR THIS BILL IS A VOTE TO
GET GET RID OF MOLD ASBESTOS
LEAD IN OUR STUDENTS DRINKING
WATER FOUNTAINS AND ENSURE THAT
OUR SCHOOLS WILL STAND. AN
EARTHQUAKE. A VOTE FOR THIS
BILL IS A VOTE TO PROVIDE OUR
CLASSROOMS WITH ADEQUATE
HEATING AND AIR CONDITIONING
AND ACCESS TO BROADBAND AND
TECHNOLOGY. A VOTE FOR THIS
BILL IS TO ENSURE THAT WE DON'T
HAVE OVERCROWDED CLASSROOMS AND
SCHOOLS. A VOTE FOR THIS BILL
IS TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
VOCATIONAL CLASS CLASSROOMS IT
WILL VERIS UNITS FOR THE JOBS
OF THE FUTURE. AS WELL AS
HIGHER EDUCATION. THE CONDITION
OF OUR SCHOOLS SET THE TONE FOR
THE SCHOOL DAY I CAN ASSURE YOU
OF THAT. LET'S GIVE VOTERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT FUNDS
FOR SAFE AND CLEAN SCHOOLS
CONDUCIVE TO LEARNING. OUR
STUDENT SUCCESS DEPENDS ON I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE MISTER
SPEAKER. MR MCCARTY HERE
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I KNOW THE HOUR IS LATE
THE MORNING IS EARLY ACTUALLY
YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT TO
SUPPORT IN THIS MEASURE WE KNOW
THERE IS THE DOCUMENT IN NEED.
IN OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM
FOCUS ON OUR FACILITIES FRANKLY
FUNDING OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM FROM PRESCHOOL THROUGH
HIGHER EDUCATION BUT THIS IS OF
COURSE THE FACILITIES BOND. IN
OUR OWN DISTRICTS WE SEE OUR
HIGH SCHOOLS ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE IS. THE
TRUE DOCUMENT IN NEED SO WE GET
THAT. BUT I DO HAVE SOME
SERIOUS MISGIVINGS ABOUT THIS
FOR ONE FOR ONE MAJOR ISSUE.
THERE IS. A GLARING OMISSION
HERE THE IT'S SOMEWHAT IRONIC
BECAUSE THIS MEASURE IS THE PRE
SCHOOL K. TWELVE. AND HIGHER
EDUCATION BOND BUT THERE IS NO
SET ASIDE. FOR PRESCHOOL. THERE
IS OF COURSE A AN OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE AN ELIGIBILITY FOR THE
NINE BILLION BUT SET ASIDES
MATTER THAT'S WELL AS A SET
ASIDE FOR YOU SEE. FOR THE
COMMUNICABLE **** FOR THE CSU
FOR CAREER TACK FOR CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND SO FORTH SO. THERE
THERE WILL BE PERMISSIVE
LANGUAGE PERMISSIVE LANGUAGE
WHICH IS HELPFUL BUT AS WE'VE
HEARD FROM OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THIS WEEK. THERE ARE SO MANY
NEEDS TODAY TO MODERNIZE OUR
CLASSROOMS TO DEAL WITH THAT
DID THE CURRENT NEEDS IF YOU'RE
A SCHOOL BOARD YOUR YOUR
POPULATION YOU SERVE. OUR
STUDENTS FROM KINDERGARTEN
THROUGH TWELFTH GRADE YOU'RE
NOT NECESSARILY SERVING
PRESCHOOL THAT'S NOT YOUR
CONSTITUENCY THAT SOMETIMES
UNFORTUNATELY. A LUXURY SO ONCE
AGAIN. UNFORTUNATELY PRESCHOOLS
GONNA GET A LEFT BEHIND WHICH
IS WHY IT'S IMPORTANT TO FOCUS
ON A SOUND INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA GOING FORWARD FOR
OUR YOUNGEST LEARNERS. AND WHY
THIS MATTER WE YOU KNOW WE GET
IT WE KNOW THAT PRESCHOOLS
APPROVING DIFFERENCE MAKER. THE
RESEARCH IS CLAIRE IF YOU WANT
MORE KIDS IN COLLEGE AND
SUCCEEDING WANT MORE KIDS
GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL. READY TO
BURKE COLLEGE AND CAREER WE
NEED MORE KIDS IN PRESCHOOL AND
WE NEED MORE CLASSROOMS AND
JUST TO PUT A LITTLE BIT OF
CONTEXT TO THIS THE LAST FEW
YEARS WE'VE STEPPED UP TO
EXPAND PRESCHOOL ACCESS IN
CALIFORNIA. WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT EXPANDING PRESCHOOL IT'S
REALLY TWO THINGS IT'S A IT'S
THAT WILL ACTUALLY THREE I'M
SORRY IT'S EXPANDING SLOTS. BUT
IN ORDER TO FILL SLOTS TO WORK
YOU NEED TWO THINGS YOU NEED
ADEQUATE RATES AND YOU NEED.
FACILITIES SO WE HAVE INCREASE
THE RATES BUT WE'VE HEARD TIME
AND TIME AGAIN SCHOOL DISTRICTS
SAY. THEY CAN'T FILL THE SLOT
BECAUSE THEY NEED FACILITIES SO
IT'S LIKE A KIND OF A CATCH
TWENTY TWO YEAR WHICH IS WHY
THIS ISSUE. IS SO IMPORTANT SO
THIS MEASURE IS. IS
UNFORTUNATELY. INCOMPLETE AND
I'M VERY CONFLICTED TONIGHT
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK THAT.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WE CARE SO
MUCH OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION CARE
SO MUCH ABOUT HER SCHOOL
CHILDREN BUT WE'RE NOT STANDING
UP FOR THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLDS
IN CALIFORNIA WHEN IT COMES TO
EXPANDING ACCESS AND FACILITIES
SO. YOU KNOW AS AS AS AS
MEASURE A PASSES AND GOES
BEFORE THE VOTERS IN MARCH YOU
KNOW I SUPPORT ALL THESE PIECES
IN THERE AND SO THAT'S WHY IT
IS CONFLICTING BECAUSE I
REALIZE THERE IS SO MUCH
POSITIVE HERE BUT WE DO HAVE
UNFINISHED BUSINESS WHEN IT
COMES TO FACILITIES FOR PUBLIC
PRESCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA AT OUR
L. AT R. ELLIE ACE. I AM
PLEASED WITH THE TALKS THAT
WE'VE HAD ALL DAY TODAY AND ALL
WEEK WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
WHERE MY FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE
FROM OUR BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
FROM COLTON IS GOING TO OUTLINE
A FEW MOMENTS AND I'M CERTAIN
THAT WOULD LEADERSHIP OF OUR
SPEAKER. AND WITH OUR BUDGET
SHARE AND I KNOW ALL BE WORKING
AS CHAIR THE BUDGET SUB TO
COMMITTEE THAT WILL MAKE A
PRIORITY OF ONE TIME
INVESTMENTS FIRST PRE SCHOOL
FACILITIES AS WE RECONVENE IN
JANUARY AND TALK ABOUT OUR.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. THEY REST
REGARDING MS RACE. YEAH DON'T
MAKE IT OUT OF THE. MR DOLLAR
YOU CAN ADDRESS ISSUES IN YOUR
CLOTHES MITHRAS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. I
WANT TO THANK BY MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SACRAMENTO FOR ALL THE
HARD WORK THAT WAS PUT INTO
THIS. THERE'S GREAT DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE HAVE A
MISNOMER AS WAS NOTED EARLIER.
THIS IS AN EDUCATION BOND. THAT
IS CALLED PRE K. K. THROUGH
TWELVE AND HIGHER EDUCATION.
YET THERE WAS NO MONEY SET
ASIDE FOR PRE K. THERE'S
PROGRESSIVE YEARS FOR PRE K.
BUT THERE WAS NO MONEY SET
ASIDE FOR PRE K. I WANT TO
THANK. THE FORTY THREE FORTY
FOUR FORTY THREE MEMBERS WHO
AGREED. THAT PRE K. NEEDED TO
BE ADDRESSED. AND THERE HAD TO
BE FUNDING FOR FACILITIES FOR
PRE K. BECAUSE IT YOU GAVE US
THE POWER. AND YOU GAVE US THE
INSTRUCTION TO ENGAGE WITH THE
GROUP WITH THE GOVERNOR. TO
KNOW WHAT WE HAD FOR THE FUTURE.
I WANT TO THANK THE SPEAKER'S
OFFICE ON THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
FOR SPENDING THE TIME. THE
HOURS TO DISCUSS HOW WE CAN
BEST. DEAL WITH THIS IN THE
FUTURE. I WANT TO SHARE THE
LANGUAGE THE WE HAVE AGREED
UPON. PRE K. AND FUNDING PRE
SCHOOL FACILITIES ARE SHARED HI
PRIORITIES OF THE GOVERNOR. THE
SPEAKER AND THE LEGISLATURE.
WITH THE GOVERNOR WE HAVE A
FIRM COMMITMENT FROM HIM TO
ADDRESS THESE PRIORITIES AND TO
WORK TOGETHER TO GET. THERE AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN AFFORD. WE
ALSO AGREE THAT FUNDING
FACILITIES AND WORK FORCE NEEDS
ARE A PRECONDITION OF UNIVERSAL
PRESCHOOL. MEMBERS WITH THE
LEVEL OF THE GOVERNOR'S
DEMONSTRATED COMMITMENT TO
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION. AND
WITH A COMMITMENT FROM OUR
SPEAKER WHO HAS BEEN A CHAMPION
FOR EARLY CHILDHOOD. EDUCATION.
I THINK WE CAN SAFELY EXPECT
THAT THE GOVERNOR. WILL LEAD
THE EFFORT TO FUND THE PRE
SCHOOL FACILITIES THAT ARE
MISSING FROM THIS PARTICULAR
BOND. THANK YOU. MR OBERNOLTE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO
AB FORTY EIGHT THIS MEASURE
WOULD AUTHORIZE THE ISSUANCE OF
FIFTEEN BILLION DOLLARS OF
BONDS TO FUND SCHOOL FACILITY%
CONSTRUCTION I AM VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF SCHOOL FACILITY
CONSTRUCTION I THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE THE STATE SHOULD
FUNDED. THE ONLY PROBLEM I HAVE
WITH FIFTEEN BILLION AS I DON'T
THINK IT'S HIGH ENOUGH I WHICH
WAS MORE BUT MY PROBLEM WITH
THIS BILL IS THIS. WE'RE
ISSUING FIFTEEN BILLION DOLLARS
OF BONDS IN A YEAR WHEN WE HAVE
A TWENTY ONE BILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET SURPLUS. TO PUT THAT IN
CONTEXT IT'S LIKE A FAMILY HAS
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE
BANK THEY WANT TO TAKE A
THOUSAND DOLLAR VACATION BUT
INSTEAD OF USING THE MONEY THAT
THEY PUT IN THE BANK. THEY
CHARGE THE VACATION ON THEIR
HIGH INTEREST CREDIT CARD THAT
MAKES NO SENSE. CURRENTLY THE
STATE HAS ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS OF
LONG TERM BOND DEBT. SO BY
AUTHORIZING THIS WE'RE GOING TO
ADD ABOUT TEN PERCENT. DOOR
STATES OVERALL DEBT AT THAT IS
SIGNIFICANT. NOW THAT IS IN A
YEAR. WHEN DEBT SERVICE IS ONE
OF THE FASTEST GROWING
OBLIGATIONS FROM THE GENERAL
FUND. NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE A
BUDGET SURPLUS THIS YEAR.
ECONOMIC TIMES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN RELATIVELY
GOOD SO THAT'S THE LAST THING
THAT YOU WANT TO DO WHEN TIMES
ARE GOOD IS TO ADD TO THE DEBT
IN FACT WHAT YOU WANT TO DO IS
THE OPPOSITE WHEN TIMES ARE
GOOD YOU WANT TO PAY DOWN. THAT
LONG TERM DEBT. PUT LESS COST
PRESSURE ON THE GENERAL FUND
LEADER IN YEARS WHEN TIMES ARE
NOT SO GOOD. AND I THINK THE
WORST PROBLEM WITH THIS MEASURE
IS THIS WE KNOW THAT WHEN WE
BORROW MONEY. WE FINANCE A BOND
OVER TWENTY YEARS IT ACTUALLY
COSTS US TWO DOLLARS TO PAY
BACK THAT MONEY FOR EVERY
DOLLAR THAT WE BORROWED. SO TO
PUT THAT A DIFFERENT WAY IF WE
INSTEAD DECIDED TODAY. WE WERE
GOING TO TAKE THAT ONE AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLARS THAT IS
GOING TO A YEAR THAT IS GOING
TO TAKE TO SERVICE THAT BOND.
OVER THE NEXT TWENTY YEARS AND
SPEND THAT MONEY. ON THE
CONSTRUCTION OF EDUCATIONAL
FACILITIES WE COULD BUILD TWICE
AS MANY SCHOOLS TWICE AS MANY
PRESCHOOLS TWICE AS MANY
COLLEGES. THAT'S A MUCH BETTER
WAY OF GOING ABOUT THIS THAN TO
PUT THE STATE FURTHER IN DEBT I
ORIGINAL VOTE. MR STONE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER A MEMBERS. THIS HOUSE
HAS HAD A LONG STANDING
COMMITMENT TO EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION. THIS GOVERNOR
CAMPAIGNED ON EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION AND I KNOW THAT
PRESCHOOL IS PERMISSIVE IN THIS
BONDS. BUT RECOGNIZE WE HAVE
STARVED SCHOOL DISTRICTS FOR
YEARS. OF FACILITIES MONEY AND
THEY HAVE LOTS OF NEEDS OF
THOSE NEEDS ARE GOING TO BE MET
FIRST ANY SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER
WILL TELL YOU THAT. PLUS WE
HAVE NOT FUNDED THE RATES FOR
PRESCHOOL AT LEVELS THAT ALLOW
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO REALLY BE
ABLE TO FUND THESE PROGRAMS AT
APPROPRIATE LEVELS AT LEVELS
THAT WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO DO.
SO WITHOUT THE RATES WITHOUT
THE MONEY GOING IN AND WITH THE
HIGH FACILITIES NEEDS THAT THEY
HAVE IT IS UNLIKELY THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WILL BE APPLYING FOR
THIS MONEY FOR PRESCHOOL. SO IF
WE PUT IT IN THERE. AS
PERMISSIVE IT'S NOT GOING TO
HAVE THAT EFFECT. IF WE CAN PUT
SOME MONEY SET ASIDE SPECIFIC
FOR PRESCHOOL THAT SHOULD
HOPEFULLY IF WE CAN ALSO
ADDRESS THE RATES ISSUE. SIGNAL
THAT WE'RE VERY SERIOUS ABOUT
DOING PRESCHOOL. SO I'M
STRUGGLING WITH THIS LOVE THE
MONEY FOR HIGHER AT. LOVE MONEY
FINALLY FOR THAT K. FOURTEEN
SYSTEM. BUT IF WERE SERIOUS
ABOUT PRESCHOOL WE HAVE TO NOW
WE HAVE THE HOUSE IF THIS BILL
PASSES. AND WE PUT THIS ONE
MEASURE FORWARD IS GOING TO BE
INCUMBENT ON US TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR BUDGET PRIORITIES
REFLECT. OUR RHETORIC AND WHAT
WE TALK ABOUT WITH RESPECT TO
PRESCHOOL. THE GOVERNOR HAS
GIVEN US. REALLY NOTHING MORE
THAN THE SHADOW OF A COMMITMENT
SO THROUGH THIS FALL AND IN OUR
BUDGET CONVERSATIONS WE HAVE TO
MAKE THAT COMMITMENT CLEAR. ON
OUR BEHALF AND ON THE
GOVERNOR'S WE HAVE AND WITH THE
SENATE SO THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE
WE REALLY MOVE TOWARDS EVERY
WHAT EVERYBODY TALKS ABOUT IS
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL BUT PUTTING
THE RATES IN PLACE AND PUTTING
THE FACILITIES IN PLACE. THAT
WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT THIS
HAPPENS. MR MEDINA YOUR RECORD
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. IT'S BEEN SIX YEARS
SINCE WE'VE HAD A HIGHER
EDUCATION BOND ON THE BALLOT
IT'S PAST TIME THAT WE HAVE A
EDUCATION BOND I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON A. B. FORTY EIGHT.
I BELIEVE THAT'S APPLAUSE FOR
BREVITY. THANK YOU MISTER
MEDINA FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
SEEING. NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION MISTER SPEAKER. YOUR
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS MEMBERS I RISE
ONCE MORE TO ASK YOUR SUPPORT
FOR A BI FORTY EIGHT THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT UPDATING THE
QUALITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
EDUCATIONAL FACILITIES IS A
WORTHY CAUSE THERE'S NO
QUESTION IN MY MIND THAT THE
VOTERS WILL BACK THAT UP WITH
VOTES FOR A BOND THE DETAILS OF
THIS BOND MEASURE HAVE BEEN
HAMMERED OUT BY THE MEMBERSOF
BOTH HOUSES AND WILL HELP
CHILDREN AT EVERY LEVEL SPECIAL
THANKS TO OUR EDUCATION CHAIR
FOR HIS WORK ON THIS BILL. IT
INCLUDES FUNDS DIRECTLY TO
SCHOOLS FOR NEEDED FACILITIES
AND ASSISTANCE TO SCHOOLS THAT
ARE SMALLER HAVE FINANCIAL
HARDSHIPS AT THE HIGHER
EDUCATION LEVEL THERE'S A FOCUS
ON FUNDING FOR SAFETY FOR
SAFETY PROJECTS LIKE FIRE
EARTHQUAKE AND MAINTENANCE WITH
INCENTIVES FOR INSTITUTIONS TO
PROVIDE ATTENTION TO AFFORDABLE
STUDENT HOW TO HOUSING AND AT
THE BOTTOM THERE IS FINANCIAL
ACCOUNTABILITY. RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR I VOTE FOR A. B. FORTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
AND FINALLY SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR OTHER MEMBER SEE
RECOGNITION MISTER O'DONNELL
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I JUST I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THE MEMBERS
UNDERSTAND THERE IS NINE
BILLION DOLLARS IN HERE FOR PRE
K. THROUGH TWELFTH GRADE A NINE
BILLION DOLLARS OKAY IF YOU
CAPITA. IF YOU CAP THE
PRESCHOOL ALLOCATIONS COULD BE
A MUCH LOWER RATES OF THE AGAIN
UP TO NINE BILLION DOLLARS HERE
TO USE FOR PRE SCHOOLS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA ASKS FOR AN AYE VOTE.
QUIRK LIBERAL. DESIRE TO VOTE
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR. ALL
MEMBERS OF A RESERVE A. CLARK
WELL. CLOSER ALL TALLY THE VOTE
EYES SEVENTY SIX. KNOWS ONE.
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. WE HAVE A CONSENT CALENDAR.
IS A MEMBER WHICH YOU'RE MOVING
OUT OF FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SEEING HEARING ON THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND EXAM
CALENDAR SOMETHING RESOLUTION
ONE TWENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO EMPLOYMENT. LOCAL
OVER THE ROLE ON THE CONSENT
CAN. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. PARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SEVENTY
FOUR. NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED. CLICK WITH
THE REMAINING ITEMS ASSEMBLY
RESOLUTION ONE OH SEVEN I
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO SOMETHING
CURRENT VERSION ONCE WHILE I
SEVENTY FOUR OH ZERO SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
NINETEEN HI SEVENTY FOUR NO
ZERO ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE TWENTY I SEVENTY
FOUR NO ZERO SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE TWENTY FOUR HI
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO.
RESOLUTION. ONE TWENTY SEVEN I
SEVENTY. FOUR NO ZERO. ONE
TWENTY EIGHT. FOR THE SENATE TO
DO THE SAME. WAS REQUIRES A
SECOND SECONDED BY MISTER BONTA.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION AND
MISTER CALDERON MOTION SINGING
HEARING NO OBJECTION THE MOTION
CARRIES IT HAS BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED THAT THE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY REGULAR SESSION
FOR THE INTERIM RECESS UNTIL
MONDAY JANUARY SIXTH TWENTY
TWENTY AND THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED